GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME YOU ALL TO THE SENATE.
MILLION BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY.
STAY HERE TOTAL OF TWENTY ONE
BILLS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY THREE
OF THEM ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
ITEM SIX SEVEN AND TWENTY ONE I
WOULD LIKE TO WELL AS I SENT LET
US NOW.
AND WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT.
FIRST UP THOUGH IS ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB THREE FIFTEEN HERTZBERG
BEFORE WE GO TO CENTER HERTZBERG.
I DO NOT THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SO WE'RE NOT GONNA FISCHLI BEGAN
AS A COMMITTEE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THAT'S THAT MEETS THE BE
OKAY WITH SENATOR HERTZBERG WE
CAN BEGIN.
ABSOLUTELY SIR WELCOME
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE PRESIDENT'S AND THE CONGRESS.
PASSED A BILL IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CALLED THE TAX CUTS
AND JOBS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHICH HAS.
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE IMPACT OF US
IN FOUR OF US FILING A TAX
RETURNS JUST RECENTLY IF WE DID
THEM ON APRIL FIFTEENTH.
AS RELATED TO SOLVE DEDUCTIONS.
ONE OF THE OTHER ASPECTS OF THAT
MEASURE HAS DO WITH CREATING
WHAT WAS CALLED OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS.
SOMETHING THAT WAS INSPIRED BY.
SENATOR FROM NEW JERSEY -- CORY
BOOKER.
AND SEAN PARKER.
WERE KIND OF THE INSPIRATION
BEHIND THIS AND THE NOTION IS.
ON LIKE IN THE AREA OF PROPERTY
TAX WHICH ARE -- WE CREATED THE
C. R. A.'S COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES THE GOVERNOR BROWN
ELIMINATED.
HE DID THAT IN MY JUDGMENT. FOR
THREE BASIC REASONS WHY TAKING
DOLLARS AWAY FOR THESE IS ARE
THESE AREAS -- THAT NEEDED TO BE
DEVELOPED.
AND USING PROPERTY TAX THE
INCOME AND PROPERTY TAX HE WAS
IMPACTING SCHOOLS WHERE YOU TAKE
MONEY AWAY FROM SCHOOLS BECAUSE
THE INCOME IT WAS USED FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT.
TO USE TAKING MONEY IN THE
COUNTY LEVEL AWAY FROM SOCIAL
SERVICES AND THREE ARM THERE
WERE ISSUES THAT HE CERTAINLY
SAW HIS IN HIS MUNICIPAL
EXPERIENCE.
DEALING WITH DEVELOPERS THE
DIDN'T EXCITE HIM AND SO NOW WE
HAVE THESE OPPORTUNITIES OWNS IT
INSTEAD OF USING PROPERTY TAX.
UTILIZED INCOME TAX AND SO WE
DON'T HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
CAPITAL GAINS AND THIS IS A WAY
WHERE IN BROADLY SPEAKING.
ARE INVESTORS WHO HAVE A CAPITAL
GAIN CAN TAKE THEIR LIABILITY
AND INVESTED IN OPPORTUNITIES ON
THE EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE SUCH ZONES DESIGNATED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY CAN INVESTIN THOSE
LOANS.
ARE ON AND GET A TAX DEFERRAL IF
WITH THE INVESTMENT LAST FOR TEN
YEARS GETS A STEPPED UP BASIS IN
THE IN THE MEASURE WHAT WE'VE
DONE HERE IN THIS BILL.
IN BEFORE YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR
TALKED ABOUT CONFORMITY
LEGISLATION WITH RESPECT
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS BUT ONE OF
THE BIG ISSUES.
AND READ AS WRITTEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE APPARENTLY
DURING THE OF MARK UP PROCESS
THEY COULDN'T GET THIS IN.
WAS TO HAVE A REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THESE INVESTMENTS LOOK LIKE
WHERE THEY GOING ARE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY ACHIEVING THESE
DELIVERABLES VERSES.
YEARS MONEY OPPORTUNITIES OWN IT
I'M BUYING A HIGH RISE BUILDING
OR WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE BUT
IF IT'S IN THE ZONE IT QUALIFIES
AND SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS TO GATHER DATA -- THIS
REPORTING PROCESS THAT WILL
TRACK THE INVESTMENT INTENTIONS
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT THE
IMPACT MEASURES AND REPORTING
THE INVESTMENT THESIS REPORTING
THE LAST COMMITTEE REPORT.
UP ON END GIVES TRANSPARENCY FOR
THE UNDERLYING ARCHITECTURE AND
IDEAS I MEAN THE THE VALUES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHICH ARE
COMMITTEE ENGAGEMENT EQUITY
TRANSPARENCY.
MEASUREMENT AND OUTCOMES SO WE
THINK THAT -- IN TERMS OF
CONFORMING AND IF WE'RE GOING TO
ADOPT THESE OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
IF IN FACT THERE DOCTOR WHATEVER
CIRCUMSTANCE THE GOVERNOR
CHOOSES THROUGH HIS BUDGET
PROCESS.
THAT BOLTED ON THIS IS A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT SO WE CAN
BEGIN TO TRACK WHAT MONEY GOES
AND WHERE IT GOES WITH THAT --
WE'VE GOT A COUPLE WITNESSES AND
TO BUT UP HEY WE WELCOME TO
WITNESSES WILL NOTE THAT THE
BILL DOES ENJOY THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CAN ALL MERCHANTS I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND CO FOUNDER OF CAL
O. Z. WHICH IS A NEW NONPROFIT
TRADE.
GROUP DEDICATED TO SUPPORTING
THE QUALITY OPPORTUNITIES ON
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
I'M HERE TODAY EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR SB.
THREE FIFTEEN OPPORTUNITIES
UNDER A BIPARTISAN IDEA WITH
ROOTS IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S WORK TO UPLIFT
URBAN SUBURBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
CALIFORNIA HAS THREE MILLION
RESIDENTS IN OPPORTUNITIES ON
FACING DAILY OBSTACLES TO THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM.
AND WHILE I WAS INVESTMENTS ARE
OFFERS IMPORTANT NEW COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT TOOL THAT WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO SQUANDER.
THE TIME IS NOW TO ESTABLISH THE
RIGHT FOUNDATION -- FOR DISEASE
BUILT ON FOUR PILLARS PILLAR ONE
IS PROTECTING AND EMPOWERING
COMMUNITIES WITH LOCAL CONTROL
SAFEGUARDS IN FUNDING TO BUILD A
PIPELINE OF QUALITY
OPPORTUNITIES ON PROJECTS.
PILLAR TO IS KEEPING CALIFORNIA
COMPETITIVE BY ENSURING STATE
POLICY STAY APACE WITH NATIONAL
TRENDS INCLUDING TAX CONFORMANCE.
PILLAR THREE IS LEVERAGING
CURACIES TO TURBO CHARGE OUR
TRANSITION TO A GREEN ECONOMY.
AND PILLAR FOR IS TO PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY THROUGH CLEAR
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
SB THREE FIFTEEN MUST REQUIRE
FUND MANAGERS TO ADOPT REPORTING
PROTOCOLS THAT DEMONSTRATE HOW
WELL INVESTMENTS FOR DELIVERING
A PROMISE IMPACTS.
BEFORE FINALIZING THE LANGUAGE
OF THIS BILL THE VOICES OF
COMMUNITIES PROJECT PROPONENTS
LOCAL POLICYMAKERS FUND MANAGERS.
AND OTHERS ARE ARE CRITICAL TO
SETTING STRONG BUT IT'S HUBAL
GROUND RULES.
CAL'S YOU'LL DO OUR PART TO
FACILITATE THAT INPUT.
LAST WEEK I WAS IN DC AND I
ATTENDED THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE
IN OPPORTUNITIES ON TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
WHICH IS A PLACE IT IN EXACTLY
SPEND EXPECTS BEEN A LOT OF TIME
ON THESE DAYS -- BUT POLITICS
ASIDE WHAT I SAW WAS INSPIRING
AND MOTIVATING.
REGARDLESS OF PARTY OR IDEOLOGY
LEADERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
TAKING A RENEWED INTEREST IN
SUPPORTING COMMUNITIES. TOO
OFTEN OVERLOOKED AND TOO OFTEN
LEFT BEHIND.
THE STRATEGIES TO DO SO MAY
DESERVE BUT THE GOALS ARE THE
SAME FOR EVERYBODY.
AND YET THE QUESTION OF METRICS
AND REPORTING FOR OPPORTUNITY
ZONES REMAINS UNANSWERED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WHICHIS
CALIFORNIA A CHANCE TO SHOW
NATIONAL LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL COMPONENT.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB THREE
FIFTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS AND MOVE
OUR STATE ONE STEP CLOSER TO THE
GOVERNOR'S VISION.
OF CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MUCH I ANY OTHER
WITNESSES.
RIGHT YOU CAN DO ME TOO THAT THE
MIKE OR YOU CAN DIE.
GIVE A MORE ELONGATED. FOR THOSE
WHO ARE NEW TO UP THE ANTE WE DO
GIVE A SIX MINUTE LIMIT.
ON WITNESSES AND SO YOU THERE IS
SOME TIME LEFT.
COLLECTIVELY YES SIR.
HI MY NAME IS STEVEN MOTIVE WITH
A BIT REPRESENTING THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL SAID AND THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CONSULTANT.
BUT NO LIKE TODAY THANK SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE -- AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE FIFTEEN WE WE COMMEND HIS
HIS LEADERSHIP -- IN MEETING THE
SHIPPING STANDARDS MARKET
CENTERS AND WORKING TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE MEASURABLE
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES TO SHOW FROM
PARTICIPATION.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INTENTIONS IN DIRECTION OF THIS
BILL WHAT WE DO SO WE WOULD WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THE TIMING AND
BURDEN OF COMPLIANCE FOR EACH OF
THE REPORTING ITEMS.
IS A TAKING INTO ACCOUNT WITH
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION.
PARTICULARLY WE BELIEVE THE TIME
LINE FOR REPORTING IS A MATERIAL
FACTOR. FOR SUCCESSFUL ADOPTION
AND MARKET PARTICIPATION.
UP WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DIALOGUE AND DISCUSSION AHEAD OF
US REGARD SPECIFICS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE COUNCIL'S POSITION.
OF FEEL WELCOME TO REACH OUT TO
ME MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
FAVORITE THEY WANT TO COME TO
THE MIKE WITH ME.
TOO THAT YOU'D BE WELCOME.
JUST SAY YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION IF ANY.
YOU DO IT AT THE MICROPHONE
RIGHT THERE IN THE CENTER.
HIS NAME AND AFFILIATION BE
GREAT HI -- MATT HORTON WITH THE
MILKEN INSTITUTE -- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS A COMMITTEE
AND TO SENATOR -- HERTZBERG. FOR
FOR BRING THIS UP THE INSTITUTE --
ITSELF IS A NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT ECONOMIC POLICY THINK
TANK IN CALIFORNIA -- ARE ARE
SORT OF REGIONAL ECONOMICS TAKES
A BROAD LOOK AT POLICIES RELATED
HOUSING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE -- AND WE
THINK I DON'T WORK HAS UNCOVERED.
A LOT OF THE BENEFITS THAT THE
SENATORS BILL IS SPEAKING TO AND
CONCEPTUALLY THIS FRAMEWORK
AROUND REPORTING WE THINK IS
REALLY VITAL STEP.
IN TERMS OF CONFORMING STATE
FRAMEWORK ABOUT HOW WE DIRECTLY
SPACE INVESTMENTS THAT CAN
UPLIFT OUR REGIONAL
COMBATIVENESS AND WE WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IRAN CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING.
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SENATOR HERTZBERG GUIDE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN THIS AREA I
I I HAVE -- OPTIMISTIC THOUGHTS
ABOUT THIS NEW OPPORTUNITIES ON
CONCEPT WITH THE HOPE THAT -- IT
CAN WORK BUT I THINK THAT YOUR
BILL BRINGS NEEDED
ACCOUNTABILITY AN ADDICT.
AND I THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE WORK THAT WE DO HERE
I WANT TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE BEFORE WE RECOGNIZE MOTION.
THAT'S RIGHT OKAY OKAY AS A
CENTER LATHE IS MADE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE BILL.
ALL THIS WILL DO A QUORUM FIRST
OKAY WE HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS WE
DO.
WHEN WE TAKE OUR ROLL CALL FIRST
GLAZER HERE LATER HERE CHIANG?
ARCHULETA ARCH LETTER HERE DON
GALGIANI.
HILL HERE PHIL HERE LEYVA THEY
MAY HAVE PAN.
WELCOME RESIDENT WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO WILL RECOGNIZE CENTER
LATEST MOTION -- TO DO PASS
[inaudible] TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
ALL RIGHT CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD AS YANNI.
HILL HILL AYE LEYVA LIVE AYE PAN
WILK I WILL DIE CENTER THAT HAS
ENOUGH BILLS TO GET OUT VOTES TO
GET OUT THE REAL HOLD THE ROLE
OF BROWN'S THE MEMBERS THANK YOU
BOTH VERY MUCH AND FOR YOUR
WITNESSES.
SENATOR JOHN SIZE HERE IN THE
HOUSE YEAH.
WE WELCOME YOU TO BE IN FEE
.
CENTER JONES WELCOME YOU HAVE --
SB THREE THREE NINE I'D NUMBER.
TWO YES MISTER SHARED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED ON PAGE.
SIX OF THE COMMITTEE ALICE'S TO
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY NINE
ENHANCES CONSUMER PROTECTION BY
CLARIFYING THAT WHEN A LAND
SURVEYOR IS RETAINED AS AN
EXPERT IN CIVIL PROCEEDINGS.
ANY NON DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT
SIGNED BY THE SURVEYOR MAY NOT
PROHIBIT THE SURVEY OR FROM
REPORTING MALPRACTICE. TO THE
ROGUE REGULATORY AGENCY
SURVEYOR'S REPORT THAT THESE
INDIE ETS INCREASINGLY SEEK TO
PROHIBIT ANY REPORTING.
OF VIOLATIONS OF PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS TO THE REGULATORY
BOARD WHICH DOES NOT PROTECT THE
CONSUMER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY WITH ME IS MY COLOGNE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LAND
SURVEYORS ASSOCIATION. TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU SENATOR
FIRST WITNESS MISTER TURN
MEMBERS MIKE BILLOWED ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA LAND SURVEYORS
ASSOCIATION REALLY IT IS VERY
VERY SIMPLE BILL WE JUST DON'T
THINK AND DA'S SHOULD.
OPERATE TO PROHIBIT A LICENSEE
FROM REPORTING MALPRACTICE TO
THE BOARD GOOD FOR TRANSPARENCY
GOOD FOR CONSUMERS.
AND THE LANGUAGE -- DRAFTED BY
YOUR STAFF IS BETTER THAN WHAT I
DID AND I THANK THEM FOR THAT.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN FAVOR.
ANY WITNESSES AND OUT WE HAVE
WITNESSED IN FAVOR.
A TWEENER COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS
I AM NANCY I SWEAR I AM THE
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE BOARD FOR PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS LAND SURVEYORS AND
GEOLOGISTS.
AT THE BOARDS APRIL ELEVENTH
MEETING THEY DID VOTE TO OPPOSE
THE BILL AS IT IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN.
HOWEVER THEY ALSO VOTED TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
CONCEPT THAT THEIR LICENSEES
SHOULD NEVER BE PROHIBITED BY
THE TERMS OF AN AGREEMENT OR
CONTRACT. FOR PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO THE BOARD
REGARDING.
SUSPECTED VIOLATIONS OF THE
LICENSING LAWS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND ACCEPTED BY
SENATOR JONES.
I BELIEVE THE BOARD WILL REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT BASED ON IF
THAT LANGUAGE IS PLACED IN ITS
OWN SECTION OF THE LAWS RATHER
THAN.
RELATED TO THE ARTICLE.
RELATING TO REPORTING OF LEGAL
ACTION SUPPORT WOULD BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SO THAT'S WHY I AM AT IN BETWEEN --
A PNC BANK YEAH ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER -- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
NEUTRAL.
HOW THAT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
I SING AND WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
SENATOR I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SENSITIVITY TO SOME OF
THESE ISSUES AND APPRECIATE YOUR
WORKING WITH OUR STAFF.
YOU'VE ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE EEN OFFERED.
CERTAINLY THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE BOARD OF ENGINEERING
AND GEOLOGISTS -- LAND SURVEYORS
HAS RAISED A BROADER ISSUE I
HOPE YOU'LL TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION IS THE BILL GOES
FORWARD GREAT THANK YOU WITH
THAT ASK YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
ALLIES FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
RIGHT WITH THAT I THINK I
RECOGNIZE EMOTIONS CENTER LEYVA
TO MOVE THE BILL.
AS AMENDED.
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD GALGIANI HILL
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN WILK I WILL GUIDE
CENTER THAT STILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET UP ORGAN HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU AND YOUR WITNESS THANK
YOU FOR BEING UP HERE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA ASK THE
OTHER AUTHORS WHO ARE HERE IN
THE BUILDING OR CAN HEAR MY
VOICE TO COME TO COMMITTEE.
FIRST ONE AND GETS TO GO AND SO
WILL TAKE OF POTS AS WE WAIT FOR
THAT TO HAPPEN.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A CONSENT --
CALENDAR ANYBODY WISH TO TAKE
ANYTHING OFF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEE NO OBJECTION TO THE CONSENT
COUNTERSIGNED HER HILLS MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE
CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD GALGIANI HILL
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN WILK.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET APPLE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN BY AND JUST FOR THOSE
LISTENING MAYBE NOT HAVING THE
FILE IN FRONT OF THEM THAT'S SB.
FIVE SIXTY NINE SB SIX OH ONE IN
SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX I WILL TAKE A
PAUSES OR WAITING FOR AUTHORS.
OR WE'RE GOING TO HEAR SOME OF
OUR OWN BILLS THAT'S ANOTHER
OPTION -- THEY HAD A REALLY GOOD
AUTHORS OF THOSE BILLS
[inaudible]
DOORS OPENING.
HI SESSIONS OKAY.
CENTER STONE COME ON IN YOUR OF
YOUR NEXT UP.
THIS IS THE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP.
FOUR SEVENTY SIX CENTER STONE.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WELCOME
HOME.
THANK YOU MISTER TURN MEMBERS
I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT -- SB FOUR
SEVENTY SIX I WOULD FIRST LIKE
TO THANK -- THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR ALL THEIR VERY GENEROUS TIME
AND HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND
ESPECIALLY YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
SPENDING.
A GENEROUS AMOUNT OF TIME WITH
ME.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY CURRENTLY HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO DENY.
OR REVOKE ANY PHARMACY LICENSE
WHEN THEY'RE GROUNDS FOR
DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
AS YOU MAY KNOW WHEN THE
PHARMACIST EXCEPT THE TITLE OF
THE PHARMACIST IN CHARGE HE OR
SHE IS SIGNING UP TO PUT OUR
LICENSE ON THE LINE FOR THE
PHARMACY THEY WORK IN.
SB FOUR SEVENTY SIX IS A SIMPLE
MEASURE TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING MISTAKES.
ARE TRULY HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS.
THIS BILL.
SIMPLY SPECIFIES THAT A PERSON
WHO SIGNS UP TO BE PHARMACISTS
IN CHARGE.
SHOULD NOT BE PUNISHED FOR
ACTIONS TAKEN IN THE PHARMACY
THAT THEY HAVE NO AUTHORITY OVER.
CURRENTLY PHARMACISTS AND
CHARGER FOUND IN VIOLATION
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING THAT THE
PHARMACY LICENSE HOLDER DID.
DIDN'T DO OR INSTRUCTED THEM TO
DO.
THIS BILL WILL FIX THIS PROBLEM
BY MAKING IT CLEAR THE
PHARMACIST IN CHARGE TOOK ALL
ACTIONS WITHIN THEIR AUTHORITY.
TO REMEDY A POSSIBLE VIOLATION.
APPS MOST IMPORTANTLY SB FOUR
SEVENTY SIX PLACES THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR VIOLATIONS ON
A PHARMACY LICENSE HOLDER. FOR
APPROPRIATING THE AUTHORITY OF
THE PHARMACIST IN CHARGE IN
THEIR ABILITY TO CARRY OUT THEIR
DUTIES BY ALLOWING THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY.
DEFINED THE LICENSE HOLDER UP TO
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN TODAY'S WORLD YOUNG
PHARMACISTS ARE TOO OFTEN OFF
THE TITLE THE PHARMACIST IN
CHARGE IN EXCHANGE FOR A FEW
EXTRA DOLLARS.
AN HOUR WITHOUT REALIZING THAT
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY INCLUDES
PUTTING THEIR LICENSE AND HARD
EARNED MONEY ON THE LINE.
SB FOUR SEVENTY SIX IN THE
MOMENTS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
WILL MAKE IT CLEAR THAT LICENSE
HOLDERS ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE ACTIONS TAKEN AT THE
PHARMACY.
THIS BILL PROTECTS PHARMACISTS
FROM BEING HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR
ACTIONS THEY HAD NO CONTROL OVER.
IT'S COMMON SENSE IT'S FAIR AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I DID HAVE TWO WITNESSES ARE
GOING TO BE HERE TODAY
UNFORTUNATELY ONE HAD TO FLY TO
SOME IN CALIFORNIA TO BE WITH AN
ILL PARENT AND THE OTHER ONE WAS
SICK TODAY -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR I
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND IN
SUPPORT.
DOES HE GROW WITH UFCW WESTERN
STATES COMES ON SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OR I WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION.
AT SENATOR UP FIRST LET ME THANK
YOU FOR THAT FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE
A PHARMACIST IN CHARGE I DIDN'T
REALLY KNOW MUCH ABOUT IT --
UNTIL A FEW WEEKS AGO AND AND
YOUR BILL CERTAINLY HAS -- DRAWN
MY ATTENTION AND I'M SURE MY
COLLEAGUES TO THE TO THE ISSUE.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU WORKING --
TO FIND WAY I FIND A PATHWAY TO
DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE -- I KNOW
INITIALLY THE BILL -- REMOVE
PHARMACIST IN CHARGE OF ACTIVITY
THAT THEY WEREN'T AWARE OF AND I
THINK YOU HEARD MY CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT THAT.
I THOUGHT IT HAD THE POTENTIAL
TO UNDER UNDERMINE CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
AND THAT WE HAD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE THE WORK THAT WAS DONE
WAS APPROPRIATE.
AND I THINK YOUR BILL THAN
FEARED IN THE DIRECTION THAT WE
SEE IT TODAY WHICH IS
[inaudible] TO TO FOCUS IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION ON THE
OWNERSHIP OF THE THE FACILITY
LESS THAN THAT AND ON THE
PHARMACIST IN CHARGE.
AND US I APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE MADE AND CERTAINLY
THE EDUCATION THAT'S OCCURRED
WITH THAT WITH THAT PROPELLED
THE THE BILL AS YOU ARE
CURRENTLY PROPOSING IT.
I THINK ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT THAT STILL REMAINS WITH ME --
IS TO UNDERSTAND HOW SIGNIFICANT
OF A PROBLEM THIS IS -- OUT
THERE IN OUR WORLD.
AND THAT IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
WANT TO COMMENT UPON IN TERMS OF
HIS OR ANY STUDY OR DATA THAT
THAT YOU CAN REFERENCE THERE IN
TERMS OF THIS BUT TO THIS.
YUP POTENTIAL PROBLEM OR THIS
EXISTING PROBLEM THANK YOU
SENATOR YOU KNOW IS -- THE FIRST
PHARMACIST IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
THIRTY YEARS -- MANY OF THE
PHARMACY PROFESSION IS KIND OF
THEY SEE ME AS THEIR AMBASSADOR
HERE IN IN THE IN THE
LEGISLATURE SO I'VE.
HAD NUMEROUS CORRESPONDENCES
WITH THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
INAPPROPRIATELY CITED AS
PHARMACISTS IN CHARGE AND THOSE
THAT ARE NOT WILLING TO TAKE THE
JOB BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
PUT THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY.
AND WHAT I'M GOING TO DO --
SENATOR -- MISTER CHAIR IS I'M
GONNA REFER A LOT OF THOSE
CORRESPONDENCES THAT I'M GETTING
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SO
YOU CAN SEE THAT THIS IS NOT A
OF AN ISSUE THAT I'VE I'VE
DREAMED UP IT'S IT'S REALLY AN
ISSUE OF OF GETTING COMPETENT
PEOPLE -- THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE
IN WORKING ESPECIALLY IN RETAIL
PHARMACY TO BE AND IN CHARGE OF
THAT PHARMACY INTO CONTROL.
OF THE MANY NUANCES THAT COULD
HAPPEN IN THE PHARMACY PHARMACY
LAWS VERY COMPLICATED BOTH AT
THE STATE LEVEL ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND ALL THAT
RESPONSIBILITY FALLS ON THE
PHARMACIST IN CHARGE WHETHER R
NOT.
THEY'RE EVEN AT THE PHARMACY IF
IT'S A TWENTY FOUR HOUR PHARMACY
IN A VIOLATION OCCURS AT TWO
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING THE
PHARMACIST IN CHARGE GET CITED.
IF YOU CAN DONATE ACTIVITY IN
SHE IS SHOWN THEY GAVE DIRECTION
TO DISOBEY THE LAW HE DESERVES
TO BE CITED AS THE PHARMACIST IN
CHARGE.
BUT BUT I THINK THE BEST THING
TO DO IS TO HEAR FROM THOSE
PHARMACISTS THAT.
ARE REFRAIN FROM BIG PHARMACISTS
CHARGES KNOWS OF AN
INAPPROPRIATELY SIDE.
I APPRECIATE THAT -- AND AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE NICE
THINGS ABOUT.
I'VE BEEN IN THE SENATE THE
LEGISLATURE WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES IN LIFE
THAT WE BRING TO THE ARE
LAWMAKING PROCESS BECAUSE THAT
THAT'S REALLY WHAT MAKES GOOD
LOSS RIGHT AND AND MAKES GOOD
JUDGMENTS IS THAT WE WE SEE AND
FEEL THAT EXPERIENCE.
CERTAINLY THAT ALSO COMES FROM
THE WITNESSES THAT COME AND
TESTIFY BEFORE US.
I'M SO WHAT I I THINK FOR ME AT
LEAST THAT WHERE I'D BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE COMFORTABLE IN MOVING
THIS BILL IS THAT IF WE WE ASK
THAT THE BOARD OF PHARMACY TO
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE.
AND SEE IF THEY CAN -- TAKE A
CAREFUL LOOK AT THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THIS IS A PROBLEM AND
INFORM US. TO WHAT THEY FIND
THAT THAT MIGHT BE FOR ME AT
LEAST PROVIDE A BETTER
FOUNDATION AND WHICH HAD. TO
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES OF FIVE
RAISING FINE LEVELS IS THIS BILL
PROPOSES OR OTHER ACTIVITIES
THAT WE MIGHT.
CONSIDER DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE THE OUR RULES ARE ENFORCED
THAT THE PERSON IN CHARGE REALLY
IS IN CHARGE.
I AND IS HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THAT AND IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY
AND SO.
I WONDER IF YOU WOULD BE WOULD
BE OPEN TO THAT IDEA OF OF
DIRECTING THE BOARD OF PHARMACY
TO EXAMINE THIS ISSUE IN MORE
DETAIL -- WE COME UP WITH
LANGUAGE IS TO THIS SPECIFIC --
THINGS THAT THEY WOULD DO BUT
ASSN TO REPORT BACK IN A YEAR --
TO WITH THAT KIND OF INFORMATION
AND THESE FOR ME AND I'LL LIST I
HEAR FROM MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AS WELLBUT THAT WOULD MAKE ME A
LITTLE BIT MORE COMFORTABLE
RATHER THAN JUST THE ATTACKS
FINE CHANGE.
WITHOUT A REAL CAREFUL
EXAMINATION OF THE PROBLEM IS TO
LET'S TAKE IT A HALF STEP
FORWARD MAYBE BUT AT LEAST A
STEP FORWARD.
AS YOU WORK TO EDUCATE US AND
OTHERS AS TO WHY THIS MAY BE A
PROBLEM OUT THERE WOULD YOU
CONSIDER THAT YES -- MISTER HERE
I'M HAPPY -- TO TO WORKWITH YOU
AND IF IF THAT'S THE DIRE THE
CHAIR OF THE HAPPY TO
ACCOMMODATE YOU -- YOU MAY ASK
YOU KNOW WHY THE TEN FOLD
INCREASE IN IN THE FINE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THESE LARGE
CHAINS IT'S VERY EASY WITH THEM
WHEN THEY GET A VIOLATION IS
WRITE A CHECK FOR FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND MOVE ON BUT I CAN
TELL YOU IF IT'S FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE A
SECOND LOOK AND SAY OKAY WE HAVE
A PROBLEM.
AND WE NEED TO FIX THAT PROBLEM
I THINK THEY'LL BE A LOT MORE
SERIOUS.
SO -- IT'S IF THAT'S THE WILL OF
THE CHAIR I'M HAPPY TO
ACCOMMODATE YOU AT YOU SIR IN
THE COMMITTEE IN ANY WAY TO WITH
THE BILL FORWARD OKAY LET ME SEE
IF I COLLEGES ANY AGREEMENT OR
DISAGREEMENT WITH THAT DIRECTION.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I THINK THAT'S A A
GOOD APPROACH -- AND IT MIGHT
THE SOLUTION AND THE SANCTION
MAY NOT JUST BE FINANCIAL IT
THERE MAY BE SOME OTHER
RESTRICTIONS IT COULD BE PLACED
ON THEIR ABILITY TO DO BUSINESS
IN SOME CASES SO I THINK THAT'S
A GOOD APPROACH TO HAVE THE THE
BOARD OF PHARMACEUTICAL.
A CLOSER LOOK AT IT MAYBE IN ONE
YEAR YOU KNOW GIVE A LITTLE TIME
I DON'T HAVE TO IS NECESSARY BUT
I'D LIKE TO SEE SOMETHING SOONER
THAN LATER MAY BE HELPFUL.
OKAY THANK CENTER LEYVA YOUR
THOUGHTS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I I AGREE WITH YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTS BUT I ALSO LIKE TO SAY
I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR STONE.
THAT MANY OF THESE LARGE
CORPORATIONS TO SEE IT AS A COST
OF DOING BUSINESS AND SO IF IT'S
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS THEY'LL DO
WHATEVER THEY NEED TO DO WRITE
THE CHECK AND CONTINUE TO BE
REPEAT VIOLATORS.
SO SOMETIMES WE DO HAVE TO HAVE
A BIGGER STICK SO.
I AGREE WITH THAT BUT I ALSO
AGREE WITH PRECEDING THE
PHARMACY BOARD THAT'S FINE WITH
ME.
ALL RIGHT.
CENTER ARCHULETA YEAH MY CONCERN --
THANK YOU FOR BRING THIS BEFORE
AT MY CONCERN IS -- HAVING A TOO
LONG I THINK TWO YEARS MIGHT BE
A LITTLE BIT TOO LONG IF THERE'S
AT IF THIS IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND WE AREN'T AWARE OF IT.
THEN YOU GOT TO BRING IT BACK
WITH FACTS AND DATA.
SO THEN WE CAN ACT QUICKLY
BECAUSE I THINK TWO YEARS WOULD
BE TOO LONG.
A MISTER CHAIR OF SO AS I HAVE
MY COLLEAGUE MATCHES TO THE
BETTER.
THAN A GET WELL IF THIS BILL AT
IS IS ENACTED THIS YEAR IT
WOULDN'T GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL
TWENTY SO MAYBE ALLOWING THEM TO
REPORT BACK IN.
TWENTY ONE A YEAR LATER MIGHT BE
THE APPROPRIATE DATE I GUESS
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD -- BUT I
WOULD SUGGEST.
SO SO CENTER A GALGIANI.
TOM WHAT ABOUT THE SMALL MOM AND
POP PHARMACIES ARE THEY TREATED
THE SAME UNDER THIS BILL.
BECAUSE MY CONCERN IS IF YOU
HAVE A SMALL SMALL PHARMACY OWN
PHARMACISTS TO MAKE THE MISTAKE.
THAT COULD PUT THAT PHARMACIST
OUT OF BUSINESS ENTIRELY WELL IF
THEY MAKE A MISTAKE IT DOESN'T
MEAN THEY'RE GOING TO GET FINED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IS FOR
NOT FOLLOWING PHARMACY LAWS IN
EXAMPLE.
THERE'S A CERTAIN RACIAL
PHARMACY TECHS THAT YOU CAN HAVE
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW SO IF
YOU'RE A SOLE PROPRIETOR LIKE I
AM A COMPOUNDING PHARMACY.
AND I DECIDE I'M GONNA HAVE SIX
TAX WORKING BECAUSE I NEED TO
GET THE VOLUME AT A ONE IRON OF
THE PHARMACIST AND THEY SHOULD
BE APPROPRIATELY CHARGE.
HOWEVER IT'S UP TO FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE GONNA SEE THE STATE BOARD
LEVY THAT KIND OF A FEE UNLESS
IT'S REALLY SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY VERY SERIOUS.
SO IT'S LIKELY THAT THAT WOULD
NOT HAPPEN TO A SOLE PROPRIETOR
I I WOULD DOUBT IT BUT ALSO IN
RESPONSE TO SENATOR HILL.
WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
FINES WERE TALKING ABOUT --
SUSPENSIONS OUR REPLICATIONS OF
LICENSES THAT'S WHERE YOU REALLY
HAVE -- THE CHAIN STORES
ATTENTION WHEN YOU HAVE ONE OF
THEIR STORES THEY DON'T WANT THE
PRESS. TO GET A HOLD OF THE FACT
THAT THERE ONE STORE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WAS SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE THEY'RE PHARMACISTS WERE
WE'RE NOT FOLLOWING THE LAWS SO.
THIS IS NOT JUST FINANCES ALSO
THE LICENSES IS THE KEY TO
MAKING SURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT.
THEIR LICENSE IS IN JEOPARDY IF
THERE'RE AND IF THEY'RE NOT
INSTRUCTING -- THEIR PHARMACIST
IN CHARGE TO CARRY OUT THE LAWS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF
THEY BASICALLY TOM TO SKIRT THE
LAW OR YOU'RE GONNA BE FIRED IN
THE AND AND THEY DO THAT.
THEN THE LICENSEE SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND THE PICTURE BE
HELD RESPONSIBLE AS WELL.
OKAY CENTER GALGIANI AND OTHERS
SO BY THE AUTHORS AGREEING -- TO
MAN HIS BILL TO ELIMINATE -- THE
PROVISIONS RELATIVE TO FINES AND
OBLIGATIONS AND SIMPLY ASK AS AS
I STUDY BE DONE TO THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY.
ON THIS ISSUE AND REPORT BACK IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT'S WHAT'S
GONNA.
THAT'S WHAT WE IF THE COMMITTEE
AGREES THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH TODAY.
OKAY SENATOR A STONE YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ON THAT THAT THAT NOTE YES
MISTER I THINK WE DISCUSSED AT
THE TO MAKE YOU AWARE THAT THAT
WE HAVE A LOT OF PHARMACISTS
WOULD LIKE TO BE PHARMACIST IN
CHARGE I THINK WHICH HAVE THE
MOST EXPERIENCE PHARMACIST IN
CHARGE ESPECIALLY.
WITH THE GRADUATES THAT ARE
COMING ONLINE -- I LEARNED MY MY
BEST -- CARE OF PATIENTS THROUGH.
YOUNG OR PHARMACIST IN CHARGE
THAT I WORK WITH.
ONE DR JIM DE WAS MY PRECEPTOR
IN HOLLYWOOD WHO TAUGHT ME A LOT
MORE THAN EVER HEARD IN PHARMACY
SCHOOL ABOUT PATIENT SAFETY AND
AND CARING FOR PATIENTS AND IN
HIS MEMORY I'D LIKE.
TO ASK YOUR AYE.
THEY'RE IN VERY NICE SELF UP FOR
OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- ASKED
FOR A MOTION THAT THAT WOULD BE
DO PASS -- WITH THE AUTHORS --
PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO REPLACE
THE CONTENT OF THE BILL WITH THE
REQUIREMENT. TO THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY TO DO A STUDY.
REPORTING BACK TO US IN JANUARY
FIRST -- TWENTY TWENTY ONE ON
THE ON THE ISSUE OF THE
PREVALENCE -- INTERFERENCE OF
CORPORATE MANAGEMENT AND
PHARMACISTS IN CHARGE AND THE
BEST WAY TO HANDLE IT.
AND THAT THAT THE AUTHOR WORK
WITH OUR STAFF ON THAT EXACT
LANGUAGE PRIDE WHICH FOR
PRESENTATION TO APPROPRIATIONS.
OKAY.
CENTER LEYVA WAS THAT TO THAT
ITEM.
WITH THAT THE SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AIDAN GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN WILK HI WILL
GUIDE CENTER THAT BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET APPLE HOLD
THE ROLE OF INFRASTRUCTURE THE
MEMBERS.
THE CENTER BRADFORD.
I SEE YOU THERE THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
SO WE'RE GONNA LOCK CENTER
BRADFORD TO THE COMMITTEE --
THIS IS US ITEM SEVENTEEN SB.
SIX FIVE EIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE I MEAN MR
CARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE.
PRESENT SB.
SIX FIVE EIGHT AND I AM -- AS
YOU COMMITTEE ANALYSIS STAGE I
AM REMOVING THE FIRST SECTION OF
THIS BILL AS AGREED UPON AS
DURING THE DISCUSSIONS I THINK.
THE CHAIRMAN'S STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH A SIGH SB SIX FIVE A WILL
EMPOWER LOCAL REGULATORS.
AN INCREASE CONSUMER SAFETY AND
CANNABIS INDUSTRY THE STREET FOR
MEASURED THOSE TWO THINGS ARE
REQUIRED TO BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL TO US DOLLARS.
ECONOMIST RETAIL BUSINESS EMBLEM
PROGRAM AND TO AUTHORIZE LOCAL
ROUTE -- REGULATORS ACCESS TO
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS TRACK
AND TRACE SYSTEM.
WITH THE VOTER APPROVAL OR PROP
SIXTY FOUR IN PASSAGE OF THE
CIVIL ADULT USE CANNABIS --
REGULATION AND SAFETY ACT OUR
STATE ESTABLISHED A ROBUST TOOL
LICENSE LICENSING SYSTEM WHICH
REQUIRES BUSINESS OWNERS TO
OBTAIN A LICENSE FROM THEIR
LOCAL GOVERNING BODY.
AS WELL AS THE STATE LICENSE
FROM THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH DEPENDING ON WHAT TYPE
OF BUSINESS THEY'RE OPERATING.
WHERE'S WHERE IS A KEY FEATURE
OF THE LAWS WAS PASSED WORK TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY AUTHORITY
TO FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
WORK WITH THE STATE TO CREATE A
FUNCTIONAL INDUSTRY.
THE UNFORTUNATE THING IS THE
PREEXISTING UNDERGROUND
MARKETING COMPLEX LICENSE LAWS
HAVE SLOWED THIS PROGRESS THE
LISTEN MARKET REMAINS A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE FOR MANY CANNABIS
CONSUMERS TO THE LARGE PART
BECAUSE OF THE BUSINESS OWNERS.
ARE ABLE TO THE SKIES -- ILLEGAL
OPERATIONS AS HIGH IN LEGAL
BUSINESSES.
BECAUSE CONSUMERS ARE CURRENTLY
UNABLE TO EASILY IDENTIFY
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES FROM THE
ILLEGITIMATE BUSINESSES MANY PUT
THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY.
ADDRESS BY PATRONIZING RETAILERS
WHO WHOSE PRODUCTS ARE NOT
TESTED AND OPERATIONS ARE NOT
REGULATED SB SIX FIVE EIGHT
ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM BY
REQUIRING THE BUREAU TO DEVELOP.
AND IMPLEMENT A STATE EMBLEM
PROGRAM FOR ALL LICENSE HOLDERS.
NUMBER MUST BE IN PLAIN VIEW FOR
CONSUMERS TO VERIFY THAT THE
BUSINESS HOUSE LOCAL AND STATE
LICENSE.
WHICH ALSO HELPS IDENTIFY
UNLICENSED ILLEGAL ENTERPRISES
THAT HAVE FLORIST ACROSS OUR
STATE ADDITIONALLY THAT IN
ANOTHER AN INVALUABLE RESOURCE.
USED TO COMBAT TO ELICIT MARKET
INCREASED TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS
INDUSTRY.
OUR STATE IS RECENTLY -- STOPS --
TREES AND NOT TRACK AND TRACE
SYSTEM USED BY ALL STATE
CANNABIS LICENSEES FOR THE
PURPOSE OF REPORTING THE
MOVEMENT ACCOUNT OF HIS.
THROUGHOUT EACH STEP OF THE
SUPPLY AND DISTRIBUTION TRACK
CHANGE.
THE PROBLEM IS UNDER EXISTING
LAW THERE IS AMBIGUITY AS TO WHO
CAN ACCESS THE SYSTEM BESIDES
THE THREE STATE LICENSE ENTITIES
AND THE STATE. FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SB SIX FIVE
A PROVIDES IN THIS THIRTY
CLARITY FOR LOCAL REGULATORY.
REGULATORS TO TRACK AND TRACE TO
GROWTH MOVEMENT AND SELL
ACCOUNTS WITHIN THE CITY AND
COUNTY.
OVERALL THIS BILL WILL HELP
IMPROVE OUR STATE REGULATORY
SYSTEM BY INCREASING CONSUMER
PROTECTION TO HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ENFORCE THEIR
CAMPS LOS.
ALL WITH ME TODAY AS CAT PACKARD
WHOSE EXACT DIRECTIVES STEVE LOS
ANGELES ON CANNABIS --
REGULATIONS HAVE BEEN A A KEY.
OF VOICE AND HELPING LA SHAPE
HERE -- PROGRAM AS WELL AS REST
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU CENTER RIGHT FOR YOUR
FIRST WITNESS.
HI MY NAME IS KAT PACKER I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
REGULATION FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
A GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND CHAIRS AS
THE LOCAL AGENCY I AM CHARGED
WITH IMPLEMENTING AND LEADING
THE CITY'S COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
PROGRAMS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS BODY.
AND URGE YOUR VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FIFTY EIGHT I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR BRADFORD FOR ALL
OF HIS WORK TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HAVING RESPONSIBLE AND
EQUITABLE.
CANNABIS POLICY AND ITS
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
CONTINUANCE OF THIS WORK ARE THE
SENATORS OFFERINGS BILL WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL TO ESTABLISH AN
EMBLEM PROGRAM.
AND TO CLARIFY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MAY HAVE ACCESS TO
TRACK AND TRACE DATABASE THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES IS ONE OF
THE LARGEST CANNABIS MARKETS IN
THE WORLD.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE CANNABIS
MARKET AND AS SUCH THE SUCCESS
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM IS
VERY MUCH INTERDEPENDENT WITH
THE SUCCESS OF LOCAL REGULATORY
PROGRAMS.
AS SUCH WE WORKED INTENTIONALLY
WITH STATE OFFICIALS AND
AGENCIES TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT FIRST IN TIME POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS.
AND THIS IS NO DIFFERENT OVER
THE WEEKEND MANY CANNABIS
CONSUMERS ARE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES PARTICIPATED IN AN
UNOFFICIAL CANNABIS HOLIDAY
KNOWN AS FOR TWENTY
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THOSE
CANNABIS CONSUMERS IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MAY HAVE HAD A DIFFICULT TIME
UNDERSTANDING WHICH FACILITIES
WERE LEGAL AND WHICH ONES WERE
NOT.
CURRENTLY INDIVIDUALS CAN MAYBE
CHECK ONLINE FOR HAVE TO GO INTO
A PHYSICAL LOCATION OVER TO
DETERMINE IF A LICENSE I
BUSINESS IS LICENSE.
IN ORDER FOR THE LEGAL MARKET TO
BE SUCCESSFUL CONSUMERS MOST
MUST BE BOTH AWARE OF THE
LOCATION OF LICENSE FACILITIES
AND AWARE OF THE RISKS AND
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED.
WITH BUYING FROM LEGAL OR
ILLEGAL CANNABIS STORES
FURTHERMORE LOCAL REGULATORS
MUST BE AWARE OF HOW.
AND WHAT PRODUCTS ARE MOVING IN
AND THROUGH THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS ACTIVITY IS
JUST GETTING STARTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND WE HOPE THAT THROUGH
THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL BOTH
CONSUMERS AND LOCAL REGULATORS
ARE EMPOWERED. TO BE RESPONSIBLE
ACTORS IN THE NASCENT BUT
GROWING INDUSTRY IN MARKET THANK
YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
SET THE MICROPHONE.
SURE MEMBERS ROSS BUT THE ON
BEHALF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAR INTERNET ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED CAN WAS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FOR IN A
SANDERS WE SEE THOUSANDS OF
ILLEGAL SHOPS THAT ARE.
ESTABLISHED CUSTOMER DAHLE CAN'T
TO THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
LEGAL PERSONALLY OR SHOP OUR
SHOP'S CONTINUE TO HIS REVENUES
AND WE CONTINUE TO LAY OFF
WORKERS.
SO WE APPRECIATE CAT PACK AND
THE SERIAL AND SIGNS AND SAID
ABOUT FOR FOR BRINGING A BILL
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS ANY FRANCO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBER
CHARLES HARVEY WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I WILL BRING THE ISSUE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
DISCUSSION MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS.
SENATE ARCHULETA YES I WOULD
JUST I'D LIKE.
TO COMPLIMENT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES OF COURSE ARE SENATOR --
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE ALL BEEN WAITING.
FOR A LOT OF CITIES ARE WAITING
TO OPEN A LOT OF CITIES ARE
BEGINNING TO START TO LOOK INTO
OPENING -- FACILITIES AND SO ON
AND THIS IS A GREAT WAY TO START
PUTTING PUTTING IT RIGHT UP
THERE.
THAT THIS IS THE AVERAGE MAN IS
LEGAL IN ITS AUTHORIZED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU HAVE A CENTER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR GOOD WORK IN THIS
AREA -- JOYS THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THE STAFF ON ON THE AMENDMENTS
LIKE I OFFER YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE THANK YOU.
AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS IN YOUR SUPPORT -- AS
STATED IT'S JUST A COMMON --
SINCE MEASURE THAT'S GOING TO
PROVIDE CONSUMERS WITH GREATER
PROTECTION BUT ALSO GUARANTEE --
THE PROMISE OF PROP SIXTY FOUR
THE REVENUES TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU CENTER THE
CENTERS CLOSE SAID WELCOME THE
MOTION HERE.
CENTER ARTS LETTERS MOVE THE
BILL WITH THE AMENDMENTS AS
SUBMITTED.
AND WITH AD THIS IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THAT CORRECT
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROVES DO PASSES AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE CHIANG.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN WILK.
HI.
CENTER THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WILL HOLD.
THE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THE ABSENCE OF A
AUTHOR FROM OUTSIDE OF THE
COMMITTEE.
GOING TO INVITE A MEMBER OF THE
MEDI.
WE HAVE WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
[inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HOPE YOU HAD A NICE WEEKEND.
AS WE GOT OFF GET YOUR ENERGY
BACK YEAH [inaudible]
I'VE ALREADY -- YES A LOT GOING
ON IN THE NORTH COAST WE WELCOME
YOU TO THE PNP COMMITTEE.
SB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER THREE WHERE DID YOU GO
ANY TIME YOU ARE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND WELCOME
BACK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING US TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT TODAY AND I APOLOGIZE
ABOUT BEING.
A LITTLE LATE.
I WILL ADMIT THAT THIS ISSUE --
THAT WE ORIGINALLY THOUGHT WE
TACKLED BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN IT'S A
COMPLICATED ONE BUT WE'RE LUCKY
THAT TODAY'S BILL IS A SIMPLE
CLEAN UP -- TO A PREVIOUS STATE
BILL THAT PROTECTS FOSTER YOUTH.
THE CITY CALIFORNIA MISTER
CHEERS GUARDIAN TO APPROXIMATELY
SIXTY THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS.
IN A HOLDS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THIS VULNERABLE POPULATION.
THIS BILL IT EXTENDS TO THE
MONITORING IN THE ADMINISTRATION
OF MIND NUMBING PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS.
THAT CAN LEAD TO IRREVERSIBLE IN
LIFELONG IMPACTS IF NOT
PRESCRIBED APPROPRIATELY.
IN AN EFFORT TO BE ABLE TO CRACK
DOWN ON EXCESSIVE AND
UNNECESSARY PSYCHOTROPIC
PRESCRIBING TO FOSTER YOUTH.
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A SERIES
OF BILLS IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN INCLUDING SB.
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR WAS INTENDED TO
GIVE THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD DATA TO INVESTIGATE
POTENTIAL.
I WANT TO STRESS POTENTIAL CASES
OF INAPPROPRIATE PRESCRIBING.
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BUT BUILT
OFF A IN EXISTING DATA SAID.
N. IN EXISTING DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT.
AND IT ESTABLISH A FORMAL
ONGOING PROCESS FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO REVIEW AND
CONFIDENTIALLY INVESTIGATE
PSYCHOTROPIC.
MEDICATION PRESCRIBING PATTERNS
OUTSIDE THE STANDARD OF CARE.
FOR FOSTER USED TO HAVE BEEN ON
THREE OR MORE PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS FOR NINETY OR MORE
DAYS.
THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES PROVIDES THE MEDICAL
BOARD WITH THE FOLLOWING.
NUMBER ONE A LIST A PSYCH MEDS
PRESCRIBED.
NUMBER TWO THE START AND STOP
DATES FOR EACH MEDICATION. THREE
THE FOSTERS YOUTH DATE OF BIRTH
AND NUMBER FOUR THE STRENGTH IN
QUANTITY OF MEDICATION AND THE
NUMBER OF DAYS SUPPLY OF
MEDICATION.
MET THE MEDICAL BOARD THEN
CONTRACTS WITH AN EXPERT
PSYCHIATRISTS WHO SPECIALIZES IN
PEDIATRIC CARE TO REVIEW THE
DATA TO DETERMINE IF AN
ACCUSATION OF INAPPROPRIATE
PRESCRIBING SHOULD BE MADE WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WELL SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WAS
AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT FOR STATES
FATHI FOSTER YOUTH.
THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS SINCE
INDICATED THAT THE DATA SHARED
DOES NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH
INFORMATION. FOR THEM TO
INVESTIGATE PRESCRIBING PATTERNS
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO CRITICAL MEDICAL INFORMATION
SUCH AS A DIAGNOSIS FOR THE
PSYCH MADE PRESCRIPTION.
NOW THIS IS WHERE IT GETS
COMPLICATED LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
DESCRIBE THE CURRENT PROCESS
THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS TO BE
ABLE TO GO THROUGH THE BETTER
DETERMINE.
IF A CHILD IS BEING OVER
PRESCRIBED HERE WE GO SAID
ARCHER LET IS READY [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ONE EARLY THE MEDICAL BOARD FLAG
THE CASE THEY WANT TO LOOK AT
THEY MUST GO THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES AS
A LIAISON TO ASK FOR PERMISSION
TO CONTRACT THE INDIVIDUAL
FOSTER YOUTH.
MEDICAL BORDEN PROVIDES DSS WITH
UNIQUE IDENTIFYING NUMBER WHICH
DSS THEN HAS TO GO MATCH TO A
NAME OF A CURRENT OR FORMER
FOSTER.
DSS THEN SENDS A LETTER TO THE
LAST KNOWN ADDRESS TO THE FOSTER
YOUTH.
AND OR THE COUNTY ASKING
PERMISSION. FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO CONTACT THE FOSTER
YOUTH.
IF DSS GETS A LETTER BACK WITH
APPROVAL.
THE MEDICAL BOARD THEN MUST
CONTACT THE CHILD TO USE AGAIN
TO ASK FOR AUTHORIZATION. FOR
THE RELEASE OF RECORDS.
THIS PROCESS HAS BEEN PROVEN SO
CUMBERSOME THAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD HAS BEEN UNABLE TO CARRY
OUT.
THEIR A STATUTORY OVERSIGHT
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXAMPLE.
IN THE FIRST BATCH OF CASES THE
MEDICAL BOARD LOOKED INTO.
THE EXPERT WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD FLAG EIGHTY SIX USE THAT
NEEDED MORE INFORMATION.
DSS SINCE THEN EIGHTY SIX
LETTERS OUT BUT ONLY RECEIVED
FIVE RESPONSES.
THOSE FIVE RESPONSES WERE USED
EIGHTEEN OR OLDER. NINE BILLION
MEET THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN IN
AFTER CONTACTING THE USE THE
MEDICAL BOARD WAS ABLE TO GET
AUTHOR ASIA AUTHORIZATION.
FOR THREE THIS BROKEN PROMISE
HAS PROVEN INEFFECTIVE IN
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
YOUTH FOM OVER PRESCRIBING OF
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION.
SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN WILL CUT
THROUGH THE RED TAPE AND FINALLY
ALLOW FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD TO
GET ACCESS WITH THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO CONFIDENTIALLY I
WANT TO STRESS THAT
CONFIDENTIALLY INVESTIGATE.
BY GRANTING AUTHORIZATION WITHIN
A MEDICATION IS AUTHORIZED BY
THE COURTS.
CURRENTLY ALL PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATION FOR MINORS IN FOSTER
YOUTH MUST BE APPROVED BY
JUVENILE COURT JUDGE IN THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY THE JV TO TWENTY
FOUR THAT THE JUDGE HAS TO BE
APPROVED.
UP FROM A MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
IN FRONT OF THEM AS FAR AS THE
PRESCRIBING PATTERNS.
SB THREE SEVEN SEVERAL CREATIVE
PROCESS THAT ESTABLISHES AT THE
TIME APPROVAL OF A PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATION A JUVENILE COURT
JUDGE WILL AUTHORIZE FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO REVIEW THE
DIAGNOSIS.
FROM THAT FORM FOR THE
PRESCRIPTION SHOULD THE MEDICAL
BOARD NEED TO INVESTIGATE.
THIS BILL ALLOWS REQUIREMENTS OF
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR TO BE
REALIZE THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR IN THE SPIRIT A PASS IN
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR APPROVED TO
BE A TO PROTECT.
THESE YOUTH BUT WHAT WE HAVE
FOUND THREE YEARS LATER IT'S
BEEN POSSIBLE TO BE ABLE TO
GATHER THE DATA.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY JENNIFER
SOMOS WHO'S BEEN LIVING THIS
DREAM -- SHE'S CHIEF LEGISLATION
AT THE MEDICAL BOARD AND SHE CAN
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT MAY HAVE AS WELL AS SPEAK
TO ANY CONCERNS THAT ANY MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN HAPPY TO DO SO AS WELL.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
LONG A STATEMENT IN RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR MCGUIRE.
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ARE THERE
OTHERS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
HE COME FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT ANY -- FOLKS WHO ARE
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION WE DO NOT HAVE A
FORMAL OPPOSE POSITION.
BUT AS WE READ THE ANALYSIS IN A
WE JUST RECENTLY GOT OUR OWN
LEGAL ANALYSIS OF THE BILL WE
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THERE MIGHT BE --
SOMEONE WHO HAVE HOLES LEGAL
PRIVILEGE UNDER THE
PSYCHOTHERAPIST PATIENT
PRIVILEGE IN THE EVIDENCE CODE.
WHO HAS EITHER REFUSED ON BEHALF
OF A PATIENT OR HAVE HAS THE
PATIENT HAS -- REFUSED TO SIGN A
RELEASE FOR THAT INFORMATION SO
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT THIS
COULD BE AN END RUN AROUND THE
PRIVILEGE.
AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR MORE
INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
A DETERMINATION ABOUT WHERE WE
LAND ON THIS.
BECAUSE SIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL ASK THE OFFICE
THAT QUESTION IN JUST A MOMENT
ANYBODY ELSE.
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITIONTO
THIS BILL OR WITH QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT NOT WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK OUT TO THE COMMITTEE.
A CENTER DO YOU ARE YOU
REPRESENT ONE OF ADDRESS THAT
CONCERN HAS BEEN RAISED
ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO WORK WITH
MISTER HAGEL SO WE ARE ALSO
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS ON THIS BILL. FOR
WORKING OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD THE MEDICAL BOARD --
IN I HAD A MEETING WITH DSS WE
ALSO HAD A MEETING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
WERE ALSO CURRENTLY MEETING WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL -- ON THIS
BILL AND YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
THAT WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
MEET ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT IS
A BIT OF A COMPLICATED ONE AND
WE NEED TO BE -- TO GET IRONED
OUT BECAUSE THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THE SAFETY PROTECTION OF FOSTER
YOUTH -- AND YOU HAVE MY WORD
THAT WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
WORKING MISTER HAGEL IN ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED.
THAT WITH THAT OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF THE QUESTION IN
FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD AND IT
SHOWS THE THE THIS SEEMS LIKE
EVERY.
PRESCRIPTION WOULD THEN GO TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD FOR SOME OF
THE U. ATION.
IT IS THAT BY UNDERSTANDING AND
THAT WOULD.
DO YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO THEN
HAVE THAT.
GO TO A PROFESSIONAL. TO TO THEN
THE I GUESS IT'S SO IT'S A TIME
MANAGEMENT ISSUE.
IS THAT WORKABLE.
SO I DON'T IT'S NOT THE EVERY
EVERY WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT
EVERYONE'S RECORDS ARE GONNA
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION IT'S
BASICALLY A PRECURSOR TO OUR
PROCESS NOW.
SO THAT AUTHORIZATION WOULD BE
WAITING THERE SO WHEN WE GO
THROUGH THAT DATA USAGE
AGREEMENT AND HAVE OUR EXPERT.
YOU KNOW LOOK AT ALL THE
INFORMATION AND SAY HERE SOME
POTENTIAL INAPPROPRIATE
PRESCRIBING WHEN WE GAVE THAT --
IDENTIFIER NUMBER TO DSS TO
MATCH UP TO FIND OUT WHICH CHILD
IS IF THERE WAS ONE OF THESE ON
FILE THEN WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS IT'S AN
ACQUIRED DESCRIBED WITH.
YOU KNOW DSS SAID IN A LETTER
AND THEN GETTING SOMETHING BACK
AND THEN US IN IN A LETTER IT
WOULD ALREADY BE THERE AND SO
ONCE THAT INAPPROPRIATE
PRESCRIBING IS IDENTIFIED.
AND AND THE YOU KNOW SOMETHING
WAS ON FILE BECAUSE THIS BILL
PASSED THEN WE WOULD JUST BE
ABLE TO GET THE RECORDS LOOK AT
IT HAS NOT EACH ONE WOULD NOT BE.
REQUIRE APPROVED YEAH OKAY THANK
YOU.
RIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS NOT LOOKING FOR A
MOTION BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
BETTER HILL IS MOVE THE BILL.
AS AMENDED.
IT AMEND.
NO BUT LET ME AG I'LL PROVIDE
THE AUTHOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE -- CENTER CHOIR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR GOOD WORK IN THIS AREA
CONTINUE GOOD WORK.
ON A GIVEN THE CHANCE TO MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS JUST WANT
TO COME SEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
RICHER FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH US WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO VERY CAPABLE STAFF WHO.
HAS ALSO BEEN IN THESE MEETINGS --
IN -- LISTEN IN IN IN PROVIDING
FEEDBACK AND JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
I WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION --
DO PASS UP YES SIR AS FOR THEIR
AMENDMENTS THAT SORRY.
NOW [inaudible]
OKAY NOW.
YOU ARE A PROPOSED AMENDMENT
SENATOR PAN.
NO I WASN'T SURE I IS IN THE
DETAIL IN THE CONVERSATION SOUND
LIKE THERE WAS SOMETHING YOU
WERE THAT I DIDN'T KNOW THE
AUTHOR IS JUST COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES ON SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE WITNESS
EARLIER.
OKAY THANK YOU.
I'LL GET TO READY FOR A VOTE.
OKAY THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG RICHER LETTER.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
I LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN.
WILK I WILL BUY.
SENATE REQUIRE THAT HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT WILL HOLD THE
ROLL UP AND WRAPS MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CENTER RUBIO ARE YOU HEAR
YOURSELF OR GET.
YOU UP TO COME ON OUT
[inaudible]
THE TIMING [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
YEAH.
CENTER I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE ALSO
PRESENTING FOR SENATOR HUESO YES
WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE ME THAT
YOU CAN GO IN ANY ORDER YOU WISH
THERE YOU GO.
OKAY WELL.
WHICH PHILLY PRESENTING THAT
FIRST [inaudible] SIX FIFTY OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB SIX FIFTY
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TERM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TâM PROUD TO PRESENT SB SIX
FIFTY AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT RELATES TO
COUNTER MEDICATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST THANK THE
CHAIRMAN AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING REALLY HARD ON THIS BILL.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE TEN
OF THE ANALYSIS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT WHICH ALLOWED
COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH PROGRAMS
TO DISPENSE.
DONATED UNUSED MEDICATIONS
HOWEVER THE BILL WAS LIMITED TO
COUNTY RUN OR CONTRACTED
PHARMACIES AND CANCER MEDICATION
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THIS
PROGRAM.
AS AMENDED SB SIX FIFTY WILL
REQUIRE THE BOARD OF PHARMACY IS
TO WRITE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE REPORT
SHALL IDENTIFY THE BEST
MECHANISMS TO ENABLE THE
TRANSFER OF AND USE COUNTY
MEDICATIONS. TO PERSONS IN NEED
TO ENSURE ACCESS TO NECESSARY
MEDICATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BOARD SHALL
ANALYZE THE EXISTING SURPLUS
MEDICATION COLLECTION AND
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM.
DID IT AND DETERMINE WHAT
MODIFICATIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF PATIENTS
NEEDING CANCER DRUGS.
MR TURN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE TWO
WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER THEIR TESTIMONY ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THIS SET SHORT AND AUTUMN ADEN
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR HERE
FIRST WITNESS.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS --
ALTAMONT IN SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK -- CANCER IS ONE
OF THE LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH
IN THE USTHE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY ESTIMATES THAT ROUGHLY
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION NEW
CASES OF CANCER WILL BE
DIAGNOSED IN THE U. S. IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I'M MORE THAN
FIFTEEN MILLION AMERICANS LIVING
TODAY HAVE A CANCER HISTORY.
NOT ONLY DOES CANCER TAKE AN
ENORMOUS TOLL ON THE HEALTH OF
PATIENTS AS SURVIVORS.
IT ALSO HAS A TREMENDOUS
FINANCIAL IMPACT.
AND TWENTY FOURTEEN US CANCER
PATIENTS PAID NEARLY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS AN OUT OF POCKET
COSTS.
AND THE DISEASE BECAUSE THE
COUNTRY EIGHTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION IN CANCER RELATED HEALTH
CARE SPENDING.
EVEN WITH INSURANCE CANCER
PATIENTS OFTEN FACE
UNPREDICTABLE OR UNMANAGEABLE
COSTS INCLUDING HI COINSURANCE
HI DEDUCTIBLES.
AND I ARE HAVING TO SEEK OUT OF
NETWORK CARE AND NEEDING
TREATMENT THAT IS NOT COVERED BY
THEIR HEALTH PLAN.
AT THE SAME TIME IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR SOME CANCER
PATIENTS TO FIND OUT EARLY IN
THEIR TREATMENT.
THAT THEIR TREATMENT OPTIONS ARE
NOT WORKING AND THIS LEAVES THEM
WITH ON USE AND I NEEDED
MEDICATION -- AS CERTAIN AS BE
SIX FIFTY WOULD HAVE HAD THE
POTENTIAL TO REDUCE WASTE AND
INCREASE TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE -- FOR THEIR DILIGENCE
AND THEIR HARD WORK ANDI THINK
THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
TAKING TODAY.
WILL OFFER CALIFORNIA A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TAKE A STEP BACK AND%
UTILIZE THE GUIDANCE OF THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY TAX HAS THE
BEST.
A SAYS THE BEST COURSE OF
FORWARD AND INSURING THIS
PROGRAM WORKS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU.
THE SET SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATES ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONCOLOGY NOW TO START
BY THANKING SENATOR RUBIO AND
HER STAFF OFFER CHAMPING THIS
ISSUE ON BEHALF OF CANCER
PATIENTS AND THEIR PHYSICIANS.
I'M PLEASED TO BE ARM ON BEHALF
OF AND SUPPORT OF SIX FIFTY THE
BILL IS NEEDED BECAUSE THE
CURRENT DRUG RECYCLING PROGRAM --
IS REALLY FAILING ARE CANCER
PATIENTS WELL IT IS DOING A GOOD
JOB AND AND HELPING SOME
PATIENCE AND SOME LOCAL ENTITIES --
IN TERMS OF DISTRIBUTING AND
UNUSED MEDICATIONS.
ARE CANCER PATIENTS ARE NOT --
BENEFITING FROM THESE PROGRAMS --
WE BELIEVE THAT CANCER PATIENTS --
NEED TO GET SOME RELIEF FROM THE
COST OF THEIR MEDICATIONS AND
AND RECEIVE TIMELY MET ACCESS TO
TIMELY MEDICATIONS AND A PROGRAM --
LIKE THE ONE WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT I THINK WILL LEAD US IN
THAT DIRECTION.
OUR PHYSICIANS SEE CANCER
PATIENTS EVERY DAY WHO HAVE I
NEEDED UNUSED MEDICATIONS IT'S
THE NATURE OF CANCER TREATMENT
AND THEY ALSO SEE EVERYDAY
PATIENTS WHO ARE IN DESPERATE
NEED OF THEIR MEDICATIONS TO
STARS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE -- AND
DON'T WANT TO AND DON'T AND
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT.
A LENGTHY PART OF TIME FOR THEM
TO ACCESS THOSE MEDICATIONS --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE BOARD -- TO CREATE THIS
REPORT WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LAGGING BEHIND IN CREATING SUCH
A PROGRAM THAT WILL ALLOW OUR
PATIENTS ON CALL JUST TO TEAM UP
TO ENSURE MEDICATION IS NOT
WASTED.
AND ENSURE THAT MEDICATION GETS
INTO THE HANDS OF THESE PATIENTS
THAT ARE DESPERATE FOR IT.
I'M AN EXAMPLE OUR PROGRAM HAS
BEEN CREATED IN NEW MEXICO WHERE
IT IS SAFE PATIENTS AND ONE
PRACTICE ALONE MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A
YEAR.
AND WE THINK CALIFORNIA PATIENTS
DESERVE JUST AS MUCH IF NOT MORE --
SB SIX FIFTY IN THIS REPORT WILL
BE A STEP TO FIGURE OUT WHY THE
CURRENT PROGRAM IS NOT WORKING
FOR CANCER PATIENTS.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO CHANGE
IT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
THERE FOR THEM.
SO -- DRIVE A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
SENATOR LET ME JUST SAY THANK
YOU TO YOU -- YOU HAVE A HEART
OF GOLD FOR AND SO MANY WAYS BUT
CERTAINLY -- WE SHARE THAT GREAT
CONCERN FOR CANCER PATIENTS AND
ALL THAT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
AND YEAR.
YOU WITNESSES OF FAST SO A
PROBABLY IDENTIFIED THOSE
CHALLENGES AND BURDENS AND IT'S
IT'S A VERY SCARY TIME AND AND
COST SHOULD BE -- SUCH A
DOMINANT ELEMENT IN TERMS OF
GETTING.
A PROPER TREATMENT AND I I AT
YOUR BILL IS HEADED IN THAT
DIRECTION I THINK WITH YOUR
AMENDMENTS.
IT'S NOT THE STUFF FULLY STEP
FORWARD THAT YOU'D LIKE TO SEE I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT I HOPE THAT IT IS A STEP
FORWARD AND I THINK PART OF OUR
OBLIGATION -- IS TO ENSURE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO ADVANCE THIS IDEA
THAT THE THE WITH THE STUDY
THAT'S DONE THE WORK THAT'S DONE --
IS DONE WITH THE IDEA OF HOW WE
HOW WE CAN DO MORE AND DO BETTER.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE DIRECTION
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO PUSH US
INTO QUITE APPROPRIATELY.
SO -- I THANK YOU FOR BEING A
CHAMPION FOR CANCER PATIENTS AND
BY THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
CLOSING COMMENT JEWISH THANK YOU
AND THE MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME I
ACT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE.
OKAY STAY HERE SENATOR HILL --
CENTER ARCHULETA.
MOVE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
THERE CAN YOU USE THAT YOU
[inaudible]
IT REALLY.
ALL RIGHTYOUR ONE ALL RIGHT SO
IN A MOTION BY SENATOR ISOLATE
AND SENATOR PAN WE COULD -- CALL
THE ROLL THE BILL AS AN AS
AMENDED DO PASSION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE GLAZER.
HI GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
GALGIANI AYE HILL.
AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN.
CAN I WILL.
OKAY THAT BILL HAD -- WITH
[inaudible]
IT ISN'T [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO THANK YOU -- JUST ONE
MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT A I UNDERSTAND SENATOR
HUESO -- IS NOT ABLE TO JOIN US
HERE THIS MORNING.
AND CENTER RUBIO YOU'RE GONNA
PERCENT FOR HAVE THIS IS -- ITEM
TWENTY SB.
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT YES THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SB SEVEN
THIRTY A. WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA TRADE AND SERVICE
OFFICE ADVISORY GROUP TO
PRIORITIZE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
AN INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
INVESTMENT OFFICE IN MEXICO CITY
MEXICO.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND IN FEBRUARY
THE GOVERNOR DESIGNATED
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR COOL KNOCK
AS AS THE STATE'S REPRESENTATIVE
ON INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND
TRADE.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ALSO
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA TRADE
AND SERVICE OFFICE ADVISORY
GROUP CONSISTING OF PRIVATE
SECTOR AND NON GOVERNMENTAL
LEADERS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
EXPLORING.
AND IDENTIFYING THE USE OF NON
STATE FUNDS TO OPEN IN SUPPORT
OFFICE AS PROMOTING CALIFORNIA
TRADE.
AND SERVICES GLOBALLY.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THAT
ADVISORY GROUP TO PRIORITIZE
ESTABLISHING AN OFFICE IN MEXICO
CITY MEXICO.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE FIFTH FLOOR
IT IS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD AS A RESULT IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE EXPAND OUR
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES ABROAD.
AND ENSURE THAT WE REMAIN
COMPETITIVE IN TODAY'S GLOBAL
MARKET.
AS OUR NEIGHBORING COUNTRY THE
TRADE AND INVESTMENT OFFICE IN
MEXICO MAKES SENSE MEXICO IS THE
FIFTEENTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD MORE SPECIFICALLY
CALIFORNIA MEXICO SHARE A ROBUST
TRADE RELATIONSHIP.
NOT ESTABLISHING A TREAT OFFICE
IN MEXICO CITY PUTS CALIFORNIA
AT A HEIGHT DISADVANTAGE TO
TRACK TRADE AND INVESTMENT INTO
OUR STATE.
MEXICO HAS ONE OF THE LARGEST
NETWORKS OF FREE TRADE
AGREEMENTS IN THE WORLD WITH
MORE THAN 90% OF TRADE ACCORDING
OCCURRING UNDER THESE AGREEMENTS.
SINCE MUCH OF THIS TRADE AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY HAPPENS WITH
THE U. S. CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT
TO BENEFIT FROM EXPANDING OUR
POTENTIAL TRADE AND INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WITH MEXICO.
WITH ME TODAY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE IS
DOUGLAS MERE PRACTICING ATTORNEY
OF INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO YOUR
FIRST WITNESS.
WELL THE THINK YOU -- COMMITTEE
I MEAN IS THAT WAS MORE -- I
DAYS SERVED AS AN INTERN FOR AN
OR PRO TEN RIVER RD BACK IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES WHEN I WAS AT
THE DOOR -- AND WE ACTUALLY SET
AT THE COVEN WORLD TRADE MISSION
AND FROM THERE.
THE ORIGINAL.
OFFICE IN MEXICO CITY -- I WAS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO SERVE AS A
DIRECTOR OF THE MEXICO CITY
OFFICE UNDER GOVERNOR.
GRAY DAVIS AND IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE THE ROUTE MIGHT -- THESIS
WHEN I WAS DOING MY EL AL AND
DEGREE AT THE FLETCHER SCHOOL ON
CALIFORNIA DRAFT INTERNATIONALLY
THE NEED FOR AN INTERNATIONAL
PROGRAM -- CELL I THINK YOU WILL.
BE HARD PRESSED TO FIND THE
LARGER SUPPORTER OF RE
ESTABLISHING -- THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE IN MEXICO -- BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS
IN REGARDS -- TO THE BILL THAT
IS BEFORE YOU RIGHT NOW -- I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED. TO
COLLABORATE AND WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I
HAVEN'T HAD TALKS WITH WITH BOTH
OF THEM -- WHAT I AM?
CONCERNED ABOUT IS.
CALIFORNIA MISSING A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY THAT IS BEFORE IT
RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME SINCE
OFFICES WERE CLOSED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR AND I HAD THE
UNFORTUNATE.
DUTY AND OBLIGATION TO CLOSE OUR
OFFICE IN MEXICO CITY BACK IN --
TWO THOUSAND FOUR TO REESTABLISH
CALIFORNIA AS A PRESENCE THAT IT
NEEDS TO HAVE INTERNATIONALLY
AND THE VITAL IMPORTANCETHAT IT
HAS FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD -- AND IN
THAT -- RESPECT I'D LIKE TO
SUBMIT MY MY PAPER -- HANDED TO
YOU AS PART OF THE RECORD THAT
GOES TO THE FORTY YEAR HISTORY.
OF HOW IT DID REGIONAL
INTERNATIONAL PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED BY WAS A STAB LIST
THE PALMS IT HAD AND WHAT LED TO
ITS ULTIMATE DEMISE.
AND WHAT I SEE IN THIS BILL ALL
RIGHT NOW OR ARE MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES IT'S A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE'RE IN A PLACE WHERE.
ACTION IS BETTER THAN NO ACTION.
BUT WE ARE CALIFORNIA AND WE CAN
DO BETTER.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
INPUT AND DIRECTION FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE TENANT
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE -- THEY HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS -- BUT TWO
THINGS DRAMA TENSION.
A NUMBER ONE THE NAME OF THE
OFFICE I WOULD NOT CALL IT THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF TRADE
INVESTMENT BECAUSE WHEN I WAS
THERE.
I'D SAY MAYBE HALF OF MY WORK
WAS IN REGARDS TO ACTUALLY TRADE
INVESTMENT.
THE MAJORITY OF IT WAS WORKING
ON THE POLITICAL AGENDA BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO.
AND OUR RELATIONS WITH THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT -- WHERE
THERE IS AT THE -- WORKING ON
BEHALF OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
ORDERED THE MEMBERS HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
IN PUTTING THROUGH THE KEY --
ISSUES AT STAKE AT THAT TIME AND
THAT WILL PLAY.
INTO EFFECT TODAY AS WE GO
FORWARD SECONDLY IN REGARD TO
THE ISSUE OF FUNDING.
IF CALIFORNIA'S SERIOUS ABOUT.
RE ESTABLISHING -- THE
INTERNATIONAL PRESENCE.
THEN.
THE FUNDING IS GOING TO HAVE TO
COME FROM THE GENERAL ACCOUNT --
AND I'D SAY THE VAST MAJORITY OF
IT.
THERE IS A NEED TO HAVE SOME
PRIVATE FUNDING. TO SUPPORT THE
ACTUAL TRADE PROMOTIONS OR TO
HOST EVENTS BECAUSE CAN'T USE
STATE FUNDS FOR THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THAT'S WHY.
WHEN I WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE IN MEXICO CITY
WE SET UP A FIVE OH ONE C.?
THREE ENTITY -- TO FUND AND TO
THOSE EVENTS -- SO THERE IS THE
NEED FOR THAT [inaudible]
BUT AGAIN IN TO REITERATE.
THE COLLABORATION I GOT THAT I
THINK A PROPOSED TO OTHER
AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE BILL BUT SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TODAY AS A TIME VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF OKAY YES.
THEY SEE THEY MAY BE QUESTIONS
THAT ALONE BUT ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT THE BILL CURRENTLY
ENJOYS COMMITTEE SUPPORT BUT I
TURN TO SENATOR GOT FOR A
QUESTION OR COMMENT.
THE OBVIOUS SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY I JUST YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY
ACTUALLY RAISE THE QUESTION MY
MIND.
WHAT PROBLEM ARE WE TRYING TO
SOLVE?
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER.
TWO WITH THIS PROGRAM IS NOT
BEEN IN PLACE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOUR WHAT OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
MISSED OUT ON OR HAVE THEY
MISSED OUT ON THAT WOULD BE
BETTER FOR CITIZENS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BONE DIDN'T LET ME ANSWER IT
THIS WAY.
WHEN I WAS IN IT?
THE DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA WAS
MEXICO THERE WERE TWENTY EIGHT
OTHER US STATES THAT HAD OFFICES
IN MEXICO CURRENTLY THERE ARE.
NINETEEN THEY'RE COMPETING IN.
HAVING THE INFLUENCE IN MEXICO.
AND CALIFORNIA'S NOT THERE BUT
AT THE SAME TIME CALIFORNIA
TODAY HAS OVER A HUNDRED
PROGRAMS.
IN MEXICO THERE EITHER BEING RUN
THROUGH IT THIS AT A CALIFORNIA
STATE AGENCY OR DEPARTMENT.
THROUGH -- COMMISSIONS AND
THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SYSTEMS.
NOT EVEN TO MENTION CALIFORNIA
FOOD AND DRUG CAL EPA THE ENERGY
COMMISSION.
BUT THERE'S NO OVERALL
[inaudible]
STRATEGIC COORDINATION.
BETWEEN THESE OFFICES AND AND
THAT'S THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS.
RIGHT NOW I'M FOR IT.
VERY GOOD A SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU -- I I APPRECIATE AND
I THINK WE'LL WE'LL WHILE MOVE
THIS LEGISLATION FORD BUT I
WOULD.
YOU KNOW I I THINK BE HELPFUL
BECAUSE I MAKE NOTE AND ANALYSIS --
BEFORE WE CLOSE THEM THE LA L.
LOOKED AT AND SAID THAT THESE
OFFICES DIDN'T REALLY CONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANTLY -- TO EXPORTS ARE
INVESTMENTS AND WELL THAT WAS
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
THAT'S BEEN A WHILE -- EIGHT I
THANK HAVING SOME MORE EVIDENCE --
NOW REALIZE THIS BILL SAYS IT'S
GONNA BE PRIVATE FUNDS ANYWAY SO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT --
CURRENT STATE FUNDS BUT I I
THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL TO HAVE
SOME KIND OF ANALYSIS -- THAT
WOULD DEMONSTRATE -- THAT AN
OFFICE LIKE THIS WOULD -- WE
HAVE WOULD BRING TO IT WHETHER
IT'S FROM OTHER STATES OR OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS YOU MENTIONED AS
MANY OTHER -- OFFICES THERE THAT
THAT THAT THAT THAT ARE THERE
FROM OTHER STATES BUT IT BE GOOD
IF SOMEONE COULD DO AND HOUSES
OF WHICH WHAT KIND OF THEO.
THE NO STATE HOUSE ONE WHAT
EXACTLY DID THEY BRING THAT
ACTUALLY ENDED UP BEING OF
GREATER BENEFIT BECAUSE WE
CERTAINLY HAVE MANY TIGHT TIES
WITH.
MEXICO AND OTHER COUNTRIES THE
QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT IS THIS
WHAT'S THAT SUCH AN OFFICE WOULD
DO IN ADDITION. TO WHAT WE'RE
READY DOING -- WOULD BE HELPFUL
SO.
SO WHILE I CERTAINLY I THINK OF
SUPPORT MOVING THIS BILL FOR
TODAY I'D APPRECIATE HAVING MORE
DATA AND EVIDENCE ABOUT THE
EFFICACY OF OF OF THE OFFICE.
SENATOR PENN CENTER GALGIANI.
AND I WAS HERE'S A STAFF MEMBER
WHEN THE TRADE AND COMMERCE
AGENCY WENT AWAY IT WAS DUE TO
BUDGET CUTS SO IT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WE DIDN'T WANT TO SEE --
TAKEN FROM US HOWEVER BECAUSE WE
HAD TO MAKE SO MNY CUTS BACK AT
THAT TIME THAT WAS ONE OF THE
CASUALTIES.
I'M ALIFORNIA HAS A TREMENDOUS --
ECONOMIC EXCHANGE WITH MEXICO
WHEN IT WITH WHEN REGARDING
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS SELL I SEE
A TREMENDOUS BENEFIT TO THIS
BILL AND ALSO WHAT WE HAVE NOT --
CAPTURED IS THE POTENTIAL GROWTH
THATWE COULD HAVE CAPTURED ALL
THESE YEARS SINCE THE TRADE
AGENCY WENT AWAY SO I AM PLEASED
THAT YOU'RE DOING THE BILL -- I
THOUGHT ABOUT TRYING TO TO DO IT
EARLIER IN THE YEAR WHEN I HEARD
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR COULD UNLOCK
THIS WAS ALSO -- WANTED TO BRING
THAT BACK SO I COMMEND YOU FOR
TAKING THIS ON I THINK IT WILL
BE A TREMENDOUS BENEFIT FOR THE
AG INDUSTRY.
AND MANY OTHER INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE STATE
OF MEXICO.
THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI CENTER
OF RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
FOR SENATOR HUESO YES PLEASE I'M
AN OLD AFRICAN THEY ALL YOUR
YOUR YOUR MESSAGES -- JUST TO
CLOSE SO NOW IS THE TIME TO
ENSURE TO MEXICO'S CIVIC
BUSINESS LEADERS THAT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA VALUE ROBUST TRADE
AN OPEN DIALOGUE WITH THEM.
BY TOSSING THIS ADVISORY GROUP
WITH PRIORITIZING THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF TRADE AND
INVESTMENT OFFICE IN MEXICO CITY
WE CAN MOVE TOWARDS
STRENGTHENING OUR BY NATIONAL.
ECONOMY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO CENTER
GALGIANI DID I TAKE THAT AS A
MOTION.
I DO I HEAR MOTION FROM SENATOR
GALGIANI ON MY RIGHT
[inaudible]
CALLING ALL.
THE NATION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHANG.
CHANG AYE ARCHULETA.
PARTULA I'D DODD.
NOT A GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN.
AND I WILL ALL RIGHT WILL GUY.
ALL RIGHT THE BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO ARE HALF THE CENTER.
I SEE -- CENTER CABALLERO YOU
FOR NEXT UP.
YOU ARE.
WELCOME.
HI THIS IS ITEM EIGHTEEN SB.
SIX NINETY SEVEN THERE CABALLERO
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE HE CAN
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
DIE SENATORS AND PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB. SIX NINETY SEVEN
WHICH WILL MODERNIZE THE
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT PRACTICE TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN UNDERSERVED AREA.
CALIFORNIA'S IT IS EXPECTED TO
FATE FACE IT SHORTFALL OF
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS IN THE
NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS WITH A HUGE
SEARCH SHORTAGES.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE
CENTRAL COAST AND THE SOUTHERN-BORDER AREAS THIS IS DUE TO THE
AN EVEN DISTRIBUTION.
OF CARE ACROSS THE STATE AS WELL
AS A LACK OF SUPPLY IN
CLINICIANS.
IN FACT THE STUDY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO INCLUDED THE
CALIFORNIA COULD SEE A POTENTIAL
SHORTFALL.
OF FOUR THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
CLINICIANS AS SOON AS TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WHILE THERE ARE MANY
PROPOSED SOLUTIONS TO THIS
CRISIS SB SIX NINETY SEVEN
FOCUSES ON ONE IMPORTANT
RECOMMENDATION MADE BY THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH.
WORKFORCE COMMISSION REGARDING
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS FOR P. A.'S.
MANY PH CURRENTLY WORK IN-HOSPITAL SETTINGS WERE ARCHAIC
STATE LAWS INTERFERE WITH
PRACTICE LEVEL DECISIONS ABOUT
HOW PATIENT CARE TEAMS CAN BEST
MEET THE QUALITY AND ACCESS
NEEDS OF PATIENTS.
REGULATE REGULATIONS -- THAT
PA'S ARE UNDER THAT WERE WRITTEN
DECADES AGO HAVE NOT PROGRESSED
THE WAY PRACTICING MEDICINE HAS
AND IMPOSE A BURDEN UPON BOTH
THE PA AND THE PHYSICIAN.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS CREATED A
DISINCENTIVE TO HIRE PA'S.
THE DISINCENTIVE IS CONTRIBUTED
A LACK OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES
ACROSS OUR STATE BUT ESPECIALLY
IN RURAL AREAS THIS IS WHY WE
HAVE BEEN REDUCED SB SIX NINETY
SEVEN WHICH WOULD ELIMINATE TH
OUTMODED REQUIREMENTS THAT EACH
PA WORK WITH A SINGLE PHYSICIAN.
AND AND THE DISPARITIES BETWEEN
PA'S AND OTHER MEDICAL PROVIDERS
WITH SIMILAR SCOPE OF PRACTICE
PROFESSIONAL REGULATIONS.
SPECIFICALLY -- SB SIX NINETY
SEVEN WILL GRANDFATHER IN.
CURRENT DELEGATION OF SERVICE
AGREEMENTS AND TRANSITION PO P.
H.OVER TO A STREAMLINED PRATT
PRACTICE AGREEMENT AND REMOVE
REQUIREMENTS FOR MEDICAL RECORDS
REVIEW AND CO SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO REMOVE THE
NUMERICAL LIMIT PAC CAN BE
SUPERVISED BY A PHYSICIAN AT ANY
ONE TIME AND STREAMLINED THE
PRESCRIBING PRACTICES BY
INCREASING PHYSICIAN TO PA RATIO
TO SEX.
THESE UPDATES HAVE COME FROM
EXTENSIVE COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ENSURING THAT MUCH THAT HAS BEEN
PUT INTO THE UPDATE.
BY MODERNIZING THE OPERATIONAL
PRACTICE AND CREATING MORE
FLEXIBLE WORK ARRANGEMENTS THE
BILL WILL INCENTIVIZE POSITIONS
TO UTILIZE PA'S TO THEIR FULLEST
POTENTIAL WHICH WILL EXPAND
HEALTH CARE OPPORTUNITIES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I. BUT WITH ME TODAY IS TOM
RILEY FROM.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TOM RILEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY PA'S
OF FIRST WELL I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR CAFIERO FOR CARRYING
THIS A VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE.
I AND HER REMARKABLE STAFF BUT
HI EQUALLY A YOUR AMAZING STAFF
WHO HAS ESSENTIALLY WORK THROUGH
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS.
TO COME UP WITH THIS PRODUCT AND
I JUST I KNOW YOU KNOW THEY'RE
REMARKABLE BUT I THINK IT NEEDS
TO BE MENTIONED -- AS WELL AS MR
BELOW MENTIONED EARLIER -- TWO
THINGS OF IMPORTANCE IN THIS
BILL -- ONE PA'S ARE REMARKABLE --
IT INDIVIDUALS AND PROFESSIONALS
DOING GOD'S WORK OUT THERE IN IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS ALLOWS THEM
TO DO IT EVEN MORE EFFECTIVELY
AND EFFICIENTLY PARTICULARLY IN
AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE THERE
IS DIRE NEED.
PEOPLE MAY HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO TO
HEALTH CARE -- SECOND.
THIS DOES IT IN A WAY WHICH
CONTINUES SUPERVISION IT ALLOWS
FOR INSTEAD OF APA TO BE AN
EXTENSION OF A PHYSICIAN IT
ALLOWS PHD EXTENSIONS OF MANY
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS.
I WITH ME TODAY IS JEREMY ADLER --
WHO IS A PA OPERATING IN A SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I LIKED HIM
JUST TO SAY A FEW WORDS IF YOU
MAY?
I AM P. A GERMAN NOW THEIR
PRACTICE IN SAN DIEGO AND PAIN
MANAGEMENT I'VE BEEN IN PRACTICE
LAST TWENTY YEARS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF P. A.'S.
I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME --%
TO PROVIDE SOME BRIEF COMMENTS.
THE MAYES PRACTICE WITH IS
REALLY WITHIN THE DNA OF THE P.
A PROFESSION THAT WE HAVE.
WORK WITH PHYSICIANS AND WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
POSITIONS ONE OF THE THINGS I
THINK THAT REALLY SETS APART
PIECES ARE FLEXIBILITY IN THE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE.
WE ARE ALL EDUCATED -- THROUGH
pGRADUATING TODAY GRADUATES WITH
A GRADUATE DEGREE.
AND TO FIND SOLUTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE I THINK%
WE ARE WELL POSITIONED. TO
ENHANCE THE POWER FLEXIBILITY AT
THE PRACTICE LEVEL REALLY
FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT WE'RE HOPING
HERE IS TO MOVE THE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL.
CURRENT PRACTICE TO REALLY
EMPOWER A PRACTICE LEVEL
DETERMINATION OF THE PA AND THE
POSITION TEAM.
AND WITH THAT I'M HERE CERTAINLY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MAKING ALL RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REALLY JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE THANKS TO THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR ALL OF THE
WORK.
AND TO YOUR STAFF FOR HURT.
I'M DILIGENCE AND PATIENCE AS WE
WORK THROUGH ALL OF THE ISSUES
OF THE SPELL -- IT IS COME A
LONG WAY AND WITH THE TECHNICAL
MOMENT SEE AMAZES FOR THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT DO I
NEED TO USE THE MIKE MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RANDALL
HAGER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THIS BILL
WERE VERY PLEASED A SUPPORT.
IT AND WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE
PROSPECT THAT THIS CAN HELP
EXTEND PSYCHIATRIC CARE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THE ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS I CONCUR
WITH THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AMBER CAM WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND THE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR TO MAN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE
MIRACLES EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AS
WELL AS A CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
THEIR COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY WE
DO NOT HAVE AN OPPOSE POSITION --
OUR FOLKS REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS THEY'VE HAS EXPRESSED
SOME CONCERNS OVER THE CHANGE IN
THE SUPERVISION RATIO FROM FOUR
TO ONE THE SIX TO ONE I'M WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
STILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR SPONSORS OF THE BILL
MCGEORGE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYBODY ELSE THAT WANTS TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OR THE NEUTRALITY
YOUR ME WITH QUESTIONS OKAY.
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR A QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SENATOR HANNAH.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU SACRAMENTO FOR FOR BRING
THIS FORD EIGHT NOW I THINK IT
MAKES SOME VERY IMPORTANT STEPS
IN TERMS OF UPDATING THE AYE
GUIDELINES.
ON PS I I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE SUPERVISION RATIO
CHANGE.
BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE MAY MAY NOT
REALIZE THAT -- FOR EXAMPLE THE
RATIO -- FOUR TO ONE COMES FROM --
ACTUALLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LOOKING AT HOW MANY --
PHYSICIANS A A SO IN RESIDENCY
TRAINING I WAS THE REST OF THE
TRAIN DIRECTOR -- WE WERE NOT
PERMITTED -- TO SURPRISE MORE
THAN.
FOUR FOR PRESENTS HIS ACTIONS AT
A TIME AND AND STILL BELT
MEDICARE AND THAT WAS THE CMS
GUIDELINES.
AND I THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW I I
DO THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME MORE CONSIDERS SOME
CONSIDERATION ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
IS THAT NUMBER IN THE END --
BECAUSE OTHERWISE THEN YOU'RE
JUST A NAME ON A PIECE OF PAPER
IT'S NOT SUPER VISION ISN'T
ACTUALLY HAPPENING AND I THINK
WE'VE HAD THIS DISCUSSION BEFORE
SOME PREVIOUS HEARINGS.
I THINK AT NE POINT DOES
PROPOSAL THAT WELL SINCE YOU
COULD DO FOR YOU COULD DO FOR IN
SEASON FOUR PA'S NOW YOU NOW CAN
SUPERVISE TWELVE PEOPLE ON
REALISTICALLY.
AS SOMEONE WHO'S HAD PASSED THE
SUPERVISORS AT SHE HAD TO
SUPERVISE -- OTHER UP SPECIALS
PARTICULARLY ACTUALLY INCLUDING
OTHER PHYSICIANS.
THERE'S A CERTAIN POINT WHERE
YOU'RE NOT REALLY ABLE TO TRULY
SUPERVISE AND AND AND AND AND SO --
THAT IS AN AREA THAT I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS -- BECAUSE THE FOR
DEBT IF THERE'S A BASIS FOR THE
FOR SO I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THE
BASIS FOR THE SIXES.
AND BEING SURE THAT -- THAT WE
HAVE SOME.
BECAUSE THIS THAT DOESN'T ONLY
AFFECT THIS BILL RIGHT WITH P.
A.'S BUT ALSO THEN START TALKING
ABOUT WELL WHAT ABOUT THIS RATIO
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS.
EXACTLY WHAT IS THE WORKLOAD
EXPECTED OF THE SUPERVISOR AND
TO BE SURE THAT THERE IS
ADEQUATE SUPERVISION.
AND THAT WE MAINTAIN PATIENT
SAFETY SO I MEAN I I SUPPORT
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THE BILL AND THE OTHER
PROVISIONS I THINK YOU KNOW IT
AGAIN MAKES SENSE -- BUT I WANT
TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO GO ON THE RATIO -- SO
IS THE FORD THERE WAS A
RATIONALE FOR THAT -- THE SIX
I'D BE I'D APPRECIATE HAVING --
MORE DATA OR EVIDENCE AS TO WHY
SIX IS OKAY AND AMOUNT OF WHAT
THE WORKLOAD EXPECTED AS A
SUPERVISOR EXAMPLE AT SIX IS A
SURPRISED AND NOT DO ANY
CLINICAL WORK SO THAT I CAN
ACTUALLY ADEQUATELY SUPERVISE --
THAT'S GONNA BE IT SHOULD BE A
QUESTION SO WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE SOMEONE SPENDING ALL THE
TIME.
AND THEN THEY'RE NOT SUPERVISING
RIGHT SO EXACTLY WHAT IS THE
EXPECTATION THAN OF THE
SUPERVISOR OF WHEN YOU HAVE SIX
PEOPLE YOU'RE TRYING TO KEEP
TRACK OF AND ALL THE PATIENTS
ARE TO IF IT'S REALLY ALL THE
PATIENTS ARE TAKING CARE OF ME
AND SHOULD BE SURE THAT YOU.
CAN REVIEW AND BE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW THINGS ARE BEING MISSED AND
SO FORTH.
WITH PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR --
SWIMBAIT THE SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
IN THIS BILL IS TAKING DECISIONS
THAT ARE MADE AT THE PRACTICE
LEVEL -- THAT ARE OW DICTATED
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
THE PRACTICE LEVEL.
AND SAYING.
IF YOU SEEN ONE PRACTICE YOU
SEEN ONE PRACTICE WE'RE ALL
DIFFERENT -- WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT CONSTRAINTS AND WE
ALSO HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS FOR
MEETING PATIENT NEEDS.
AND SO MUCH OF THE FLEXIBILITY
IN THIS BILL COMES.
TO THE PRESS IT TO THE PRACTICE
LEVEL TO PUT IN.
THOSE.
SIGN DOCUMENTS THIS IS WHAT YOU
MAY DO AND WHAT YOU MAY NOT DO.
IN IN PASSING THAT FROM THE
STATE TO THE PRACTICE WE HAD
MANY DISCUSSIONS -- WITH THE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND WITH
OTHERS ABOUT WHAT FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF THOSE RATIOS OUGHT TO
BE -- AT MY I'M NOT GIVING AWAY
ANY SECRETS MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
SAID WE ARE ON RECORD AS HAVING
SUPPORTING ONE TO SIX RATIO --
IF THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE P.
A COMMUNITY WOULD LIKE WE'RE ON
THAT SAME PAGE IT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT A PRACTICE THAT ALL
PRACTICES ARE IMMEDIATELY GOING
TO GO TO A ONE SIX RATIONS.
SOME MAY BE A ONE TO ONE RATIO
SOME MAY BE WE HAVE A NEW
PHYSICIAN.
AND WE DON'T FEEL THAT THAT
POSITION SHOULD BE SUPERVISING
ANY.
WE HAVE A NEW P. A. N. WE THINK
THAT THAT P. A. SHOULD BE VERY
CAREFULLY SUPERVISED IN DE.
THAT ENDED CERTAINLY.
I THINK THIS IS AN HOUR LIMIT
RIGHT SO I WAS EACH PRACTICE
SITUATION BUT I THINK THERE'S A
CERTAIN POINT WHERE THAT OUR
LIMIT -- WE NEED TO FIGURE OT
WHERE THAT LINE IS BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THEN YOU ARE TO USE
THAT YOU AND I MEAN THAT'S THE
SITUATION THAT'S REASON WHY CMS
HAD THOSE GUIDELINES.
THEY SAID WE REALLY WANT YOU WE
DO KNOW.
THAT PROTECT PATIENTS WE NEED TO
BE SURE TO ACTUAL SUPERVISION
GOING ON SO THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME -- EXAMINATION OF EXACTLY
HOW MUCH TIME IT TAKES TO
SUPERVISE EVEN AT THAT HOUR
LIMIT SO THAT.
ACTUALLY THERE IS APPROPRIATE
PATIENT SAFETY SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE AND I THINK CERTAINLY
THAT'S ROLE FOR THIS COMMITTEE
SO THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE A RACIAL
THE FIRST PLACE ALWAYS WOULD
JUST SAY FOR WHATEVER BUT AND
AND SO I THINK.
WE'LL.
IT'D BE HELPFUL TO HAVE A BETTER
IDEAAS TO HOW WE'RE GOING TO
HOW WE STAB WISH THAT NUMBER --
SO IS THAT THERE WAS A RATIONALE
FOR THE ONE FOUR ONE CAN ARGUE
HOW GOOD OF A RATIONALE BUT
WE'RE GOING TO THAT ONE THE SIX
I MEAN BEEN SOMEONE'S GONNA
PROPOSE.
ONE EIGHT ON THE TEN AT WHAT PUT
YELP.
SO AND AND REALIZE ALSO THE
OTHER THING THIS BILL DOES IT
SERVE DECREASES SOME OF THE I
GUESS ALL PAPERWORK WORKLOAD
RIGHT SIGNING STUFF LIKE THAT SO.
BUT IN TERMS OF ACTUAL
SUPERVISION I WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE ESTABLISHED RATIOS THAT
ARE THAT WILL STILL PROTECT
PATIENTS.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
OUT LAWCENTER COVER I REMEMBER
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A BILL
BEFORE YOU INTRODUCED IT NICE
TODAY ARE YOU SURE THIS IS A BIG
HEAVY LEFT IT SEEMS LIKE
TECHNICAL AND SMALL BUT DISCOVER
PRAXIS IS CAN BE VERY VERY
DIFFICULT AND YOU SAID YOU
WANTED TO TRY TO MOVE.
AHEAD YOU THOUGHT YOU COULD FIND
COMMON GROUND -- AND YOU HAVE.
AND I THINK THAT THE BILL BEFORE
US TODAY.
IS A REFLECTION OF OF YOUR HARD
WORK OF THE THE SUPPORTERS AND
THE CERTAINLY OUR STAFF HERE AT
THE COMMITTEE.
I TO GET US TO THIS PLACE WHERE
THERE'S SOME STILL QUESTIONS
BEING ASKED BUT THEY FOR THE
MOST PART I THINK THIS BILL.
HAS REALLY MOVE FORWARD IN A
VERY POSITIVE WAY IN AN
IMPORTANT WAY.
AS WE WORK.
TO PROTECT PATIENT SAFETY AND
HEALTH BUT ALSO TRY TO LOWER
COST HEALTH CARE COSTS WHICH WE
KNOW ARE BECOMING BIGGER AND
BIGGER BIRDS I APPLAUD YOU AND
THE SPONSORS AND ALL THAT HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS SO
FAR TO TO BRING THE BILL TO ITS
CURRENT.
SITUATION I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
TODAY AND THANK YOU AGAIN.
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE ROBUST CALM CONVERSATION --
I DO WANT TO HAVE SHOW MY
APPRECIATION STAFF THEY DID A
TERRIFIC JOB OF HELPING US -- TO
TO WEAVE THROUGH THE PIECES THAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY.
AND CENTER THE BILL'S BEING
PROPOSED -- WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'RE CORRECTING THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY LOOKING FOR A
MOTION FROM THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS.
SENATOR WELCOME OF THE BILL WITH
THE AMENDMENTS AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS THIS IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. TO PUT DO PASSES
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR
CALL THE ROLL GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE CHIANG.
TRYING AYE ARCHULETA.
ACTUALLY I DODD.
GALGIANI.
AT ANY AYE HILL.
HILL AYE AND LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN.
ALL RIGHT WELL GUY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO THE BILL IS OUT EIGHT
ZERO THINK YOUR IMAGE THIS IS ME
HOLD.
MISSING SOMEONE.
ALL RIGHT EIGHT ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT.
OF TWENTY THREE OKAY.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES WERE
GONNA PUT ON CALL FOR US TO
MEMBERS VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THE CENTER I'M BURGER.
CENTER I'M BURKE COME ON UP
WELCOME.
OF YET AND I SAID.
RANG BREAK.
THIS IS.
THIS IS I HAVE NINETEEN SB.
SEVEN THIRTY SIX CENTER YOU CAN
BE ANYTIME YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE.
WHO WORKED -- QUITE VIGOROUSLY
TO HELP IMPROVE HIS BILL.
IT HAS BEEN AMENDED THIS MORNING
THE VISION REMAINS THE SAME BUT
SOME OF THE EXECUTION OF THAT
VISION HAS BEEN CHANGED A BIT.
SO HERE'S THE VISION THE VISION
OF THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA IN PARTICULAR
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE COMPETITIVE WITH
OTHER CITIES AND COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
TERMS OF ATTRACTING EVENTS -- I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A GREAT DEAL
OF EMPHASIS ON SPORTING EVENTS
AND THAT'S PART OF IT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY.
OUR CINEMATIC EVENTS
AGRICULTURAL EVENTS -- OTHER
PERFORMANCES OTHER FESTIVALS
THAT KIND OF THING THAT ARE
BEING STAGED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY CALIFORNIA.
NEEDS TO BE COMPETITIVE THE
VISION THE BILL WAS TO PROVIDE.
AN INCENTIVE FOR CITIES TO BE
ABLE TO ATTRACT THESE KINDS OF
EVENTS.
BY EXTENDING ALONE IT'S BEEN
CHANGED.
AND AND SO YOU MAY NOT BE AWARE
THE CHANGE THE CHANGES IS TO
ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE TO
BASICALLY EXAMINE THIS ISSUE AS
TO HOW WE CAN MAKE.
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
COMMUNITIES COMPETITIVE WITH
OTHER CITIES AND COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY THE TASK
FORCE IS TASKED WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY EXPLORING THIS
ISSUE.
AND REPORTING BACK TO
LEGISLATURE -- WE HAVE SEVERAL
WITNESSES HERE WITH US TODAY.
TESTIFIED IN CONNECTION WITH THE
BILL -- MISTER BURSTS OF WITH
THE ANAHEIM OF VISIT AMERICA
ANAHEIM THANK YOU J. FOR BEING
HERE.
AND AND ALSO CASSANDER COSTELLO
WITH VISIT SAN FRANCISCO THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CHAMBER US AND I
REPRESENT VISIT ANAHEIM AS WELL
AS THE ORANGE COUNTY VISITORS
SOCIAIS SHIN.
AND A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE DO
THIS SENATE BILL SEVEN THIRTY
SIX THIS TYPE OF FUND IS NOT NEW
TO OUR INDUSTRY.
IN FACT SIMILAR PROGRAMS ARE IN
PLACE IN TEXAS AND LOUISIANA IN
A RECENT ONE JUST PASSED IN OHIO --
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE I'VE HAD WITH THE
WITH THE PROGRAM WITH IN TEXAS
THE PROGRAM IN TEXAS IS INTENDED
FOR TWO CATEGORIES. ONE OF THE
INTENDED FOR MEGA EVENTS SUCH AS
A SUPERBOWL.
THE OTHER EVENTS TRUST FUND WAS
INTENDED TO GROW THE AMATEUR
SPORTS MARKET FROM NCAA
CHAMPIONSHIPS TO OLYMPIC
QUALIFYING TYPE.
EVENTS.
THE PHONE STRUCTURE LOT FOR
HOSTING ENTITIES APPLY FOR
REIMBURSEMENT OF FUNDS NECESSARY
TO SECURE AND HOST THE EVENT.
REIMBURSEMENT WAS BASED ON
INCREMENTAL TAX DOLLARS THAT
WERE COLLECTED BY THE STATE DUE
TO THE HOSTING THE EVENT.
THEY COULD NOT THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN HOSTED IN ANOTHER STATE.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF A LARGE
DESTINATION IN DALLAS AND A
SMALLER DESTINATION IN OR
ARLINGTON WE WERE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THESE FUNDS FOR
SUPERBOWL AN NBA ALL STAR GAME.
A FINAL FOUR BASKETBALL
CHAMPIONSHIP AND THE AMERICAN
CUTTING HORSE EVENT ALSO HELD IN
THE DALLAS FORT WORTH AREA.
WE WERE ALSO ABLE TO ADD THE
ACADEMY OF COUNTRY MUSIC AWARDS
TO THE EVENTS TRUST FUND TO THE
IMPACT RESULTING AND HOSTING OF
THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY SHOW.
MOVING FROM LAS VEGAS FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A DECADE IN FACT
WE WON THE BID AGAINST A
COMPETING CALIFORNIA CITY.
THE LARGER IMPACT WAS ON SMALLER
DESTINATIONS WHICH WERE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE FUND TO HOST AMATEUR
SPORTS EVENTS TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
MANY OF THESE EVENTS REQUIRE BID
FEES AND OTHER HOSTING COST
WHICH SYMBOL SMALLER
DESTINATIONS DO NOT ALWAYS HAVE
ACCESS TO SUCH FUNDS.
THE EVENTS TRUST FUND ALLOWED
CITIES SUCH AS COLLEGE STATION
IN ARLINGTON TEXAS. TO HAVE A
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE OVER
SIMILAR CITIES AND OTHER STATES.
RESULTING IN A BOOMING SPORTS
MARKET IN TEXAS POSITIVELY
IMPACTING THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
YOUTH WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
EACH YEAR DOZENS OF CULTURAL
SPORTING AGRICULTURAL AND
ENTERTAINMENT EVENTS ATTRACT
INTERNATIONAL ATTENTION PROVIDE
AN IMPORTANT SOURCE OF REVENUE
FOR HOTELS.
RESTAURANTS RETAIL AND
TRANSPORTATION AND CREATE AN
EXPANSIVE SHOWCASE FOR THE HOST
CITY AND COUNTY.
THESE EVENTS FOSTER INNOVATION
AND ENCOURAGE SPILLOVER EFFECTS
THAT CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OTHER INDUSTRIES BY ATTRACTING
INVESTMENT.
TOURISM CONSUMER SPENDING AND
GENERATING NEW TAX REVENUES.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
BILL AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU I'M GONNA
GO TO YOUR SECOND WHICH IS FOR
JUST POINT OUT THIS COMMITTEE
THAT.
THIS BILL DOES ENJOY COMMITTEE
SUPPORTS A SECOND WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CASSANDRA COSTELLO AND I
REPRESENT THE SAN FRANCISCO
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION AND I ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE PROUD
SPONSORS OF SB.
SEVEN THIRTY SIX CALIFORNIA
NEEDS A CREATIVE ECONOMY AND
SENT TO FIND TO ASSIST LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND COMPETING WITH
OTHER STATES TO ATTRACT AND
BRING MAJOR CREATIVE ECONOMY
EVENTS TO CALIFORNIA.
IN CALIFORNIA THE CREATIVE
INDUSTRY SUPPORT TWO POINT SIX
MILLION JOBS OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY EIGHT BILLION IN
LABOR INCOME AND SIX HUNDRED AND
FIVE BILLION IN ANNUAL OUTPUT.
OF THOSE TWO POINT SIX MILLION
TOTAL JOB THIS ONE MILLION OF
THEM REPRESENT WORKERS DIRECTLY
EMPLOYED IN THE CREATIVE
INDUSTRY.
AND ONE POINT SIX MILLION ARE
JOBS INDIRECTLY GENERATED BY THE
STATE'S CREATIVE INDUSTRIES.
THE CREATIVE ECONOMY INCLUDES
ALL CREATIVE ACTIVITIES WITHIN
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES AND CREATIVE
OCCUPATIONS.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE STATES IN AMERICA THE
STRENGTH OF OUR DIVERSITY
BROADENS THE UMBRELLA AND
DESCRIPTIONS OF CREATIVE ECONOMY
EVENTS TO INCLUDE A WIDE VARIETY
OF TOPICS AND THEMES.
THAT ARE UNIQUE TO A PARTICULAR
CITY COUNTY OR REGION WITH IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITHIN CALIFORNIA
WITH MUCH NEEDED FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO SUCCESSFULLY COMPETE
IN ATTRACTING CREATIVE ECONOMY
EVENTS.
WE THINK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US AND
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
COLLABORATION AS THIS BILL
PROCEEDS TO THE PROCESS THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISS PATTY MCDONOUGH FROM LA
TOURISM.
HE SAID A ME TOO YOUR WELCOME TO
GET A SUMMARY STATEMENT IF YOU
WISH.
OKAY SO I'LL BE BRIEF AND I
STATEMENT OKAY -- A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS OF
THE COMMITTEE Y NAME IS PATTY
MAKE JANET AND I'M REPRESENTING
LOS ANGELES TOURISM AND
CONVENTION BOARD -- AND I'M
PLEASED TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND FROM
ANAHEIM IN BEING ONE OF THE
SPONSORING BODIES ALONG WITH THE
SAN DIEGO VISITORS AUTHORITY WHO
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY -- WE
KNOW FROM OUR ECONOMIC IMPACT
STUDIES AND STUDIES HAVE
RECENTLY DONE BY MICROECONOMICS
THAT MAJOR EVENTS DELIVER
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC IMPACT TO
THE HOST REGION WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THESE EVENTS HAVE A
SPILLOVER EFFECT -- FROM MANY
OTHER REGIONS WITHIN THE STATE
AS A LEISURE VISITORS TEND TO
VISIT MULTIPLE DESTINATIONS WHEN
VISITING CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU CAN SEE FROM THE DIVERSE
LIST OF FORTY PLUS SUPPORT
LETTERS THAT WE'VE RECEIVED FOR
THAT YOU RECEIVED -- WE GOT
LETTERS FROM BY BUSINESSES
CULTURAL ORGANIZATIONS VENUES
AND TOURISM OFFICES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THE REPRESENT A BROAD
RANGE OF CITIES FROM LARGE TO
MID SIZE CITIES AND MANY SMALL
DESTINATIONS.
BOTH IN URBAN AND IN MORE RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT STATE INITIATIVE
IS ESSENTIAL AND ENABLING CITIES
OF ALL SIZES SUCCESSFULLY
ATTRACT CREATIVE ECONOMY EVENTS
THE CALIFORNIA.
AND ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
MICROPHONE JUST ME TO THIS PLACE
YES THE RETURN COVERAGE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU A CORTES STROKES VISIT
CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND ALSO THEY
COLLEAGUES AT TRI VALLEY THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATT LEWIS VISIT
RICHMOND CA SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTER GERMAN MEMBERS JOE L<c.cyan>G</c>
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES RAMS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU [inaudible]
GOV WRAPS.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN STREET OVER
HALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
TAMMY MILLER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I SING THAT WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION OR COMMENTS.
THE NOT I HAVE A MOTION OF
CENTER HILL AS CENTER NUMBER WE
LIKE TO CLOSE WOULD LIKE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
FOR THERE HILLS MOVE THE BILL --
IS THERE WITH AMENDMENTS.
NOW I BELIEVE.
WITH WITH IT WAS AMENDED THIS
WHITE WE NEED -- TO EXCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS IF SO WE DO ALL RIGHT
WE DON'T.
DOUBT.
DO WELL WITH ASKED.
THE PAST.
FOUR THE MOTIONS TO PASS.
A TO APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE CHIANG.
CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCH LE AYE DODD.
AYE GALGIANI.
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN HI AND I WILL
WRITE WILL GUIDE CENTER THE BILL
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET APPLE
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU AND ALL YOUR
THANK YOU FOR COMING UP FOR SHE
HAD A RIGHT SENATOR PAN ARE YOU
READY TO GO.
BUT THERE'S NO RATIOS IN THIS
NEXT BILL HER AGO HI SENATOR PAN
IS SB -- FIVE FIFTY SIX ITEM.
FIVE BEGIN AS YOU'RE READY OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
FIRST OF ALL I WANT.
TO START OFF BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH --
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL AND
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS --
THIS BILL SB FIVE FIVE SIX
AMENDS THE PROFESSIONAL LAND
SURVEYORS ACT.
LAND SURVEYING IS A HIGHLY
TECHNICAL TRADE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY INVOLVES A
PERFORMANCE OF SURVEYS USING
MATHEMATICS AND THE AND PHOTO
GRANT CHEMISTRY THIS DEVILISH
PROPERTY LINES ARE THE
BOUNDARIES OF ANY PARCEL OF LAND
RIGHT OF WAY AND EASEMENTS.
THESE BOUNDARIES ARE USED
THROUGHOUT THE ENTRE PROJECT TO
ENSURE CONSTRUCTION PLANS ARE
BEING FOLLOWED CORRECTLY.
HOWEVER THE BOARD FOR
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LANCER IS
A GEOLOGIST AND PROFESSIONALS IN
THE INDUSTRY ARE SEEING AN
INCREASE AND UNLICENSED ACTIVITY
DUE TO THE BAD SO ATTRACTED
KNOWLEDGE HE WE'VE ALSO SEEN
SOME CONFUSION ABOUT SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL TERMS IN THE ACT.
SB FIVE FIVE SIX WOULD CLARIFY
THESE TECHNICAL TERMS REFLECT
THAT TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES IN
THE FIELD AND CLOSE LOOPHOLES IN
THE ACCESS DECADES OLD
DEFINITIONS OF LAND SURVEYING
WORK.
DEFINITIONS OF WHO MAY OR MAY
NOT PERFORM SUCH WORK THIS BILL
IS NOT TO CONSTRAIN A LIMIT THE
PRACTICES OF OTHER CRAFTS OR
TRADES IN THE FIELD BUT THE
CRACKDOWN ON UNLICENSED
ACTIVITIES.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO ENHANCE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE BOARD
FOR PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS AND
OTHER STATE LICENSING BOARDS BY
REQUIRING THAT VALLEY COMPLAINTS
OF UNLICENSED LANCER ACTIVITIES.
ARE SHARED WITH BOARDS THAT
REGULATE HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AND
BOARDS THAT REGULATE WAGES AND
OTHER LABOR REQUIREMENTS WITHIN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
I WOULD MENTION HERE THAT I'VE
BEEN HEARING SOME FEEDBACK ABOUT
THE TERM VALID COMPLAINTS NEED
TO BE NARROWED DOWN IN OUR
OFFICE OF THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL OR COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE BOARD AND
COMMITTEE STAFF TO RESOLVE THIS
ISSUE.
FINALLY THIS BOARD WOULD ENSURE
EMPLOYER ACCOUNTABILITY BY
ESTABLISHING A CERTIFICATE OF
AUTHORITY THAT BUSINESS WHICH IN
FOR FORMS ARE OFFERS PERFORMED
LAND SURVEYING MUST OBTAIN PRIOR
TO OFFERING THOSE SERVICES AND
AUTHORIZES THE BOARD TO CONSIDER
ESTABLISHING A NEW FIND FOR A
BUSINESS ACTING AS A
PROFESSIONAL LAND SURVEYING
WITHOUT.
A CERTIFICATE THERE WITH ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THE
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
WITNESSES FROM TWO TO WORKERS
SPONSORS THE INTERNATIONAL UNION
OF OPERATING ENGINEERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CIVIL
ENGINEERS AND LANCE AFFAIRS
ASSOCIATION SPEC WE ASK WHEN I
BUT THANK YOU SENATOR PAN.
YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
BUT TIM CRIMMINS REPRESENT
INTERNATIONALLY OF OPERATING
JUNIOR SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
WELL AS THE SENATOR SAID THIS IS
AN ATTEMPT TO CLARIFY WHEN AND
WHERE IT A LICENSED AND
CERTIFIED SURVEYOR SHALL BE USED
BUT ALSO SHOULD BE USED AND THIS
ISN'T A PRINCIPAL CLASS CLASS
FOR US AND SURVEYORS ARE USED ON
ALL OUR OUR MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS HERE IN THE STATE.
AND AGAIN THIS DOESN'T LIMIT
YOUR TOOL OF TRADE YOU CAN STILL
USE A TRIPOD EVEN IF YOU ARE OR
ARE NOT A LICENSED SURVEYOR IT'S
ONLY WHEN IT LICENSE SERVING
PRACTICES REQUIRED GET.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YES I'M JOHN RECTOR ON WITH
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
WE ARE A PART OF THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING GROUP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT REPRESENTS.
ALMOST A THOUSAND SURVEYORS AND
OVER A HUNDRED FIRMS WORKING IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY AND WE SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU JOHN OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ALEX COLDER -- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA ENGINEERS AND
LANCE FOR SOLICITATION -- HERE
TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR SB.
FIVE FIVE SIX OUR MAIN POINT
HERE IS TO ADDRESS NOW MY SINCE
PRACTICE AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC.
WE ARE CLARIFYING -- THREE
THINGS WE ARE CLARIFYING
TECHNICAL TERMS.
IMPLEMENTING A NEW
ACCOUNTABILITY PROGRAM FOR
EMPLOYERS.
BY TO EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT -- CURRENTLY IN THE
PROFESSIONAL LIABILITY FOLLOWS
THE LICENSEE EITHER MYSELF OR
ANY ANY OF MY FELLOWS -- IF I
LEAVE FROM COMPANY A AND I GOT A
COMPANY BE.
FRESH LIABILITY STILL FOLLOWS
THE LICENSEE.
WHERE THERE IS NO CORPORATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SO THAT
BUSINESS PRACTICES BEING USED --
AGAINST US LICENSEES SO
ESTABLISHING SOME CORPORATE
LIABILITY IS.
A IS A NEEDED MECHANISM AT THIS
POINT -- FURTHER -- NUMBER.
THREE CHANGES HOW ARE BOARD
COORDINATES AND SHARES
INFORMATION ABOUT BALLOT
COMPLAINTS -- SO REALLY QUICK --
IF I FILE A COMPLAINT AGAINST ON
ALL MY SIS PRACTITIONER --
BECAUSE THE BOARD ABOUT THIRTY
DAYS LATER I GET A LETTER BACK
THAT SAYS YES WE FOUND A
VIOLATION OR NO.
IF YES -- I'LL GET A LETTER
STATING THAT IT'S OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION. SIX TO NINE
MONTHS LATER ALL GET A SUMMARY
LETTER.
THEY NORMALLY APPEAL.
THEN ANOTHER THREE SIX NINE
MONTHS GOES BY ON APPEAL -- ALL
THE WHILE IF IT IS -- WHETHER
IT'S A CONTRACTOR OR SOME OTHER
LICENSE -- EITHER WAY YOU'RE
TALKING TWELVE EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS UNTIL THE BOARD'S
COORDINATE WITH THEMSELVES
[inaudible]
MEANWHILE LICENSEES.
ARE TWO YEARS INTO A BURNING
PROBLEM -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AT OTHER WHAT OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF INCOME TO THE MIKE
WITHOUT ME TOO THAT BE GREAT.
MR MEMBERS WAS IMMEDIATE
COVERAGE TE COUNSELORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU JOSE.
RICHARD WAS OUR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MIKE MALANI WITH
MALIGNED ASSOCIATES REGISTERED
CIVIL ENGINEER LICENSE LANCER
THEIR PARENTS FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ARMITAGE JOHNSON
I AM A LICENSED LAND SURVEYOR
AND A REGISTERED CIVIL
ENGINEERING CALIFORNIA.
AND A BUSINESS OWNER OF BOTH AN
ENGINEERING FIRM HANNAH SURVEY.
FOR AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THIRTY BILLION HERE.
CHRIS THERE THE OPERATE YEARS
LOCAL THREE I'M IN SUPPORT I
ALSO KNOW THAT THE BUILDING
TRACTION TRADES LOCAL WITHIN
SUPPORT AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION OUR SISTER
LOCAL AND TWELVE LOCAL TWELVE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
YEAH ONE SECOND ALL RIGHT.
I ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT -- WITNESSES AT HER
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE GO TO THE MIKE
[inaudible]
MONACO -- TOWER MENDING ABOUT
HALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES CALIFORNIA
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION THE
BILL AT THIS POINT BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS GOING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR BEING HERE
FOR SURE HIS THOUGHTS.
MCI SLUR THE ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE BOARD FOR
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LANCER
THERE'S A GEOLOGIST THE BORDERS
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WE
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL'S.
CONTAINED IN IT EVEN THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS TO NOT
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS.
I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO GO
INTO MORE DETAIL IF YOU WOULD
LIKE.
OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS COULD
YOU EXPLAIN WHY WE DON'T HAVE A
LETTER ON FILE IN OPPOSITION
WHERE WE ONLY SUBMITTED THAT
LAST FRIDAY.
OUR CONCERNS RELATE TO THEM THE
ISSUES REGARDING THE DEFINITIONS
OF ENGINEERING SURVEYING AND
LAND SURVEYING.
WE BELIEVE THE CHANGES GO BEYOND
JUST CLARIFYING EXISTING
PRACTICE.
AND EXPAND THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE
WE DO NOT FEEL THERE'S BEEN
SUFFICIENT DEMONSTRATION.
THAT THE PRACTICES NEED TO BE
EXPANDED IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
BETTER PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC.
WE'RE CONCERNED WITH CREATING A
NEW CERTIFICATION A REGISTRATION
PROGRAM FOR BUSINESSES.
THIS WOULD INVOLVE INCREASING
FEES ARE LICENSEES WOULD HAVE TO
PAY.
WE HAVE ALREADY IN PLACE IN LAWS
REQUIREMENTS REGARDING THE
BUSINESSES AND WHAT THEY MUST DO.
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER SERVICES
THROUGH A BUSINESS ENTITY.
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
REFERRAL OF COMPLAINTS TO OTHER
ENTITIES WE FEEL THAT THERE.
ARE -- IS CONFUSION IN THE
LANGUAGE AND TERMINOLOGY USED IN
THAT SECTION.
ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD WELL THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THOSE VIEWS -- AS LATE
AS THEY HAVE COME IN THE PROCESS
BUT ALL THAT THE OUR DECIDE
WHETHER THEY WANT TO ADDRESS
THEM WE ARE WILLING TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE SPONSORS AND
THE AUTHORS OFFICE WE HAVE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SPONSORS
OKAY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
OR CENTER WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
THE THAT THOSE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED YES --
CERTAINLY -- WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THE BOARD -- A BIG GOT THAT
THE OPPOSITION LETTER JUST CAME
IN SO WE'RE CERTAINLY SO NO
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT BEFORE THIS
HEARING BUT WE'RE VERY MUCH
INTEREST IN WORKING WITH THE
BOARD.
THERE'S ALSO -- IMPLEMENTATION
THERE SOMETIME LAG AS WELL BUT
AS TO TO ALSO WORK THINGS OUT
BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY WANT TO WORK
ON AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
THOSE ISSUES ADDRESSED -- BUT
PRIOR -- TO THIS BILL SEEMS
FINAL FORM OF FULLY ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK.
GREAT THAT THAT THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN AND I I'M.
PLEASE TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY AND I APPRECIATED THE THE
WORK THAT YOU HAVE PUT INTO ON
THIS MATTER AND WITH YOUR WITH
YOUR SPONSORS I I WAS NOT AWARE
OF THESE CONCERNS EITHER I'M
GLAD YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH THEM ALLOWS US TO MOVE
HOPEFULLY THE BILL FORWARD.
TODAY.
AND IF YOU CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION PROTECT THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND AND
FOR YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OR IS
THERE A MOTION.
SENATOR HILL IS MOVE THE BILL.
THAT THE SECRETARY WOULD CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS IS ACCEPTED BY THE
AUTHOR.
I DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
GLAZER HI GLAZER I CHANGE MY
CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
NOT AYE GALGIANI.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN AYE PAN AYE WILK.
OKAY CENTER YOUR BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT WILL HOLD REAL
OF CONTRAPTION MEMBERS THANK YOU
OFFER COMING FOR TESTIFYING.
ALL RIGHT TO SENATOR GALGIANI
NOT HERE CENTER CHIANG THE READY.
SO WE'RE GONNA SIERRA THOUGHT WE
CAN GET THROUGH BEFORE FLOOR BUT
WE'LL WE'LL GIVE IT A TRY HERE.
SENATE CENTER JACK THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN SB.
SIX FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ON SB.
SIX FIFTY THREE SB SIX THIRTY
THREE HELPS IMPROVE ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE DENTAL HYGIENE CARE
BY EXPANDING REGISTERED DENTAL
HYGIENIST SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
RESEARCH CONTINUALLY SHOWS THAT
POOR ORAL HEALTH NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS OVERALL QUALITY OF LIFE
AND INCREASES.
SOCIAL COSTS TO TAXPAYERS THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF DENTAL
PLANS RELEASE ANALYSIS AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT SHOW THAT.
PROVIDING PREVENTATIVE.
DENTAL SERVICE TO ADULT MEDICAID
RECIPIENTS DECREASE MEDICAL
COSTS BY 36267%.
LACK OF ACCESS DON'T CARE RESULT
IN EXPENSIVE EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS MORE IN HOSPITAL STAYS
MISS SCHOOL DAYS AND ULTIMATELY
POOR ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE AND
LOST JOB OPPORTUNITIES.
UNDER THE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL REGISTERED DENTAL HGIENIST
WOULD BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS TO APPLY.
FLUORIDE VARNISH WITHOUT
SUPERVISION.
REST REGISTERED DENTAL HYGIENIST
IN ALTERNATIVE PRACTICE WOULD BE
ABLE PARTNER WITH TRADITIONAL
DENTISTS AND PHYSICIANS TO
CREATE MORE PATIENCE.
AND ALLOW THEM TO KEEP THEIR
PRACTICES OPEN IN AREAS THAT
CURRENTLY OUT LACK ACCESS TO
ORAL HEALTH CARE.
WE HAVE HAVE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH CDA AND WE'RE
WILLING TO ACCEPT AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS RELATING TO
STOP WITHIN A THRESHOLD.
FOR THE PROVISION OF HYGIENE
CARE TO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
BY AN ARTY H. A. P. IF THE THE
H. P. S. A DESIGNATION WERE TO
BE REMOVED.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOW TURN IT OVER
TO MY WITNESSES TO FURTHER
EXPLAIN THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL TEN FOR TEN ANNUAL
REPRESENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER TANNA HELL WITH ERIN
READ AND ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENISTS
ASSOCIATION.
WE WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE AUTHOR AND
STAKEHOLDERS FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL.
SB SIX FIFTY THREE DOES NOT
ALLOW DENTAL HYGIENISTS TO
PROVIDE NEW TREATMENTS THIS BILL
ALLOWS HIGH JENIS TO PROVIDE THE
SAME SAFE PREVENTIVE ORAL HEALTH
CARE.
THEY ALREADY PROVIDE IN MORE
SETTINGS TO REACH MORE PEOPLE
THIS BILL ALLOWS HIGH JENIS TO
WORKING MORE PUBLIC HEALTH
SETTINGS LIKE NONPROFIT HEALTH
CLINICS AND A MEDICAL SETTINGS
WERE HIGH JENIS CAN SCREEN AND
REFER PATIENTS TO DENNIS.
THE BILL ALLOWS ALTERNATIVE
PRACTICE HIGH JENIS THAT
SPECIALIZE IN TREATING NEEDY ARE
ELDERLY AND DISABLED PATIENTS IN
AREAS THAT LACK DENNIS
DESIGNATED AS DENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREAS. TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THEIR PATIENTS
IF THE AREA IS NO LONGER
DESIGNATED A DENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREA.
THIS WILL ENCOURAGE MORE
ALTERNATIVE PRACTICE HIGH JENIS
TO MOVE INTO THE AREA WHERE.
WHERE PEOPLE LACK ACCESS TO ORAL
HEALTH CARE?
TODAY WITH ME AS ROAD AGAIN
SALAS A REGISTERED DENTAL
HYGIENIST IN ALTERNATIVE
PRACTICE AND SHE'S HERE TEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RHODA
GONZALEZ I AM A REGISTERED
DENTAL HYGIENIST IN ALTERNATIVE
PRACTICE ON BEHALF O CD HA.
I CURRENTLY SEE PATIENTS IN WICK
SITE SCHOOL SITES WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTER AND IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES.
I HELP CONNECT MY PATIENTS TO
CONTINUITY OF CARE BY
COORDINATING CARE WITH DENTAL
HOMES IN MY COMMUNITY OF FRESNO --
THIS BILL ALIGNS WITH OUR
CALIFORNIA LOCAL ORAL HEALTH
PLAN WHICH WILL INCREASE
PREVENTIVE SERVICES IT ALSO
ALIGNS WITH THE MASTER PLAN FOR
OUR ADULTS AND OUR SENIORS WHO
ARE IN NEED OF MUCH NEEDED CARE.
THIS BILL ALSO ALIGNS WITH THE
CMS TWENTY NINETEEN CHILD COURSE
SET THAT WAS INTRODUCED AT THE
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEETING IN MARCH OF
THIS YEAR.
AND I QUOTE THEY WANT TO
INCREASE DENTAL SEALANTS FOR
SIXTY NINE YEAR OLD CHILDREN AT
ELEVATED CARRIES RISK.
WE ARE AN EXISTING WORK FORCE
THAT CAN PROVIDE PREVENTIVE CARE
WE CAN HELP THE STATE AND MEDI
CAL MANAGED HEALTHCARE PLANS
MEET THIS MEASURE IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN CMS CHILD COURSE THAT.
WE WILL ALSO HELP REDUCE GAPS IN
CARE AND COORDINATE CONTINUITY
OF CARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IS WITNESSES IN
COME ON UP.
HIS MCLAREN RT AJP CURRENTLY
LIVING IN SACRAMENTO BUT
FORMERLY OF THE VERY NEEDY AREA
OF KINGS AND TULARE COUNTY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
PLEASE OKAMOTO RGH FROM
SUNNYVALE I SPEAK STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
EARLY SACRAMENTO AND I SPEAK IN
SUPPORT ON MINORITY.
THANK YOU CAROLE LATE.
DIANNE AZEVEDO ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA.
AN R. D. H. A. P. WHO'S BEEN
PRACTICING FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
AND I CAN SUPPORT THANK YOU
DIANE.
HI I'M ELENA FRANCISCO A
MINORITY H. AND R. D. H. E. P.
FROM -- ASCALON CALIFORNIA AND
I'M IN FAVOR OF THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU ELENA.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ANTHONY LOAN.
EXECUTIVE OFFICER THE DENTAL
HYGIENE BOARD.
AND MY BOARD VOTED LAST WEEK TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL IF AMENDED --
THE AMENDED PORTION IS THERE'S A
QUOTA THAT'S PUT INTO THE BILL
AND MIKE.
MY BOARD IS UNSURE OF THE
DIRECTION OF A QUOTA -- AS
STATED -- FROM ONE OF MY MY
MEMBERS WHO IS ACTUALLY AN
ATTORNEY -- HE'S CONCERNED WITH
THE QUESTION OF THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY.
OF PUTTING ACCORDION TO SEE
PATIENTS AND WHETHER THIS IS A
RESTRICTION ON A BUSINESS
PRACTICES GOOD.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT WILL
ASK THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THAT
IN A MOMENT ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD THE NEXUS
FACE YOU'RE IN THE DAY AS FOR
FOR HER PLEASE [inaudible]
HELLO.
AFTERNOON AT MERION CAM WITH A
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION A
CDA IS APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK
SENATOR CHIANG HAS MADE ON THIS
BILL AND MOLLY HAVING OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
POSITION FOR THE BILL AND PRINT --
WE ANTICIPATE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORTING IF
AMENDED BASED ON THE I SENATORS
OPENING STATEMENT COMMITMENTS --
AND WELL AMENDMENTS ARE BEING
TAKEN ON THE D. H. M. P. S. A.
R. DIPSET LANGUAGE ISSUES CDA
MAINTAINS THAT THE OFFERED 15%
THRESHOLD.
OF FOR THE RT HEP MEDI CAL
PATIENT MIX IS JUST SIMPLY TOO
LOW AND BELIEVE THAT A MINIMUM
OF 30% THRESHOLD SHOULD BE SET
TO PRESERVE THE INTENDED.
FUNCTION OF THE ALREADY A TO A
P. -- WHICH IS TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO PERIODONTAL AND
PREVENTIVE DENTAL SERVICES TO
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND
POPULATIONS.
AS ONE THIRD OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING 50% OF ALL CHILDREN
ARE ALREADY ENROLLED IN MEDICARE
AL.
A 30% SEEMS TO BE A PRETTY
REASONABLE MINIMUM TO INSURED
CONTINUED CAN YOU CONTINUED
COMMUNITY ACCESS BY AN ARTY HEP.
WHILE ALSO RESPECTING THE NEED
FOR A BALANCED PATIENT MIX FOR
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICE.
OF THIS 30% THRESHOLD WOULD ALSO
BE IN WHAT IS -- IN LINE FOR
WHAT IS ALREADY REQUIRED FOR
DENNIS PARTICIPATING IN A
STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
FUNDED BY PROP -- FIFTY SIX FOR
DIRT FOR DENNIS PRACTICING IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
I'M CA ALSO HAS CONCERNS ABOUT
TWO OTHER PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
SURROUNDING THE REMOVAL OF
DENNIS SUPERVISION.
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PLACEMENT
OF INTO -- INTERIM THERAPEUTIC
RESTORATIONS OR TEMPORARY
FILLINGS OR IT OURS.
AND LOCAL ANESTHESIA FOR RTG
PEAS.
I'M ALREADY CHECK AP'S CONTEND
THAT THEY DON'T NEED AN THE
SUPERVISION OF A DENTIST FOR THE
I. T. R. PLACEMENT BECAUSE THEY
PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY.
HOWEVER THIS IS NOT ENTIRELY
ACCURATE AND APPEARS TO BE A
POINT OF CONFUSION.
ARE THE LAWS DOUBLE XING THE RTG
P. POINTEDLY DIFFERENTIATES
BETWEEN DENTAL HYGIENE IN THE
TREATMENT OF DENTAL DISEASES
WHICH REQUIRED THE I'M DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT PLANNING OF A
DENTIST.
I'M THE STATUTORY FRAMEWORK IS
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THE RTG P. AS
A TEAM OF DENTAL CARE PROVIDERS --
EACH HAS A ROLE IN OUR ALL
NECESSARY FOR PATIENTS TO SEE --
AND RECEIVE THE FULL RANGE OF
CARE THAT THEY NEED.
LASTLY PERMITTING THE PROVISION
OF LOCAL ANESTHESIA WITHOUT THE
SUPERVISION OF A DENTIST FOR
TYPICALLY MORE MEDICALLY COMPLEX
PATIENTS LEAVES ALREADY JP'S
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT THAT WOULD
BE PROVIDED AT INPATIENT
SETTINGS.
DURING EMERGENCIES SUCH AS BACK
UP TEAM MEMBERS AND ANASTASIA
REVERSAL DRUGS.
CDA WANTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROPER EMERGENCY PROTOCOLS AND
ARE PUT INTO PLACE FOR ALL
SETTINGS WERE RTG PEAS PROVIDE
THESE SERVICES.
I AM I WILL BE CONTINUING WITH
CONVERSATIONS WITH CCHA TO
FURTHER REFINE THIS LANGUAGE
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU OF MERRY ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT ARE WE GIVE THE AT THE
SPONSORED THE SENATOR.
BUT YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED HAVE MY SPONSOR COURSE.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY ON
THE LANGUAGE AND A COUPLE OF
THINGS THE AS FAR AS REMOVING
THE SUPERVISION COMPONENT FOR
THE I. T. OURS THE I. T. OURS
AND ARE DONE IN COLLABORATION
WITH A DENTIST IT'S USED A A
TELEHEALTH MODEL.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THEM TO REFINE THAT
LANGUAGE I THINK WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT AT SOME POINT PUTTING IN
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD.
HAVE THEM COLLABORATE SINCE THE
ALREADY ALREADY HA P. DOES NOT
HAVE ANY SUPERVISION REQUIREMENT
IN STATUTE -- THEY FELT IT WAS
CONFUSING TO ADD TO IT AND YOU
KNOW HAVE SUPERVISION AND THIS --
ONE AT PROVISION WHEN THAT'S NOT
REALLY WHAT HOW IT WORKS IN
PRACTICE SO WE'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH CDA MORE ON THAT -- AND
LOOK FORWARD TO A THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAPPENED AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
IN THE COMMITTEE SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU FIND ACOSTA BILL.
WELL I THINK THE WITNESS THAT AT
THE THAT WAY SEE IS IS THAT --
OTHER PLACES WHERE WE IN TERMS
OF ACCESS MY TIME UNDER SING
HOMES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SCHOOLS SO BUT NOW I'VE MAKE
NOTE THAT.
I THINK A. B. BUT THAT VAST
MAJORITY OF OUR NURSING HOME
PATIENTS ACTUALLY ARE ON THAT A
CAL SO WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
JUST THE SO OVERALL WE WERE
ABOUT THIRD PEOPLE MEDI CAL BUT
HALF OF ALL CHILDREN.
EVEN HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE
IN NURSING HOME CARE SO I GUESS
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I DO HAVE
IS.
HITTING A 30% THRESHOLD SHOULD
BE FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S ACTUALLY PROVIDING
CARE IN THOSE SETTINGS IS THERE
A PROBLEM WITH THE 3% THRESHOLD
AND SO CITY HA IS CONCERNED WITH
THE THRESHOLD.
IS THAT IT REALLY -- SETS A
PRECEDENT NO OTHER.
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER IS MANDATED
BY THE STATE TO HAVE A CERTAIN
PACE ELATION BUT BUT JUST BUT
JUST TO CLARIFY THIS ONLY
APPLIES.
IN NON HIP SAID AREAS TO SOMEONE
SO RIGHT NOW.
IT DOESN'T AND DO YOU CAN READ
ME LIKE READ THE BILL THAT OF
SAYS REMOVED RIGHT TO HIT JUST
YEAH SO WE'RE ONLY TALKING ABOUT
SITUATIONS WITH THE HIP SAYS
YOU'VE BEEN REMOVED HERE HIPS
AREAS THERE'S NO.
PERCENTAGE RIGHT I MEAN IT'S BY
DEFINITION THAT'S A LOW SO.
THIS THIS IS THE PROVISION WHICH
BECAUSE I THINK THERE COULD
BASICALLY I THINK THERE'S A WILL
THERE'S GOING TO BE A BIT OF
CONFUSION I'M JANITOR BUT THE
THE BOARD SAID I MEAN THE OTHER
ALTERNATIVE TO SAY WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT.
YOUR HELP SO YOU'RE FINE IF YOU
AND IT'S REALLY IT'S REMOVED
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN ALL THE TIME
IT'S FEDERAL.
THAN -- THEN THEN YOU CAN'T
PRACTICE I MEAN THIS IS WERE
TRYING TO STRIKE A MIDDLE GROUND
HERE BECAUSE I THINK THE PURPOSE
WAS IS AND ACTUALLY THE SAID
THAT THE SETTINGS REALLY ARE THE
ONES THAT I'M HEARING DESCRIBED
THINGS LIKE SCHOOLS AND NURSING
HOMES.
THOSE ARE VERY HIGH PERCENTAGE
MEDI CAL SITES ANYWAY TO START
WITH SO.
THAT'S WHY MIKE WHY IS 30% A
PROBLEM.
SO CITY HA IS WILLING TO WORK
WITH CD A ON THE ON THAT
LANGUAGE.
AND WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE THAT
CONCERN OF OPENING IT UP THAT
WOULD MANDATE PROVIDERS SEE A
CERTAIN PAPER PATIENT
POPULATIONS AWAY TONIGHT CLASS
WERE BUT WE'RE TOTALLY WILLING
TO WORK WITH THEM ON THAT AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE WILLING TO PUT
THAT THRESHOLD BACK IN THE BILL.
AND AND OKAY SO BECAUSE AFFINITY
SO.
THE ISSUE ISN'T THE PERCENTAGE
THAT ISSUES THE PROVISION OR THE
ISSUE THE PERCENTAGE FIGURE OUT
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS THE ISSUE AS
A PERCENTAGE OF THAT WE'D ALL
EVERYONE AGREED ON THE PROVISION.
BUT YOUR OBJECTION IS ACTUALLY
TO HAVING THAT PROVISION THE
FIRST PLACE.
I'M TRYING TO CLARIFY WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM WE'RE GOING TO BE
PUTTING IT BACK IN BASICALLY
DOES OKAY SO THERE IS NOT A IT'S
NOT CALLED THE PROVISION ISN'T
THE PROBLEM IT'S THE PERCENTAGE.
OKAY I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
OKAY AND AND I GUESS I'M RAISING
WHAT'S WRONG 30%.
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND 30% IS
MORE DIFFICULT TO TRACK THE MORE
AT THE HIGHER PERCENTAGE YOU
HAVE OF PATIENTS IN YOUR
POPULATION THAT YOU NEED TO
TRACK TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT PATIENT.
ANY HARD TO TRACK IT WOULD BE
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE HIGH
JENIS TO TRACK THAT -- THE
PERCENTAGE SHOULD BE EQUALLY
DIFFICULT ATTRACTION OR WHAT THE
PERCENTAGES I MEAN IN TERMS OF
BY THAT SHE IS THAT PERCENTAGE.
THAT MAY BE BUT AS A SET OF AT
THE POPULATIONS ARE THE ONES
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
CHILDREN ARE 50% OF MEDI CAL
PATIENTS RIGHTS OF YOU DOING
SCHOOLS QUESTION BE TO DIFFICULT.
NURSING HOMES.
I THINK 80% SO. 30% SHOULD BE NO
PROBLEM -- WE'RE NOT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE WHY
HEARING IS MAINLY FOCUSING ON
THOSE AREAS WHERE YOU ACTUALLY
READY HALF FOR THE BIGGEST
ACCESS PROBLEMS.
JERRY HAVE THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE MEDI CAL PATIENTS --
SO I I THINK THAT FOR ME AT THE
CENTER PAN MAKES A VERY GOOD
POINT LET ME JUST ASK OR
CLARIFICATION SO.
FROM CTA'S POINT OF YOU YOU'VE
RACED. FIVE ISSUES. ONE OF THE
WHICH IS THE THRESHOLD AND FOR
OTHERS BUT IS THE IS YOURS.
OPPOSITION REMOVAL OF YOUR
OPPOSITION BASED ON THE
THRESHOLD CHANGE.
AND THE OTHERS WITH OUR CONCERNS
THAT YOU THINK ARE YOUR WORKING
ON WITH THE WITH THE AUTHOR IS
THAT SO WE'RE WORKING ON IT SO
WE WE RAISE THREE ISSUES THERE
IS THE DIPSET DESIGNATION --
THAT THE PERCENTAGE THRESHOLD
REQUIREMENT THERE IS THE I. T.
R. GENERAL SUPERVISION AND THEN
THERE IS ALSO THE SUPERVISION
FOR LOCAL ANESTHESIA BOTH OF
WHICH FOR EACH AB IS.
AN THE THE POSITION OF MOVING
BACK TO SUPPORT OF AMENDED WAS
BASED ON ADDING THE DIPS A
INFORMATION -- OR THAT IF THE
DEFINITION BACK INT THE
LANGUAGE BUT ON ALL THREE ARE
ARE DEFINITE CONCERNS THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON IT BUT IF THE AUTHOR
MOVED THE THRESHOLD OF 30%.
BUT THAT REMOVE YOUR OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
IF.
IF IT SO THAT THE LANGUAGE THAT
SHOULD THAT SENATOR CHIANG IS
PUTTING BACK AND WE WILL BE BACK
TO WE ANTICIPATE BACK TO A
SUPPORT AMENDED.
CENTER CHANGE YOU WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT THEN ARE YOU ABLE
TO COME TO THAT THAT WE ABLE TO
GET TO THE SPACE HERE.
RIGHT ABSOLUTELY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATION I KNOW BUT
SPECIFICALLY TO THAT IS THAT THE
30% NUMBER THAT YOU'RE ASKING
FOR WE'RE STILL ASKING 430%
PRESSES YOUR ANGLE WITH HAVING
THE PROVISION OF ALL I THINK IT
WAS THERE WERE 930%.
WE'RE NOT COMFORTABLE WITH 15%
WE'RE LOOKING 430% BUT WE WILL
MOVE OUR POSITION TO SUPPORT IF
AMENDED.
WITH THE 15% LANGUAGE THAT WAS
OFFERED IN THE ANALYSIS.
BUT WE WANT 30% CORRECT.
WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING WE WILL
DEFINITELY HAVE THAT PROVISION
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING ON
THE PERCENTAGE.
AS WELL AND ARE COMFORTABLE YOU
GUYS A COMFORTABLE I MEAN RIGHT
THAT'S ONE OF OUR MENACES RIGHT
THE AMENDMENT OF MOVING FROM
153230% BECAUSE PRIOR.
CLARIFY WHETHER YOU ARE MOVING
FROM OPPOSITION. TO SUPPORT WITH
THE AMENDMENTS AS THE AUTHOR HAS
PROPOSED TODAY WE ARE.
FAR YEAH YES.
AND THAT IS THAT THE THOSE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDED AT A
THRESHOLD OF 15% AT 30%.
RIGHT SOURCE SUPPORT OF AMENDED
STILL WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
15% FOR ME WOULD NOT A SUPPORT
YOU WOULD EXIST PORT OF AMENDED.
YOU WOULD ONLY SUPPORTED 30%.
WRECKED WALDRON NOW NOTE NOW
WE'RE WE'RE SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
FOR THE THREE ISSUES.
THE DIP SERVING FROM FIFTEEN TO
THIRTY AND THE OTHER.
TWO THOUGH.
SO OKAY YOU ARE CONFUSING ME NOW
YEAH.
YEAH I JUST RE OKAY [inaudible]
THAT -- YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THAT.
YEAH SO IT'S NOT IN OPPOSE IS
NOT IT'S NOT WE WERE IT RIGHT
NOW IT'S IT'S AN OPPOSE UNLESS.
AMENDMENT ADDED AND THE SUFFIX.
TO WE HAVE THREE CONCERNS WITH
THE LANGUAGE THAT'S BEING TAKEN
RIGHT NOW.
WE'LL BE IN SUPPORT OF AMENDED.
THIS MORE OF A NEUTRAL.
OR OKAY THAT'S THE CONFUSION
BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING IF YOU
TAKE THESE AMENDMENTS SHOULD BE
SUPPORT IF IF AMENDED.
WHICH IT CREATES THIS COMPUTER
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL WE'RE STILL
THINKING ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS.
OKAY AND WE WILL BE WORKING WITH
CD EIGHT SO THAT'S A NEW ONE FOR
ME I GUESS.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
YES SENATOR PAN SIDE FROM THE
RATIO -- THE PASSAGE OF US I AS
THE SHOW IT'S A LOCAL ANESTHESIA
AND YELLING.
IN ORDER THERE WILL LOOK.
LIKE YOU TALK TO AND OF THERE SO
THE LOCAL ANESTHESIA AND SO WHAT --
SO THERE'S THIS THEIR NEW.
NEW AUTHORITIES AND BILL NOW
OKAY EXPLAIN TO ME WHAT THE
ISSUE CURETTAGE AND LOCAL
ANESTHESIA IN NURSING HOMES AND
THE HOMES OF THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED.
I'M NOT SCHOOLS -- IN IN DENTAL
AND MEDICAL SETTINGS AND THIS
WOULD HELP ADDRESS -- WORKING
WITH ELDERLY PATIENTS THAT MAY
NEED THOSE DEEPER CLEANINGS AND
LOCAL ANESTHESIA PROVIDES --
PAIN RELIEF WE ARE NOT INCLUDING
THE NITROUS OXIDE OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE THAT CHANGES YOUR
CONSCIOUSNESS -- BUT THE LOCAL
ANESTHESIA WAS A WAY TO ADD
ADDITIONAL PAIN RELIEF FOR THOSE.
ELDERLY PATIENTS THAT NEED THE
DEEPER LEANINGS OKAY SO ON ONE
LEVEL I APPRECIATE.
THE IMPORTANCE OF PAIN RELIEF.
HI BUT I'M ALSO CONSCIOUS OF THE
POTENTIAL SIDE EFFECTS.
AND A ONE BE VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT
THAT SCIENTISTS ARE YOU WORKING
WITH THAT CA ON THAT BECAUSE
WHAT WE DON'T WANT ANY WE WANTED
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO SENIORS BUT
WE DON'T ALSO WANT TO HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S OUT THERE.
DOING SOMETHING AND THEN THEY
GET IN TROUBLE AND THEY DON'T
HAVE BACK UP. TO THAT THAT THAT
WOULD BE VERY SERIOUS.
SENATOR HILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN AND IT
SEEMS LIKE.
THERE'S THERE'S COMPROMISED
THERE AT SOME LEVEL AND IT MAY
GET TO THE FULL AMOUNT OF MY
SUGGESTION WOULD BE WE MOVE THE
BILL FOR TODAY.
AND WITH THE SERVE IF IT CANNOT
BE RESOLVED IN APPROPRIATIONS
FOR THE TO YOU COULD BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AT SOME
POINT IN TIME AS BEFORE IT GETS
TO THE FLOOR OR SOMETHING.
I THINK THAT'S A THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT SUGGESTION.
THE BILL GOING GREAT WISDOM --
BUT THE I'M A GIVE CENTER CHIANG
AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE AND WE'LL
SEE IF WE HAVE A MOTION TO DO
JUST.
THAT THAT WAS EXACTLY WHAT I WAS
GONNA ASK FOR ON BECAUSE WE WILL
DEFINITELY BE WORKING WITH CDA
AND JUST A SIDE NOTE I HAVE
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO WERE.
DENTISTS AND DENTAL HYGIENISTS
OF THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
INTERESTING CONVERSATION.
WELL -- BUT WITH THAT I I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE OKAY THANK THANK
YOU CENTER CHIANG SO.
SENATOR HILL SUGGESTION WOULD BE
TO TAKE THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS --
BUT TO ASK THAT THE FURTHER
UNABLE TO RESOLVE THEIR
DIFFERENCES -- PRIOR TO
APPROPRIATIONS THAT THAT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY -- TO TO GET
BACK TO THE CONVERSATION HERE AS
A COMMITTEE OKAY WITH THAT.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT'S TO PASS AS
AMENDED -- TO APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
A SUSAN.
SO -- I AM LOOKING FOR A 30%.
SO.
I WILL VOTE THE PASSES OUT NOW
BUT IT HITS THE FLOOR DOESN'T
HAVE THAT I MIGHT HAVE DIFFERENT
OPINIONS OKAY FAIR ENOUGH THANK
YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION AND
WITH THAT.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
YEAH CENTER HILLS HAVE CENTER
HAS MADE THE MOTION.
QUESTION IS DO PASS AT THE
MEDICINE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GLAZER HI GLAZER I
CHANGE.
I ARCHULETA.
ARCHER THAT I DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
FANS.
PAN AYE WILK.
RIGHT RIGHT I SAID THE CENTER
CHIANG YOUR BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT THE WHOLE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS IN
THE LET ME A LET THE COMMITTEE
KNOW THE FLOOR SESSION OF THE
SENATE IS BEGINNING.
IN JUST A MOMENT -- SO I'D LIKE
TO ASK YOU ALL THAT.
COME ON BACK AFTER FLORA WILL
FINISH THE THE IMPORTANT AGENDA
STILL AHEAD.
THANK YOU
IN SESSION.
THE BILL HAD A GOOD LUNCH
WHEREVER YOU ARE.
AND DOES CENTER GOLGI ARE YOU
READY TO TAKE UP YOUR BILL THIS
IS ITEM FOURTEEN SB SIX TWENTY
SEVENTH.
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AND I WANT TO
THANK.
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US
LAST WEEK TO COME UP WITH THE
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS THAT MAKE
THIS A BETTER BILL AND MORE
CONCISE.
AND WE ARE WILLING TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED BY THE COMMITTEE STAFF
THANK YOU.
SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN PROVIDES
VETERINARIANS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOMMEND THE USE OF CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FOR MEDICINAL USE ON
THEIR ANIMAL PATIENTS.
PETS OUR FURRY FRIENDS SUFFER
FROM MANY OF THE SAME IF NOT
SIMILAR AILMENTS HUMANS DO AND
WHICH MEDICAL CANNABIS PRODUCTS
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO HAVE A
THERAPEUTIC BENEFIT.
SINCE VETERINARIANS ARE
CURRENTLY LIMITED ON HOW THEY
CAN DISCUSS THE USE OF MEDICINAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS LET ALONE
PROVIDE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS ON
DOSAGE OR APPLICATION OF
PRODUCTS.
PET OWNERS WOULD LIKE TO TREAT
THEIR ANIMALS OFTEN TURN TO THE
INTERNET FOR ADVICE OR SEEN
SIMPLY SEEK THE COUNSEL OF THE
RETAIL CANNABIS CLERK.
BEHIND THE COUNTER OR MAKE
GUESSES.
INSTEAD OF HAVING ACCURATE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
RATHER THAN GETTING THE ADVICE
AND RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
MOST QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL THEIR
LOCAL VETERINARIAN PET OWNERS
ARE UNINTENTIONALLY PUTTING
THEIR PETS HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
DANGER.
ANIMAL CAN AVOID RECEPTORS
SYSTEMS ARE DIFFERENT FROM
HUMANS SO DOSAGES MUST BE
ADJUSTED FOR THE TYPE OF ANIMAL
ITS WEIGHT AND OBVIOUSLY THE
CONDITION YOU ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS.
IN AN EFFORT TO PROTECT ANIMALS
PROVIDE FOR THE SAFE USE OF
CANNABIS PRODUCTS AND TO ALLOW
THOSE VETERINARIANS WHO WISH TO
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION ON
CANNABIS USE.
I AM PRESENTING SB.
SIX TWENTY SEVEN I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE COMMITTEE IS PROVIDED A
SET OF AMENDMENTS WHICH CLARIFY
THE DIRECTION OF SB.
SIX TWENTY SEVEN SO THAT IT FITS
WITHIN A FRAMEWORK SIMILAR TO
THE ADOPTION OF MEDICAL CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FOR HUMANS.
THE AMENDMENTS ALSO PROVIDE FOR
GREATER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
THEY ASKED THE VET VETERINARIAN
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. TO
ADOPT GUIDELINES FOR THE USE OF
MEDICINAL CANNABIS FOR AN ANIMAL
PATIENT I AM ACCEPTING ALL OF
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU.
LET ME EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
MEASURE SIMPLY PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK FOR THOSE
VETERINARIANS WHO CHOOSE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE USE OF
CANNABIS WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SO.
I RECOGNIZE THAT NOT ALL
VETERINARIANS WILL WANT TO DO SO.
AND LASTLY THE MEASURE PROVIDES
PEACE OF MIND TO THOSE PET
OWNERS WHO ARE CURRENTLY USING
CAMPUS PRODUCTS ON THEIR PETS
AND FOR THOSE PET OWNERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO USE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS ON THEIR PETS.
THAT THEY CAN SPEAK WITH AND
RECEIVE A MEDICAL RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE VETERINARIAN THE MOST
TRUSTED AND QUALIFIED PERSON
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR PETS
HEALTH.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE PAUL
HANSBERRY AND SUSAN TEVIN FROM
LOVINGLY AND LEGALLY WHO
SPONSORED THIS LEGISLATION AND
ARE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR GALGIANI.
YOUR WITNESSES WANT TO SPEAKER
JUST ANSWER QUESTIONS I WANT TO
BE CLEAR ON THAT.
LIKE THE BLOOD.
SEASON SEVEN GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ALSO A CO SPONSOR I
BELIEVE IS DOCTOR GERRIE RICHTER --
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SAY SOMETHING
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY OR WE
CAN BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
YOUR YOUR CHOICE.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY ON OF AS A CO
SPONSOR -- I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR GUIDANCE.
ON MAN IS NOTED ON THE BILL
ALLOWS FOR FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
THE ISSUE A RECOMMENDATION AS WE
GO FORWARD WORKING WITH OF
VARIOUS REGULATORY AGENCIES.
IT FURTHERS CONSUMER HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
AND IT FURTHERS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF ANIMALS AND SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK OF FOR A YES
VOTE FOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL
VERY GOOD THANK YOU ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THE
WOULD LIKE -- TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES FOR THE RECORD.
PLEASE COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
RIGHT HERE IN FRONT.
SAY YOUR NAME.
THIS IS LEILANI.
AND DIED MY NAME IS MICHAEL HARD
TRUE BLOOD -- SHE'S MY SON'S
SERVICE STARK.
IS AUISTIC IT IS BETTER SERVICE
DOG FOR TEN YEARS.
SHE HAS INTEROPERABLE -- A FIVE
TO WORK MASH.
AND SO ARE I FEEL IT'S CONSUMER
I'VE HAD TO GO OUT ON MY OWN.
AND TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
WITHOUT THE GUIDANCE OF OF MY
FAT [inaudible]
I YOU KNOW IN ITS IN ITS.
DRAMA YOU KNOW THIS THIS NEEDS
TO MOVE FORWARD I APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON THIS [inaudible]
I YOU KNOW I WANT THE BEST FOR
HER I WANT THE BEST FOR MY KID.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN USING.
JUST WHAT WE COULD FIND ON THE
INTERNET.
AND SHE WAS IN REMISSION AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S BACK SO.
I KNOW THIS BILL WON'T EXACTLY
HELP HER.
BUT A FUTURE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WHO HAVE PETS SEWER
INOPERABLE FOR THEIR TUMORS.
I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK
AT ALTERNATIVE TREATMENT WITH
PROPER GUIDANCE THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND A LINE A FOR FOR BEING
HERE [inaudible]
YES SIR.
HEY I MEXICO ONUS ON BEHALF OF-THAT CD WE'VE GOT A OUR COMMENTS
POSITION -- WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE BILL MOVING FOR TODAY -- WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS INDICATING THAT --
THERE'S SOME QUESTIONS AROUND
MARKET ACCESS IN THE CONCERNED
SECTION THE LAST A CONCERN
LISTED -- AS MUCH AS THE BILL
WOULD BE LIMITED TO TO SIMPLY
MEDICINAL OF RETAILERS AS
OPPOSED TO DAHLE USE AMAZON
RETAILERS -- INTO BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGING MARKET DYNAMICS WE ARE
FAVORING A BROADER ACCESS FOR
THESE PRODUCTS ONCE APPROVED --
BUT STILL APPRECIATE OFFICE
OFFICE AND WORKING WITH THEM
THEIR STAFF IN ONE BUILDING
FOURTH THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK
YOU -- ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE STEP UP.
NOW THIS IS THE GALGIANI BILL.
WE TWEENER BY CBS SURE.
YOUR THOUGHT THAT YOU'RE WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CRISTINA THE CAR --
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION A
WE HAVE A DISAPPROVING LESS
AMENDED POSITIONS ARE NOT NOT
THE HEAVY OPPOSE POSITION WE
JUST HAVE.
A TWO CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
WRITTEN RIGHT NOW -- WE SHARED
THEM WITH THE COMMITTEE AND AND
WITH MS GALGIANI THE REFERENCE
TO THE QUALIFIED VETERINARIAN
DESIGNEES -- IT PUTS A UNIQUE --
RESTRICTION ON THE VETERINARY
COMMUNITY.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
DESIGNATIONS LIKE THAT IN THE
VETERINARY MEDICINE PRACTICE ACT
BUT SOME POINT THAT THE STATE
DETERMINES THAT.
A RECOMMENDATION IS APPROPRIATE
FOR VETERINARIANS WE JUST LIKE
TO SEE THAT ALL VETERINARIANS BE
GIVEN THIS AUTHORITY AND THEN
SIMILARLY CDMA DOESN'T SUPPORT
THE CARVE OUT FOR THE MANDATORY
CONTINUING EDUCATION WE HAVE
BETTER NEAR IT'S TAKING THESE
COURSES RIGHT NOW.
THE FINING THEM VERY USEFUL AND
SO -- WE DON'T THINK THAT
pTHERE'S REALLY A NEED FOR THAT --
WE THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS IS REALLY
QUITE GOOD BROUGHT UP -- SOME
ISSUES THAT WE HAD YOU KNOW THIS
ISSUE IS VERY COMPLICATED WE
WERE BEFORE YOU LAST YEAR ON A.
B. TWO TWO ONE FIVE BY MISTER
KALRA.
ASKING FOR THE PERMISSION TO
JUST DISCUSS THIS ISSUE WITH OUR
CLIENTS AND SO HERE WE ARE -- IN
A DIFFERENT FORMAT TODAY SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
BUT WE THINK THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE VERY PROMISING TERRIFIC
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER -- WITNESSES AND
NEUTRALITY OR IN OPPOSITION.
STEP ON FORWARD.
OKAY WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
FOR COMMON OR QUESTIONS OR
CENTER GALGIANI YOU CAN SPEAK TO
THE LAST COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
BUT I SEE SENATOR DODD.
VERY GOOD SENATOR GALGIANI WAS
THERE ANY RESPONSE YOU'D LIKE TO
SHARE WITH US.
YES WE WILL BE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION VETERINARY SO SHE
XIN AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A
PATHWAY FORWARD.
AND THE PATH THAT WE CAME UP
WITH ISN'T NECESSARILY EXACTLY
WHAT IT NEEDS TO BE AS LONG AS
WE'RE GOING IN THAT DIRECTION
AND CAN FIND OURSELVES GOING TO
THAT PLACE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
AVOID IS WHAT'S IN EXISTENCE NOW
AND THAT IS THAT.
PET OWNERS ARE ARE USING THE
PRODUCT BUT THEY'RE GUESSING AND
THAT PUTS THE SAFETY OF OF OUR
PETS IN JEOPARDY.
YEAH I FIRST OF ALL I
APPRECIATED YEAH THAT WILL IN
THIS I THINK THAT -- THE
VETERINARIANS ASSOCIATION GAVE A
COUPLE REALLY STRONGPOINTS
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH THEM AT ALL MOVED BILL.
K. THAT CENTER GALGIANI WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE THERE ARE A FEW MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE OR THE LEGISLATURE
THAT ARE GREATER CHAMPIONS OF
OUR FOUR LEGGED FRIENDS THAT
YOUR SENATOR CALL JOHNNY SO
THANK YOU.
YOUR COMPASSIONATE LEADERSHIP
AND FINDING WAYS TO HELP THEM.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
SENATOR DODD IS MADE A MOTION.
WITH THAT OF THE SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THIS IS THE THE BILL TO
PASS AS AMENDED. TO APPROACH.
TWO ROPES OKAY BUT THAT
SECRETARY CALDERON LASER HI IS --
I'D CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA.
VIRTUALLY THE AYE DODD AYE AYE
GALGIANI.
GEN I STILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA HAND WILK WILL
GUIDE.
ALL RIGHT CENTER GALGIANI
THERE'S ENOUGH VOTES TO UPLOAD
YOUR BILL OUR GONNA.
HOLD ON CALL. FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WITNESSES FOR COMING.
THE HEARING TODAY.
WELL I THINK THAT LEAVES SOME OF
THE NON CONTROVERSIAL MEMBERS TO
THE END.
WHEN A PASSED THE GAVEL TO MY
VICE CHAIR
OUR MISTER CHAIR SO
YOU'RE GOING TO BE PRESENTING SB
[inaudible]
SIX OH SIX THE CORRECT.
GREAT DEBT AT MADAME VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- SB SIX SO SIX
EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE. FOR THE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL BUREAU.
TO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IT -- THIS
MEASURE ADDRESSES SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED IN THE
COMMITTEE BACKGROUND PAPER AND
THE HEARING THAT WE HELD.
TOGETHER WITH THE ASSEMBLY --
EARLIER THIS YEAR -- IT MAKES TO
CHANGES THE MEASURE REMOVES THE
PERIOD OF TIME FOR RETAKING THE
EMBALMERS EXAMINATION.
I KNOW YOU'RE ALL WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT.
AND IT ALSO REQUIRES THE BUREAU
TO EXAMINE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
AND BOMBER LICENSURE.
IN OTHER STATES EVERY FOUR YEARS
RATHER THAN FROM CO TIME TO TIME
AS THE CURRENT LAW STATES.
THIS BILL ALONG WITH THE OTHER
OTHER SUNSET BILLS I'M GONNA
PRESENTING IN A FEW MOMENTS IS
THE PRODUCT OF OUR COMPREHENSIVE
SUNSET REVIEW.
OVERSIGHT PROCESS UNDERTAKEN BY
THIS COMMITTEE IN COORDINATION
WITH OUR ASSEMBLY COUNTERPARTS.
THE CHANGES IN THE SUNSET BILLS
WERE OUTLINED AS I MENTION OUR
BACKGROUND PAPERS MADE AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC PRIOR TO OUR
OVERSIGHT HEARING.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE RIGHT VOTE IN SB SIX OF SIX
ROOSEVELT -- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SPHERE AYE THOSE.
DESERVE MOTION FROM US SENATOR
WILL.
CENTER WILL HAVE MOVED THE BILL.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR WILL CALL
THE ROLL GLAZER HI.
THERE I CHIANG I CHIANG AYE
ARCHULETA.
VIRTUAL IT I DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
AND WILK FIVE WILL GUIDE
[inaudible] SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
THE WE CAN AT LEAST THE WOULD
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR MEMBERS.
UP BILL REST IN PEACE FOR NOW SB
SIX OF SEVEN ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VICE CHAIR -- SB SIX OR SEVEN
REQUIRES THE BOARD OF BARBARY
AND COSMETOLOGY'S HEALTH AND
SAFETY ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE THREE BOARD MEMBERS.
IT ALSO ADDS INFORMATION ON
PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC LABELING
REQUIREMENTS THE LIST OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUES.
THAT THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE CAN
PROVIDE ADVICE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON IT.
THROUGHOUT THROUGH THE INPUT OF
ADDITIONAL BOARD MEMBERS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE MAY BENEFIT
FROM INPUT AND GUIDANCE ON
INDUSTRY STANDARDS WITHOUT ASKS
FOR YOUR I'VE OF HEY USED OR
THERE WITH NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OR OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
ANY CLOSING STATEMENTS -- I'
SORRY SENATOR GLAZERS IS A
COMMITTEE BILL IS JUST ONE OF
YOUR BILLS ONE OF MY GREAT
LEADERSHIP BILLS FANTASTIC I I
WILL BE IN SUPPORT.
IT'S LIKE IN THE ADDED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR NO.
MR SURE WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO ADD THAT THE ALONG WITH
SENATOR DODD DAY SEEMS TO HAVE
THE ENTHUSIASM FOR THE BILL AND
JOINS WITH MINE THAT'S FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
SO TO HAVE A MOTION.
SENATOR DODD MOVES THE BILL.
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
HI THERE I CHIANG KAI TING AYE
ARCHULETA.
VIRTUAL THE EIGHT DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
PAN WILK.
I WILL DRIVE.
SO WE HAVE US SEVEN VOTES AND
WE'RE GONNA.
PULL THE ROLE OPEN TO LOW
MEMBERS AT ON NEXT UP.
SB SIX SO.
EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
SB SIX SO IT EXTENDS THE SUNSET
DATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ARCHITECTS BOARD.
AND THE LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS
TECHNICAL COMMITTEE UNTIL
JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND ADDRESSES
ISSUES RAISED IN THIS CASE A
COMMITTEES BACKGROUND PAPER.
AMONG THOSE CHANGES IT REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS BOARD
TO UPON THE GATE.
REGULATIONS ESTABLISHING
QUALIFICATIONS FOR CONTINUING
EDUCATION WORK.
AND PROVIDERS -- BY JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
MEASURE ALSO AUTHORIZES THE
BOARD'S EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO
DELEGATE THE ABILITY TO HOLD AN
INFORMAL CONFERENCE WITH THE
PERSON WHO RECEIVED A CITATION.
AND ALLOWS THAT PERSON TO APPEAL
THE OUTCOME OF OF THIS
CONFERENCE.
A SIX AWAIT ADDITIONALLY
REQUIRES LICENSE APPLICANTS TO
SUBMIT FINGERPRINTS FOR A
BACKGROUND CHECK. FOR THE
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS TECHNICAL
COMMITTEE THE BILL UPDATES THE
WRITTEN CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS.
AND ALSO REQUIRES LICENSE
APPLICANTS TO SUBMIT
FINGERPRINTS FOR A BACKGROUND
CHECK.
THE BILL ENSURES THAT THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WILL BE ABLE
TO PERFORM THE SAME
ADMINISTRATIVE AND ENFORCEMENT
DUTIES FOR THE COMMITTEE.
AS THE EXECUTIVE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER PERFORMS FOR THE BOARD.
I'M SO MANY AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY THAT THE WRITTEN
CONTRACT CONTENT EXEMPTIONS FOR
BOTH THE BOARD AND THE COMMITTEE.
ONLY APPLY A PUBLIC AGENCY
SUPPLIES THEIR OWN CONTRACT.
THE CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS BOARD
SUPPORTS THIS BILL AND THERE IS
NO OPPOSITION AND I'M AWARE OF
BUT ASK YOUR AYE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT LAURIE'S IN
A GUY WITH A CALIFORNIA
ARCHITECTS BOARD HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARC CHRISTIAN WITH THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
TRANSMISSIBLE OUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS
AND SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NON I ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS --
CENTER WELL.
DO YOU KNOW OUR DâN DELAY
SUPPORTS THIS BILL [inaudible]
THE T..
THAT TECHNICAL QUESTION I GUESS
IS TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU KNOW.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELL SENATORS TRYING TO BE FUNNY
BUT AND I DALY IS A FAILED.
THERE'S INFORMATION YOU HAVE.
I CAN ADD IT TO MY CLOTHES.
I CAN ADDED TO MY CLOTHES.
SO IN A CLUB AND JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ACCEPTING YOUR THE AMENDMENT YES.
EXCEPT IN A CENTER WHICH I CLOSE
AT THAT A MISTER VAN AWAY
OBVIOUSLY HAS A BIG SUPPORTER
AND MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
HAPPY.
TO TAKE ALL INFORMATION ABOUT --
THIS PARTICULAR PERSON UNDER
CONSIDERATION AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
IS A MOTION.
OKAY SENATOR HELL MOVES BILL.
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
MOST IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
GLAZER.
HI THESE ARE I CHIANG I CHIANG
AYE ARCHULETA.
SHOULD I DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI -- JENNY AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA FAN BOOK.
ALL RIGHT OKAY.
WE HAVE SEVEN VOTES AND WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN TO
LET MEMBERS TO ADD ON OKAY IN
THE NEXT STEP IS SB SIX OH NINE
WITH AMENDMENT.
RIGHT THANK YOU VICE CHAIR AS
THE MATH I'M SURE THE MEMBERS OF
FOND MEMORIES OF OUR SUNSET
HEARINGS THAT WE HELD EARLIER
THIS YEAR THEY WERE GREAT.
OPPORTUNITIES -- TO TALK ABOUT
THESE BOARDS AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY SHOULD CONTINUE OR NOT AND
OF COURSE THESE BILLS ARE A
COLLECTION OF THE FEEDBACK THAT
WE RECEIVE FROM ALL THOSE
HEARINGS.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL SIX OH NINE
IS THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE
BUREAU OF SECURITY AND
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES.
THE BILL MERGES THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR FIND AND THEY
PRIVATE SECURITY FUND TO CREATE
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICIENCIES.
IT ALSO LINES THE BUREAU
STATUTES WITH THE PENAL CODE
RESTRICTING THE BUREAU TO ISSUE
IN FIREARM PERMITS INDIVIDUALS
WERE AT LEAST TWENTY ONE YEARS
OF AGE.
THE BILL PLACES RESPONSIBILITY
FOR COMPLETING VARIOUS TRAININGS.
ON THE GUARD REGISTRANTS INSTEAD
OF THEIR EMPLOYERS IN ORDER TO
BETTER ENSURE THAT SECURITY
GUARDS ARE PROPERLY TRAINED.
I AM NOT PROPOSING TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS IS THE YOU KNOW IT IN
THE ANALYSIS AND HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THEM AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'VE A A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DENNIS WEBER THROW A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS HERE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
AS THE CENTER OF MISTER CHAIR
WHICH LIKE CLOSE JUST TO SAY
THAT DIED ALL THESE SUNSET
ISSUES.
AND HEARINGS A LOT OF THE WORK'S
BEEN DONE BY OUR WONDERFUL
COMMITTEE STAFF I WANT TO THANK
THEM. FOR THE HARD WORK THAT YOU
DON'T SEE IN THE JUST THE
PRESENTATION OF THESE BILLS BUT
A LOT OF WORKERS IN DOING VALUE
WAITING THESE.
THESE BOARDS TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE DOING THEIR WORK
CORRECTLY THERE PROTECTING
CONSUMERS AND THAT -- THAT WE
ARE INFORMED AND HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DEBATE TO ANY CHANGES
THAT ARE NECESSARY SO THIS BILL
IS A CONTINUATION OF THAT WORK
IN THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE SO SET OF SENATOR HILL
MOVES THE BILL -- SECRETARY WILL
CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS
AS A MINUTE JUST SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE USER I'D CHANGE FIVE CHIANG
AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA [inaudible]
PAN WILK [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE HAVE SEVEN VOTES AND WE'RE
GONNA HOLD WILL OPEN TO ALLOW
MEMBERS TRACK ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT STEP IS JUST BE.
FOR TEN THANK YOU I BY SHOULD
CHIANG SB TEN IS THE SUNSET BILL
FOR THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD.
THIS BILL EXTENDS THAT SUNSET
DATA THE BOARD UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IN ADDITION A
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING CHANGES
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE BOARD TO
CONDUCT A STUDY OF THE CURRENT
CONTRACTORS BOND. TO EVALUATE IF
THE AMOUNT IS SUFFICIENT AND
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES INSTEAD OF
AUTHORIZES THE BOARD TO CHARGE A
FEE FOR VERIFYING THE
ELECTRICIANS CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS SPECIFIED IN THE
LABOR CODE.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT PERSONS
WITH UNSATISFIED JUDGMENTS ARE
NOT ABLE TO OBTAIN LICENSURE.
WITHOUT FIRST SATISFYING THAT
JUDGMENT.
REGARDING THE CONTRACTORS BOND
STUDY AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THIS
BILL.
REQUIRES THE BOARD TO CONCLUDE
THE STUDY BY.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE STUDY COMPLETED
SOONER AND WE'LL SEE
COMMANDMENTS REQUIRE MORE
EXPEDITIOUS TIME FRAME.
I'M REALLY THINKING ABOUT.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I HAVE WITH ME
MICHAEL -- JAM THAT SKI FROM THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASTRONAUT
ABOUT.
WITNESSES AND MARK.
I THE BOARD AS AN ADD
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET ON THE ON
THE BILL YEAH BUT WE ANTICIPATED
SUPPORT POSITION BY A COMMITTEE
IN MAY AND BY THE FULL BOARD GEN.
WHICH YOU MARKETS AND NOT BE
HAVE THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION OF
PLUMBING HEATING COOLING
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE AMERICAN FOR SPRINKLER
ASSOCIATION ALL IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE AND THE PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
BUSTLE MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU
LIKE FLOWS. THREE I'VE OF WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
SENATOR HILL HAS MOVED THE BILL.
OF SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE.
GLAZER AYE CHANGE.
FIVE AYE ARCHULETA HI FRAUDULENT
AYE DODD.
NOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL HILL AYE LEYVA.
FAN WILL [inaudible]
LOOK I WE HAVE FIVE SEVEN ZERO
WE'RE GONNA HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT UP I BELIEVE IS THE FINAL
BILL SB. SIX SEVENTEEN SEVEN
EASIEST ONE FOR LACK.
THE THANK YOU VICE CHAIR.
SB.
SEVEN SIX SEVENTEEN I WOULD
ALLOW PHARMACISTS IN A RETAIL
SETTING. TO SUPERVISE UP TO
THREE PHARMACY TECHNICIANS IF.
IF THEY MEET CERTAIN BENCHMARKS
AND HAVE THE APPROVAL OF THE
STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY. TWO BIG
REQUIREMENTS THERE HAVE TO MEET
CERTAIN BENCHMARKS AND OF THE
APPROVAL FROM THE STATE PART OF
BOARD OF PHARMACY.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS A SINGLE
PHARMACISTS TO SUPERVISE ONE
TECHNICIAN.
RIGHT ONE TECHNICIAN.
EACH ADDITIONAL PHARMACISTS IN A
GIVENLOCATION CAN SUPERVISE UP
TO TWO TECHNICIANS.
THESE RULES ARE OUTDATED.
AND LONG OVERDUE FOR A CHANGE.
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS AGO A TASK
FORCE OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF BOARDS OF
PHARMACY.
RECOMMENDED THE ELIMINATION OF
PHARMACIST TECHNICIAN RATIOS
THAT'S RIGHT TWENTY YEARS AGO.
THIS RECOMMENDATION WAS BASED ON
A STUDY OF THE PROFESSION WHICH
FOUND THAT PHARMACISTS.
WERE SPENDING MOST OF THEIR TIME
ON ADMINISTRATIVE TASKS.
THAT REQUIRED NEITHER THEIR
CLINICAL TRAINING.
NOR THEIR JUDGMENT.
SINCE THAT TIME MOST STATES HAVE
FOLLOWED THE RECOMMENDATION.
THEY HAVE EITHER NO LIMITS ON
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN.
RATIOS OR MUCH HIGHER LIMITS
THAN CALIFORNIA.
RATIOS OF THREE TO ONE FOUR TO
ONE AND EVEN SIX TO ONE ARE
COMMON.
BUT CALIFORNIA REMAIN STUCK IN
THE ERA.
WHEN THE USE OF PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS WAS STRICTLY LIMITED?
THERE IS NO SCIENTIFIC BASIS FOR
THIS LIMIT.
FORCES PHARMACIST PERFORM DUTIES
THAT DISTRACT THEM FROM THEIR
PRIMARY PURPOSE AND OF COURSE
THEIR EXPERTISE.
PHARMACY TECHNICIANS UNDERGO
SPECIALIZED TRAINING.
AT OUR LICENSE BY THE PHARMACY
BOARD TO PERFORM TASKS THAT
REQUIRE THE SUPERVISION.
BUT NOT THE DIRECT INVOLVEMENT
OF A LICENSED PHARMACIST.
SB SIX SEVENTEEN INCLUDES A
SERIES OF REQUIREMENTS. TO
ENSURE THAT TECHNICIANS ARE
PROPERLY TRAINED AND SUPERVISED.
AND THAT THEY PERFORM ONLY THOSE
DUTIES TO WHICH THEIR LICENSE.
AND NO MORE.
AN EXTRA MEASURE OF SAFETY.
THE HIGHER RATIOS WOULD BE
ALLOWED ONLY.
IN RETAIL PHARMACIES UNDER A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
WITH THE PHARMACIST.
THE PHARMACY TECHNICIANS ARE
BOTH.
THE PHARMACY WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
USE THESE RATIOS ONLY IF THEY
DEMONSTRATE TO THE PHARMACY
BOARD.
THAT THEY HAVE MET ALL OF THE
REQUIREMENTS.
INCLUDING SHOWING THAT THE
TECHNICIANS WILL BE WORKING.
UNDER THE QUOTE IMMEDIATE
PERSONAL SUPERVISION.
UNQUOTE OF THE PHARMACIST.
THIS MEASURE WILL PROVIDE RELIEF
FOR PHARMACISTS CREATE GOOD JOBS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH ONLY A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND TECHNICAL
TRAINING.
AND PROVIDE BETTER SERVICE TO
PATIENTS.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
PLEASED TO HAVE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY MARK JOHNSON.
CALIFORNIA LICENSE PHARMACIST
AND FORMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY.
AND JACQUI LEVEL.
PRESIDENT OF UFCW LOCAL.
EIGHT WHICH REPRESENTS ALL OF
THOSE OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
OF FOR THE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS.
THIS IS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
FIRST OF MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
ONE SEVEN MY NAME'S ACTUALLY
JACQUES GLOBAL NOT JACQUI LEVEL --
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE THE NAME SHOCK
HE ANSWERED ENDING STARTS WITH A
J. -- AND PRESIDENT OF YOUR CW A
GOLDEN STATE -- AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS.
ON AND ON BEHALF OF THE U. OF C.
W. WESTERN STATES COUNCIL.
WHICH HAS OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND MEMBERS ON I
WANT TO BEGIN BY FIRST THEY CAN
SENATOR GLAZER FOR AUTHORIZING
THIS IMPORTANT.
MEASURE IN THE STAFF FOR THEIR
ANALYSIS IN THE WORK ON THE BILL
IT IS IMPORTANT MEASURE I THINK
IT WAS ACTUALLY WONDERFUL JOB
SUMMARIZING WHY -- FOR SEVERAL
YEARS THE LEGISLATION HAS
CONSIDERED INCREASING THE
PHARMACIST PHARMACY TECHNICIAN
RATIO -- THE CHALLENGE OF SUCH
AN EXPANSION IS TO INSURE
PHARMACIST PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT
THE PROFESSIONAL SKILLS AS WELL
AS THE PATIENT'S HEALTH.
ARE ALL OPTIMIZED AND I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT THIS STRIKES THE
CORRECT BALANCE ON FIRST YEAR OF
CW REPRESENTS THOUSANDS OF FORMS.
A FOR SEVERAL YEARS OUR
PHARMACIST MEMBERS HAVE RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT WORKLOAD AND THE
INABILITY TO PROPERLY OVERSEE
THE DISPENSING AND HANDLING
PRESCRIBE MEDICATIONS.
ALONG WITH THEIR OTHER DUTIES.
AS A RESULT YOUR CW A SPONSORED
SB FOURTEEN FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
WIENER AND THE NO PHARMACIST
LEFT BEHIND BILL.
INCONSISTENT WITH THAT APPROACH
SB SIX SEVENTEEN PUSHERS
PHARMACIST OUR COMPANY READ BY
TRAINED IN FULLY LICENSED
PHARMACY TECHS.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED OF PHARMACY
TECHS UNDERGO EXTENSIVE
EDUCATIONAL AND JOB TRAINING AND
THEY MUST BE CERTIFIED TO WORK
ON OUR PHARMACIES.
AND THERE ARE ALWAYS UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A LICENSED
PHARMACIST.
ANA THIS BILL DOES NOT SEEK TO
SUPPLANT PHARMACIST.
INSTEAD SEEKS TO ASSIST
PHARMACIST IN LINE WITH MOST
OTHER STATES IN THE UNION.
SECOND I SUSPECT THE OPPOSITION
WILL RAISE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
REGARDING PATIENT SAFETY.
AND THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE IS A
PHARMACIST.
LET ME BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOES
NOT CHANGE THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE
FOR EITHER PHARMACIST OR
PHARMACY TECHS.
IN ADDITION THE PHARMACY BOARD
COMPOSED UP PHARMACIST IS
REQUIRED TO APPROVE ALL RATIO
INCREASES.
THEREBY PROTECTING PHARMACIST
AND PATIENTS ALIKE MOVE FINALLY
UFCW REPRESENTS BOTH PHARMACIST
AND PHARMACY TECHS WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL IS GOOD FOR ALL
OF OUR MEMBERS.
AND FOR ALL PATIENTS.
ON IN CONSISTENT WITH OUR
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES IN OUR
CORE MISSION.
SB SIX ONE SEVEN WILL CREATE.
GOOD MIDDLE CLASS JOBS IN AS YOU
ALL KNOW PARTICULARLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
THERE IS A GREAT SHORTAGE OF
GOOD PAYING SUSTAINABLE JOBS.
AN AYE VOTE. FOUR SIX ONE SEVEN
IS VOTE FOR GOOD JOBS.
JOBS WITH BENEFITS LIVABLE WAGES
RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
GOOD DROPS HONEST SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT -- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MARK JOHNSTON AND
I'VE BEEN A CALIFORNIA LICENSE
PHARMACIST FOR TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS.
AND FORMALLY I'VE SERVED AS AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A STATE
BOARD OF PHARMACY.
I AM CURRENTLY EMPLOYED AS A
SENIOR DIRECTOR WAS CVS HEALTH I
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ITS THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF SB.
SIX SEVENTEEN WHICH WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF LIMITING
RATIOS REQUIRE PHARMACIST TO
ENGAGE IN NON JUDGMENTAL TASKS
AS OPPOSED TO PROVIDING DIRECT
PATIENT CARE AT A TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIA FACES A PROVIDER
SHORTAGE.
PHARMACISTS SPEND AN AVERAGE OF
44% OF THEIR WORK DAY PERFORMING
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN LEVEL TASKS.
AS THE PHARMACIST A TECHNICIAN
RATIO INCREASES FORM SUSPEND
LAST TIME PRFORMING TECHNICIAN
DUTIES IN MORE TIME COMPLETING
PHARMACIST ONLY DUTIES.
LIMITED RATIOS LIMIT OUR
PHARMACISTS FROM PERFORMING THE
FULL ARRAY OF PHARMACISTS
COGNITIVE SERVICES THAT WOULD
INCREASE PATIENT SAFETY.
YOU'VE ENACTED LAWS THAT ALLOW
PHARMACISTS TO PERFORM SUCH
DUTIES AS HORMONAL CONTRACEPTION
TRAVEL MEDICATION IN THE LOCKS
OWN FURNISHING.
ADMINISTERING ADMINISTRATIONS IN
ADVANCE KAGHAN OF SERVICES SUCH
AS MTM THERAPY ENHANCE
COUNSELING WHEN DISPENSING
OPIOIDS AND ENTERING INTO A
COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE
AGREEMENTS WITH PHYSICIANS.
BUT PHARMACIST NEED MORE
TECHNICIAN HELP TO MAXIMIZE
THEIR TIME SPENT ON THESE
ACTIVITIES.
SB SIX SEVENTEEN ALLOWS FOR
PHARMACISTS TO DELIVER ON THE
PROMISE OF THE EXPANDED SCOPE OF
PRACTICE OF THIS BODY ADOPTED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN
ENABLING PHARMACIST A PRACTICE
AT THE TOP OF THEIR LICENSE.
AND FOCUS ON DIRECT PATIENT CARE.
THE NATIONAL LANDSCAPE REVEALS
AN OVERWHELMINGLY.
THE NATIONAL LANDSCAPE REVEALS%
AN OVERWHELMING SAFETY.
TRACK RECORD OF SUCCESS IN SHIFT
TOWARDS AN INCREASING.
IN SHIFT TOWARDS INCREASING IN
REMOVING TECHNICIAN OR
PHARMACIST RATIOS -- FEATURING
TWENTY ONE STATES THAT HAVE
ELIMINATED ARE NEVER SOUGHT TO
ESTABLISH A RATIO WITH-WASHINGTON EXPECTED TO BE THE
TWENTY SECOND STATE AFTER RULE
HEARING THIS FRIDAY.
I ANSWER STATES WITH OVER A
CENTURY OF SUCCESS -- IN
ALLOWING PHARMACIST TO DETERMINE
AND MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE
SUPERVISION OVER SUPPORT
PERSONNEL THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF BOARDS OF
PHARMACY REMOVED ALL RACIAL
RESTRICTIONS FROM THE MODEL
STATE.
PHARMACY PRACTICE ACTIN RULES IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE SO FAR IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN SIX
BOARDS OF PHARMACY OF VOTED TO
INCREASE OR OF ENACTED INCREASES
AND RATIOS RANGING FROM.
FOUR TO ONE TO EIGHT TO ONE
WHICH WILL EFFECTIVELY LEAVE ONE
STATED A TWO TO ONE RATIO AND
CALIFORNIA ALONE IS THE ONLY
STATE WITH A ONE TO ONE RATIO.
I WILL ALSO NOTE THE NOTE STATE
IS EVER VOTED TO DECREASE THE
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN RATIO.
I WAS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE WHEN WE
RAISED OUR PHARMACIST A
TECHNICIAN RATIO FROM.
THREE TO ONE TO SIX TO ONE THE
BOARD DID NOT RECEIVE ANY FORMAL
COMPLAINTS FROM PHARMACISTS
TECHNICIANS OR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC.
REGARDING THE INCREASED RATIO.
UPON THE CHANGES SIX TO ONE I
SENT INSPECTORS TO OBSERVE
ACTUAL COMMUNITY PHARMACY RATIO
INCREASES AND WE RARELY SAW
RATIO ABOVE FOUR TO ONE UTILIZED --
THIS IS A REMINDER TO THIS BODY
THAT WE ARE AN ACTING.
NOW WHAT WE ARE IN ACTING WITH
SB SIX SEVENTEEN IS STRICTLY
VOLUNTARY.
WHAT WE DID SEE WAS AN INCREASE
IN EXPANDED PHARMACIST SERVICES
OFFERED A LAST YEAR THE STATE
REMOVE THE RATIO SO THE
PHARMACIST COULD CONCENTRATE ON
THE FULL ARRAY OF PATIENTS
SERVICES?
THIS DECISION.
WAS INFLUENCED BY PHIL BURGESS
LONGSTANDING PRESIDENT OF THE
ILLINOIS BOARD OF PHARMACY WHO
STATED.
THE ILLINOIS BOARD STRONGLY
BELIEVES THAT THE CURRENT
ILLINOIS PHARMACY REGULATIONS
WHICH DO NOT HAVE A TECHNICIAN
RATIO RESTRICTION.
ARE APPROPRIATE AND THAT THEY
ARE IN NO WAY JEOPARDIZE THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF THE
CITIZENS OF ILLINOIS.
ON BEHALF OF CVS HEALTH WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS LONG
OVERDUE IT'S BEEN MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS SINCE CALIFORNIA
INCREASE THE PHARMACIST A
TECHNICIAN RATIO.
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS SB
SIX SEVENTEEN AND I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GET YOUR CHANCE RIGHT WHEN SHE
SAID.
GET TO SEE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
UP FOR SITE MONEY DEVIATE A
LITTLE FROM MY PREPARED REMARKS
IT'S GREAT TO SEE A FAMILIAR
FACE IN THE VICE CHAIR.
ARE TWO CD SHARE THE SAME SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO DUNBAR MOMENT.
AND I'M SURE IN ADDITION TO
SHARING A SCHOOL DISTRICT WE
SURE THING WITHOUT -- MY NAME IS
LARGELY I AM PRESIDENT OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
SPARTACIST ASSOCIATE YOUR HEAD
PHARMACIST OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MORE IMPORTANTLY.
I'D BEEN A PRACTICING PHARMACIST
FOR THE LAST THIRTY YEARS.
I'M HERE TO OPPOSE SB SIX
SEVENTEEN BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED
THAT PATIENT SAFETY IS AT RISK.
WELL THERE ARE FEW STUDIES ON
THE DISCUSSION OF RATIOS AND
STATES HAVE DIFFERENT RATIOS.
I DO KNOW ONE THING.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER IN
PATIENT AND WORKER PROTECTIONS.
SB SIX SEVENTEEN IS NOT
REFLECTIVE OF THOSE CALIFORNIA
VALES.
PHARMACISTS ARE THE LAST LINE OF
DEFENSE WHEN IT COMES TO
DETECTING AND PREVENTING
MEDICATION ERRORS.
AN AREA WHERE STUDIES DO EXIST.
IN THE UNITED STATES ALONE
700-022-29000 PATIENTS PER YEAR
DIE AS A RESULT OF A MEDICATION
ERROR.
IN AN ARTICLE PUBLISHED JUST
THIS YEAR AND CITED ON THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF HEALTH
WEBSITE APPROPRIATELY ENTITLED.
MEDICATION ERRORS AUTHORS SURE
BACK IN TERRICK NOTED THAT A
DISTRACTION ANY DISTRACTION
ACCOUNTS FOR NEARLY 75% OF ALL
MEDICATION ERRORS. ONE OF THEIR
SINGULAR RECOMMENDATIONS IS TO
APPROACH EVERY PRESCRIPTION WITH
CAUTION.
WITH THE CHANGE THE PHARMACIST
TO PHARMACY TECHNICIAN ISSUE.
FARMS IS WILL BE FACED WITH
INCREASED DISTRACTIONS BY
SUPERVISING MORE AND MORE
TECHNICIANS.
INSTEAD OF CONSULTING WITH
PATIENTS AND FOLKSY FOCUSING
SINGULARLY ON PREVENTING
MEDICATION ERRORS.
MANY OF US HAVE WORKED IN CVS
AND OTHER RETAIL STORES.
WE HAVE ALWAYS FACE MANY
CHALLENGES SPECIFICALLY AROUND
STUFFING.
PHARMACIES ARE HIGH PACE HIGHLY
STRESSFUL WORK ENVIRONMENTS.
AND WHILE OF FOREIGN TECH AND
CLERKS.
CAN BE HELPFUL TO ASSIST.
NOTHING REPLACES THE SKILLS AND
JUDGEMENT OF ANOTHER PHARMACIST.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS IN
DISCUSSION REGARDING THE RACIAL
PROPOSAL WE HAVE BEEN TOLD IN
MEETINGS.
THAT IS CHEAPER TO HIRE PHARMACY
TECHS INSTEAD OF THE PHARMACISTS
[inaudible]
CURRENT LAW.
WITH RESPECT.
ALLOWS PHARMACIES TO ACCESS
THREE TECHNICIANS THAT IS WITH
TO FARMS DOES NOT SOLELY A ONE
TO ONE RATIO.
BUT THE CVS IS OF THE WORLD
WOULD NOT DO IT BECAUSE IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE.
THERE IS NO.
NO HIGHER PRICE TO PAY FOR
PATIENT SAFETY.
YOUR SAFETY THE CITY OF YOUR
PARENTS GRANDPARENTS AND
CHILDREN.
THAT'S WHY SB SIX SEVENTEEN WILL
ULTIMATELY HURT OUR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS --
PAT WHALEN HERE ON BEHALF OF
UNITED NURSES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA UNION HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS -- I JUST WANT TO
FOCUS ON A LITTLE BIT OF THE
PRACTICAL IMPLEMENTATION ASPECTS
OF THIS BILL -- THE SENATOR
MENTIONED -- THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING COMPONENT BUT HERE'S
HOW THAT WORKS IT ALLOWS THE
PHARMACY TO ENTER INTO A CBA
WITH SAY FOR EXAMPLE THE
PHARMACY TECHNICIANS.
ABOUT CHANGING DRAMATICALLY THE
WORKING CONDITIONS OF THE
PHARMACISTS.
WITHOUT ANY CONSULTATION OR
INPUT FROM THE PHARMACISTS THEY
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A CPA WITH
THE PHARMACISTS AT ALL.
AND THAT'S THAT'S A VERY
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT IN THE AREA
OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING --
BECAUSE YOU INTERJECT A DYNAMIC
WHERE THE PHARMACY EMPLOYER.
IS ENTERING INTO A CPA WITH A
THIRD PARTY -- IN WHICH THE
PRINCIPALLY AFFECTED FOLKS IN
THIS CASE THE PHARMACISTS HAVE
NO INPUT -- AND IT'S IF THAT WAS
ALL IT DID.
THAT WOULD BE BAD ENOUGH -- BUT
IN OUR VIEW IT'S EVEN WORSE
BECAUSE YOU'RE TAKING A A
PATIENT SAFETY ISSUE AS A MISTER
LILLY JUST EXPLAIN AND PUTTING
IT INTO THE VAGARIES OF THE
COLLECTIVE.
BARGAINING -- SITUATION WITHOUT
ANY INPUT FROM THE PHARMACIST
WHO IS THE LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
WHOSE LICENSES ON THE LINE AND
WHO IS THE LAST LINE OF DEFENSE.
FOR PATIENT SAFETY SO FOR THAT
REASON WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
AND OTHER WITNESSES IN OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS BRIAN
NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES WON'T
BELABOR THE POINT -- JUST HERE
IN SUPPORT OF OUR A DEDICATED
PHARMACIST.
AT THE UNITED NURSES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA -- ND IS STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
THE OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WHEN IS FOR DISEASE AMASS STUFF
RAP AT UNIKOM ALSO AVERAGED
PHARMACISTS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL?
THANK YOU ALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SUCH
AN ANTI MONEY ANTENNA CLINICAL-PHARMACIST HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS.
I VOICE MY STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL -- IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
PATIENTS AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO LEAD THE WAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRêN SMITH ON
BEHALF OF RITE AID PHARMACIES A
UNIONIZE PHARMACY IN CALIFORNIA
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX WERE
OPPOSED.
PETER CALLOUS IN ON BEHALF OF
WALGREENS WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT -- WE
UNFORTUNATELY MUST ALSO OPPOSE
BASED UPON THE LIMITED
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING COMPONENT
OF THE RATIO CHANGE.
I'M CHAIR MEMBERS TOWARDS NORM
APPLE WALMART AGAIN JUST LIKE
PETER SAID.
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR'S INTENT I
AGREE WITH THE THE WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
HAVE TO TAKE ISSUE WITH THE FACT
THAT THERE IS NO SCIENTIFIC
BASIS TO SHOW THAT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT SOMEHOW
MAKES THIS BILL SAY.
FOR US RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
MANAGER MEMBERS I'M DIRECT MARIO
BEHALF ALBERTSON'S SAFEWAY A
LITTLE OUT OF ORDER APOLOGIZES
AND MEETING WITH ANOTHER MEMBER
BY THE STARTED.
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND SUPPORT SENATOR
GLAZER IN THIS BILL.
AND JUST WANTED TO REGISTER OUR
SUPPORT DIDN'T GET A LETTER AND
ON TIME BUT WE WILL BE
FORTHCOMING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WHY DO I'M I'M GONNA SHARE MY
OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE OF
DECADES AGO I I WORKED IN A
PHARMACY BEFORE?
AND I HAVE WITNESSED -- YOU KNOW
THE WORK OF PHARMACISTS AND
PHARMACY TECHNICIANS AND I TELL
YOU I ALSO HAVE FRIENDS WHO ARE
PHARMACISTS AND THEY WOULD
ALWAYS COMPLAIN TO ME.
THAT MOST OF THEIR TIME IS SPENT
ON COUNTING PILLS DISPENSING AND
NOT REALLY.
ON WHAT THEY'RE TRAINED FOR
WHICH IS TO PROVIDE PATIENT CARE
AND I'VE HEARD THAT TIME AND%
TIME AGAIN.
AND I I WILL BE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
THIS BILL IN THE FUTURE OR A
SUBSEQUENT BILL THAT WOULD
EXPAND IT TO PHARMACIES THAT ARE
NOT COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPLORE AS WELL SO.
WITH THAT -- DO WE HAVE MOTION.
A SENATOR ARCHULETA.
WE HAVE MOSTLY FROM CENTER
ARCHULETA SECRETARY WILL CALL
THEM I'M SORRY I'M SO SORRY.
MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
LOSE YEAH THANK YOU OFFER THAT
TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR THIS
BILL.
THERE'S A REASON THAT CALIFORNIA
REMAINS LAST ON THIS RATIO ISSUE --
LOGIC WOULD SAY COMBINED -- THE
OTHER STATES DIDN'T -- RAISE IT
TO IN DANGER PATIENT HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
NOW.
HI IT'S ABOUT HOW YOU TAKE THESE
HIGHLY TRAINED PHARMACISTS AND
USE THEIR TIME APPROPRIATELY SO
IT DOES THE PAST. FOR PATIENTS.
I CERTAINLY DOES THE BEST TO
LOWER HEALTHCARE COSTS WHEN
APPROPRIATE BUT NOTHING'S MORE
IMPORTANT PATIENT PATIENT SAFETY.
BUT THINK ABOUT IT YOU'RE YOU'RE
A HIGHLY TRAINED PHARMACISTS.
AND YOUR SPIRIT SPENDING YOUR
WHOLE DAY DOING WHAT.
TALKING TO DOCTORS OFFICES TO
TRY TO GET THROUGH SITTING ON
HOLD.
COUNTING PILLS SHEET WHICH CAN
BE VERY IMPORTANT BUT BUT THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE HIGHLY
TRAINED TO DO THAT TOO WITH THAT
WITH THE DIFFERENT EDUCATION --
THAT -- CAN DO THAT PERFECTLY
APPROPRIATELY AND AND KEEP THIS
IN MIND ALL THIS IS DONE UNDER
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY.
ALL MADE UP OF PHARMACISTS OKAY
WHO ARE THERE TO PROTECT THE THE
PATIENT SAFETY AND ALL THAT THEY
DO AND IF YOU LOOK ON PAGE FIVE
OF THE BILL IT.
IT GOES TO ALL THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT THESE TECHNICIANS HAVE TO
FOLLOW THERE'S NINE OF THEM GOES
TO EVERYONE OF THE TRAINING.
AND SUPERVISION REQUIREMENTS OF
THESE TECHNICIANS IT'S EXHAUSTED --
AND AND IT'S APPROPRIATE.
BECAUSE IT IS IT IS ABOUT A
PATIENT SAFETY.
BUT THERE'S A REASON THAT I SAID
AS I SAID AT THE BEGINNING HERE
THAT WE'RE NOT ABLE TO MAKE
PROGRESS BECAUSE PEOPLE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE IT ALL ONE SIDE OR
THE OTHER SIDE.
AND THIS TRIES TO FIND THAT
MIDDLE GROUND SO WE CAN MAKE
PROGRESS ON THIS THERE'S MORE.
TO BE DONE IN THIS AREA I'M I'M
COMMITTED TO TRYING TO FIND
COMMON GROUND IF WE CAN'T AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD IF IT MOVES
FORWARD.
BUT WE HAVE TO TAKE THAT STEP
AHEAD.
AND DIED SO FOR THOSE WHO SAY I
WISH SHE WOULD DO THIS I WISH
YOU WOULDN'T DO THAT.
NOT ALL THAT I WANT THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE NO PROGRESS.
AND THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO TRY TO
FIND THAT THAT THAT THAT PATHWAY
FOR YOU WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR HIGH.
I JUST OF ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION WE BE TAKING THE A
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT YES
YES MA'AM.
WITH THAT US SECRETARY WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GLAZER HI THERE I
CHIANG I THINK I ARE TO LET US.
OR TO LET AYE DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL [inaudible]
WELL NOW [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
PAN.
WILK.
WILK NOW.
SO IT'S FIVE TWO TWO WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR UPSET
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M
GONNA KEEP.
TURN THE MEETING OVER BACK OVER
TO THE CHAIR
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA WHAT WE'RE
GONNA.
OPEN THE ROLE IN THE BILLS THAT
WE LEFT ON CALL I THINK WE ONLY
COMPLETED A COUPLE COUPLE BUT SO
FOR THOSE MEMBERS WHO ARE
PRESENT AND HAVE ABILITY BUT
LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO COME BACK.
SO WE CAN FINISH OUR WORK HERE
TODAY.
LET'S START WITH ITEM ONE SB
THREE FIFTEEN BY HERTZBERG.
WHICH I WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTES FIVE TWO ZERO CHANG.
CHANG I'D DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI HI
PAN.
CAN I BY THAT BILLS OUTSIDE
[inaudible] NINE ZERO ALL RIGHT
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB THREE THREE
NINE BY JONES OF THE SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT BOTH FIVE ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI.
CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D DOT.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE PAN [inaudible]
AND I ARE THE BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO ITEM THREE SB THREE
SEVEN SEVEN BY MCGUIRE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS D. PASSED THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FROM BOTH
SEVEN ZERO CHANGE [inaudible]
CHIANG I PAN.
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP
FOUR SEVEN SIX BY CENTER STONE
THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING I
CHIANG.
CHING I DODD.
DODD AYE PAN [inaudible]
AND I ARE THE BILLS OUT -- NINE
ZERO ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB FIVE
FIVE SIX BY SENATOR PAN
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE KERN VOTES EIGHT ZERO
CHAIR VOTING HI.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE.
OUR THAT VOTE AT THAT DEALS OUT.
SEVEN TWO ZERO NINE ZERO ITEM
SIX SB FIVE C. NOTES THAT COULD
LEAD TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO THOSE ARE THREE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE CALL THE
ROLL AND CHIANG.
CHIANG I DODD.
DODD EYES GALGIANI GALGIANI I'D
PAN TONIGHT PAN AYE.
HI CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED.
NINE ZERO OUR NEXT UP ITEM EIGHT
SB SIX OH SIX BY GLAZER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL MISSION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BUT SEVEN ZERO CHAIR READING I
LEYVA.
HI LEYVA AYE PAN.
CAN I AT BILLS OUT NINETY ZERO
ITEM NINE SB SIX OH SEVEN BY
GLAZER SECRETARY CALDERON MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO YOU'RE READING I
LEYVA [inaudible]
I PAN.
I BILLS OUT ZERO ITEM TEN SB SIX
SO EIGHT BY GLAZER THE SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
DESCENT APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FROM ABOUT SEVEN TO ZERO TO
WRITING AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN PAN AYE.
THE BILL IS AT NINE ZERO ITEM
ELEVEN SB SIX OH NINE BY GLAZER.
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
JUST SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT BUT SEVEN TO
ZERO TO READING HI LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN.
PAN AYE THE BILL IS AT NINE ZERO
ITEM TWELVE SB SIX TEN BY GLAZER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL MISSION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO CHAIR READING
HI.
LEYVA.
THIS IS A SIX TEN A LICENSING
REGULATIONS SENSE OF BILL LEYVA
I'D PAN [inaudible]
AND I THAT BILLS AT NINE ZERO SB --
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SIX SEVENTEEN
BY GLAZER THE SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BUT FIVE TO TO CHAIR VOTING ALLY.
VICE CHAIR READING I'M
[inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
PAN.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT BILLS OUT.
FIVE TWO TWO NEXT ITEM FOURTEEN
SB SIX TO SEVEN BY CENTER
GALGIANI SECRETARY CALLED A
LITTLE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
THAT SEVEN TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING
AYE.
LEYVA.
I PAN PAN AYE BILLS OUT -- NINE
ZERO I SHOW FILE ITEM FIFTEEN IS
ALREADY OUT RUBIO -- ITEM
SIXTEEN SB SIX FIVE THREE BY
CENTER CHIANG.
MOTION AS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE IS. EIGHT ZERO TO
READING AYE LEYVA.
LIVE BY.
THE BILL'S AT NINE ZERO ITEM
SEVENTEEN SB SIX FIVE EIGHT BY
SENATOR BRADFORD SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
IT'S AN APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT BUT SEVEN ZERO CHAIR
VOTING HI CHIANG.
KAI CHIANG I PAN.
PAN AYE ARE THE BILL'S AT NINE
ZERO ITEM EIGHTEEN SENATE BILL
SIX NINE SEVEN BY SENATOR COPIER.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
KERR BUT SEVEN ZERO SURE VOTING
I'D DODD [inaudible]
I PAN.
I BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO ITEM
NINETEEN SB SEVEN THREE SIX BY
CENTER ON BURKE AT SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL MISSION IS
O PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERN
VOTES EIGHT ZERO TERRE VOTING HI.
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI I'VE AT BILLS AT NINE
ZERO NEXT ONE IS ITEM TWENTY SB
SEVEN THREE EIGHT BY CENTER
HUESO SECOND OF THAT WAS A
CONSENT ITEM THAT'S OUT.
FINALLY ITEM TWENTY ONE AT
THAT'S ALSO NO WAY OUT NO.
THIRTY EIGHT WAS OUT
[inaudible] TWENTY ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY WITHOUT ALREADY ARE A
GREAT AND TWENTY ONE WAS ON THE
CONSENT COUNT OUR THAT COMPLETES
OUR WORK MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE TODAY AND WITH
THAT.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED